Hey everybody!
I wasn't ready!
What the heck?
I did a countdown!
You had to be the most ready because you started before any of us really.
I was like, Doki, no please, I'm not ready.
And she was like, I don't give a shit.
Oh yeah, yeah, fuck you.
This is my stream now.
We're live!
We're live now!
Fuck you!
Stop being bully.
Don't bully Squirt, stop.
No, no, no, we're here to bully Surefour.
The only non-Btuber here.
Surefour, have you checked your balls?
That's not bullying.
Balls check?
Wait, you want me to start talking about touching my balls?
I don't think so.
I'm the one that's being tame here.
I am suppressing myself.
You want me to take my balls out?
Woah!
This is a medical check here, Surefour.
I've been talking about my headlight for like five steps ahead.
I've been talking about my constipation for a while, like now it's your turn.
Hey, go for it.
This is a health stream now.
This is a health check.
We want to make sure everybody is medically okay.
There is nothing you can say that would make me uncomfortable.
I'm ironed by this.
To be fair...
Do it!
I dare you!
Alright, Lily, do it!
Say something, but don't go for European!
Uh...
Anal warts.
What?
Yeah, what about it?
Got them all.
You got some of those?
Oh, hello.
What about it, Lily?
Why did that...
What is your first thing you want to say?
Do you have something to tell us?
I don't know.
I just figured...
Okay, I guess we're not really on the same wavelength here.
Okay, I will...
I just thought that maybe, you know, maybe you just coincidentally googled for absolutely no reason whatsoever what it's like to have them.
Why did you google anal warts?
Can you explain for me what it might be like to have them?
I wasn't interested at all about my anal lumps.
I wasn't seeing any suspicious growth.
It's alright.
I hope you started at all and not images.
How do you even see them?
Yeah, how do you...
Oh, wait, are they inside?
Wait...
Maybe I was just investigating my health.
That's the blowhole blast.
Can you buy one of those doctor equipments that's got a camera and like a tube?
Oh, no!
Wait, Loki, that would be so fun.
That's what you do with the prize money.
What the fuck?
How did you know?
That would be so fun.
Are you gonna make a stream just dedicated to that?
I need to defend.
Okay, okay, okay.
But if you had one of those, which hole would you stick it in first?
I think... I think nose would be so funny.
Nose?
The nose?
Yeah.
The nose.
Why?
Cause like, it's like weird and...
Okay, maybe that's just me, but if you stick it up your butt, it's like, what do you expect?
Like, you kinda know what to expect.
But like the nose, it's like, it's full of like hairs and like maybe it's tiny, but maybe it's also just like a fat boogie.
Like, it's full of surprises, man!
If the camera's small enough, you can stick it down the edge of your eye.
Oh!
Oh, good!
Good guys!
Wow!
Straight in the slime, no thanks.
I can look for my last eyelashes.
Oh my god.
You know when you have eyelashes and your eye, you rub it and suddenly it's gone, it's like, well, that's just in the back of my eye forever now.
Dude, I never thought about it.
Where do they go?
Right, but if one doesn't go, they manage to disappear.
I feel like it's biodegradable, isn't it?
They get disintegrated.
Oh, boy!
It's like when there's bugs that randomly fly into your eyes.
No!
They just get disintegrated.
Oh, boy!
Is that real?
Guys, can we...
Bugs fly into people's eyes all the time.
Okay, I had it a lot when I was bicycling a lot.
I was like, little fucking bugs in my eyes.
That's just a nature massage.
I don't want them to touch my eyeballs.
How did we get here?
How the fuck did we...
Guys, how about we discuss...
We got here because you tried to make me uncomfortable.
Let's talk about the strats that we're gonna be doing for day two, everybody.
That's boring.
Why don't we tell our chat what we're planning on doing for day two, everyone?
Our chat is just like, I can't believe I got up early for this.
My condolences.
But you kind of knew what you were signing up for.
Don't pretend.
Come on.
Look at this.
Look at these people.
Look at them.
What do you mean, these people?
Yeah, what do you mean?
I don't know.
Or they're saying Lily.
These people.
One of us is a literal big bugger.
What the hell?
How do you say that about Dokie?
That's so rude.
That's discrimination.
Live on stream?
I can't believe Shidelyv2 has been cancelled.
Oh my...
Again.
I couldn't see the Twitlengers.
I can sense them.
You can't.
Oh my god.
Anyways, so our jobs today, Shorifor is our, as always, our power leveler.
He is the tank of the group.
He's gonna be catching all the hard pals.
I will be focused on the medium pals and also catching all the ingredients for the food.
Lily is the ballmaster.
I'm the ballmaster.
She's gonna be the ballmaster and Peepee will be the basemaster.
So, and she's gonna be working on doing all the base stuff.
And so yeah, that is our job.
At the two hour mark, we're gonna be doing dungeon runs.
And then one hour mark, we're gonna be petting some pals.
So just to make sure we all remember that.
Wait, when are we doing the, are we doing the faction towers too as well?
After the dungeons?
Yeah.
Should we do them as a group or singular?
I mean, if you can do it singular, do it.
I mean, the first one should be easy as fuck.
Yeah, I can do this first one.
I can focus on the first tower.
Honestly, I can do that right now.
I don't know, cause it's so low leveled.
Aye.
Yeah, and then we can figure out the other towers.
After, on the two hour mark when we're doing the dungeons.
Oh yeah, so anyway, that's our plan.
We actually have a plan this time.
Well, we.
We're not going in super blind.
Alright guys, I believe in us to be still top ten after this.
Oh yeah, easy, easy.
Yeah, we didn't do any of the global points, so that's the great part.
Yeah, cause we were just power leveling.
Trusting the process.
Just trust the process.
Also like, we know that legendaries are like 360 points.
But Surefour was like, there's no way we can get it.
Maybe it's just cause I was playing the game with the hardest difficulty.
Maybe it's easier now.
Maybe.
Oh, we check try it later.
Like at the one hour mark.
And see if we can catch any legendaries.
Also, the admin wants to see your world settings.
Oh.
Okay.
They're asking for it.
Oh yeah, we're supposed to start in one minute.
Like scrolling and shit.
Oh wait, no, they're starting the checks in one minute.
Alright, alright.
Cool, cool, cool.
I'm scrolling up and down.
He's trying his best.
I think we should figure out the breeding stuff too.
Like if we have the palace for it.
When we're in.
Oh my goodness, Peepee, I just saw your freaking Twitch Rivals image.
Wait, that's so cute.
What?
Wait, that's so adorable.
I also drew Surefour.
Wait, what was it?
Wait, you drew this?
The character's name is like Chisumi?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Chisumi.
My alt account in Overwatch.
Ah, sorry I doxxed you on me.
Oh, that's fine.
You know, he has a VTuber model too.
Yeah, he's a VTuber.
But he refused to be a VTuber.
I'm used to it once.
He's too scared.
Hard time VTuber.
He's a coward.
I'm not scared.
I'm not a coward.
Alright, turn it on then.
Why don't you turn it on?
Oh, that chat.
Your streamer's a VTuber.
You think I have my fucking shit set up right now?
You know what?
Chat, Surefour chat, how do you feel that your streamer's a part-time VTuber?
Yeah.
How do you feel about that?
Are you expecting me to like respond for you?
Like you're asking my...
Are you like looking at it right now?
Like what's going on here?
I think I can start the world, right?
Your chat does not...
We need the code.
Yeah, we need the code.
Wait, you're already a furry?
When were you a furry?
I was never a furry.
Then why is your chat saying you're a furry?
They call me Scaly because I like dragons.
Don't hide the truth.
No, I am.
Embrace your truth.
Embrace who you are.
Don't be scared.
Listen, I'm one of the most truthful people you'll ever meet.
If I was a furry, I would just say it.
Yeah, but isn't a Scaly also a furry?
Yeah.
But I'm not a Scaly either.
Hmm.
So you're trying to say your chat is lying?
I just like dragon... Listen, so dragon girls and cat girls are not on the furry scale.
Yes they are!
How are they not on the furry scale?
No they aren't.
Ears and tail is fine.
Everything else, that's when you start getting furry.
Hmm.
There's like...
But you like dragons?
It's like a degree.
It's like a spectrum.
Yeah, dragons are sick.
It's like a furry spectrum.
Dragon Ds?
Spectrum.
You think you're so smart.
What's 25 plus 25, huh?
Shepard, where the fuck is our world code?
It's not a global achievement.
I don't have to laugh.
What's 25 plus 25, huh?
Is that a trick question?
No, it's a math question.
No way.
Nuh uh.
Not gonna trick me into doing math on a Saturday.
Just establish.
Damn.
Alright, I'm joining the lobby.
I'm in the world.
I'm in the world too.
That's not answering my math question.
Yeah, why didn't you answer his math question?
Are you too stupid?
That's fucked up, Dokie.
What?
I'm asking a question!
That's fucked up.
I was just asking a question!
I'm just repeating what you said, but like in different... I'm rewording it so I don't please your eyes.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Girl, stop.
Guys, you're supposed to play a video game.
Oh, wait.
They said don't do anything.
We're not actually doing anything.
We're not allowed to do anything.
But, but, but, like, we're about to get invaded.
Wait, wait, wait, what do we do?
What do we do?
We're gonna get invaded.
Tell the admins we're gonna literally get invaded.
We're not gonna get invaded.
We are being invaded.
Help!
We have to fight back.
We can't, we can't really...
It's a... wait, but it's the Tokos!
Close the server.
I know, we need Tokos too.
We already killed them.
Wait, never mind.
They're on their way.
They said, fuck away.
Close the server.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Wait, I thought they said everything was good.
I'm in green balls.
I thought you said once you checked in you can start the server.
Yeah.
I also thought once you checked in...
I thought so too.
They were like, okay, just log in but don't leave.
Like, what?
Server's closed anyways.
Problem solved.
We solved it, guys!
We, we closed.
We closed the server.
Did they check the settings?
Oh no, we're in trouble.
I don't know, man.
We didn't do anything.
We didn't catch the last but not clear.
I thought we were in the green to start.
We were shocked.
Wait, they were like, no, they're giving conflicting information.
The admins don't even know.
Listen, all I'm saying is, he was saying, please wait for our communication.
The last time he didn't told us, we got checked and we started late.
That's all.
And then, but then the person beneath it was like, now if you're being raided, you can fight.
So technically, we don't need to close the server.
Who's right?
Who's the alpha admin?
You're being assaulted.
All right, tell me, now we can start.
Now we can start the world.
Oh, now we can.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
All right.
It's the same code.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, it made a big difference.
No session found, though.
I need the code.
We need the code.
Yeah, no session found because I'm starting it, motherfucker.
Man, now we're late again.
No, we have a set.
No, no, no.
No, we have three minutes left.
Why did I still start?
You don't have timer yet.
We can do it.
We just can't catch them.
I... chill.
Well, the raid's gone because I power gamed.
Okay, nice.
Oh.
Nice.
Is it the same code?
We exploited.
We didn't exploit.
We legally exploited.
I exploited.
Legally.
It's a legal exploit.
It's a feature.
It was...
Yeah, oh, you're right.
It's a feature.
Well, technically, it was a legal exploit because we illegally started but then legally turned it off.
Wait, so can we join?
Yeah, we can.
Yeah, now we should...
My game crashed.
Move down.
That's karma already?
No way.
Move down.
We're being punished.
We did it.
Hey, I just leveled up from doing nothing.
Let's go.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
I'm joining back again.
Don't worry.
Come back in.
Keep telling...
You guys are not allowed to touch anything when you look.
Yeah.
We're just here to...
Unless we get raided, then we can kill but not...
Then we can fight.
All right.
I'm back in.
It's okay.
I didn't have my gear.
I hope the Toko's come back.
Oh, boy.
We need them.
Why is everybody...
Wait, everyone is sick.
What did you do to our paths?
Everyone's sick.
They have terrible living conditions.
What happened?
Who the fuck did this to our paths?
What do you mean terrible living conditions?
They have fluffy beds.
Okay, look.
I'm not...
We have two fluffy beds.
I am not...
And no fucking fountain.
I'm not in charge...
I'm not in charge of the power base.
Who the fuck did this to them?
Look.
I was busy.
Dude, our cat fucking bitch is stuck.
Dude, I'm stuck, Kim.
We're not allowed to help her yet.
It's all right.
I'm getting rid of the beds today.
I'll help her.
We just have to watch her struggle for now.
Our cat just is stuck.
We're unable to do anything legally.
We actually...
We need to make the giant pell bed today.
Really, really quickly.
Really, really right after this.
All right.
That is your job.
I'm gonna...
We need to figure out what we need.
Okay.
We need a Massandra for the breeding and also the...
I mean, you got the Nubus stuff all done, right?
We're good with the Nubus breeding, right?
Probably.
I need to check gender.
All right.
And then we just need a Massandra.
I have a male Pen King.
I have a female Bushi, but I need a male Pen King.
That's the problem.
I'm gonna get the Nubus.
We got it.
Yeah.
I caught one from the boss.
I'm pretty sure he's a guy.
I need the bee.
Yeah.
I can put that in too.
So we can get some honey.
I'll put the bee and the Pen King in the thing.
Who do I take out though?
Does anybody have the cow as well?
I have a cow.
Oh, then we can put that in too.
Oh yeah.
I've got a cow as well.
Where's the fucking...
Where was the...
The doc, the Google...
Doc posting again?
Oh, let me give it to you.
He's like resending it.
Wait, are you talking about for the...
Which Google doc?
The achievement?
Which one?
Resend or...
Okay.
I can give you that.
Yay.
You can start.
Okay.
We can start now.
We can start.
Yay.
Let's go.
I can put...
I have a cow.
Just take out whatever you don't need and I'll fill a slot with the cow.
Okay.
I'm putting in my male Pen King.
Wait, I've got a cow.
I'll just throw the cow in.
Okay.
Perfect.
All right.
Where the fuck did I put the penguin?
We also need to get tomato seeds, lettuce seeds, and I think we probably already have wheat seeds.
I'm getting rid of the...
Do I get rid of the chick monk?
Which one do I get rid of?
Chipmunk is worthless.
You can get rid of it.
Okay.
And then I'll put in the G-Guard.
Where the fuck is this fucker?
I don't know.
I caught you.
Well, they're like sleeping.
So they're like trying to move in.
Wait.
Who do you want me to get rid of?
I don't know which one to get rid of.
Oh my god.
We can get rid of the cat.
Cat-tiva or whatever.
Yeah.
I got it.
Put it in.
Okay.
All right.
Let me fix my stuff.
Once it's daytime...
I need the Google Doc.
I put it in the chat.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
I'm freezing to death.
My loot is in Brazil.
Oh shit.
Welcome to Brazil.
I died at the fucking ball as soon.
Okay.
I'm gonna put all this stuff away.
Let's see.
Actually, I think it's worth getting.
Did I have anything?
No.
Oh yeah.
Remember to make more furnaces.
We need to make more furnaces.
See.
I'm about to just make a bunch of furnaces.
I'm gonna make a bunch of iron on this island over here.
I'm stealing this ball.
Thank you.
I have a lot of mats if people want.
I'm gonna make another chest to put these mats in.
I think I'm gonna make a chest to sort stuff a bit more efficiently because it'll take so much time to go through all the chests.
Let's see.
So I'm gonna redo the chest just real quick.
Oh, I have three honey.
If anyone wants honey, I put the ice organs too.
Aight.
And then...
Yeah, if you want to resort stuff, you can.
What the fuck?
Half the reason they're getting trapped is because the... this like piece of... like this cliff we're on is made out of this stone that they can fall through.
No.
What the fuck?
You're so fucking stupid.
No, it's not our fault.
They're pretty... it's just our pals are pretty stupid.
It's not our fault.
I'll sell your...
Alright, I'm just gonna set it over here.
Alright, let's see.
I have to do...
This chest here.
What do I have to do again?
Alright, I'm gonna go start killing some pals.
I'm just gonna try to put them further apart so that they don't get stuck on each other.
Okay, I make one big chest which is just like common materials.
So whenever you come to the base real quick, you can just dump all your like common shit in there.
Alright, I'm gonna get the matsurina meat for us.
And then...
Okay, it should have enough storage for everything dumpable.
Okay, I'm gonna try to get this shit off the...
I should get a massandra right now for us actually.
I feel like that'd be the easiest.
Cause we need a massandra.
Alright, I need to grab this bee.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, put the bee in the right pouch.
We fly.
Where am I?
I went the wrong way again.
We fly.
Massandra.
I'm coming over.
We fly.
We only need for the rest of the base building.
Hold on, let me take a look.
We only actually need...
Uh...
Okay, we still need 250 ingot.
But once we get 250 ingot, after that it all just becomes refined ingot.
So we need to stop making like a crap ton unless we need it for other things.
Oh, we need the ingots for the balls.
Yeah, balls.
So I guess we'll just keep trying to make that.
Yeah, I feel like we have to because we need the balls.
Alright.
Where am I?
I need 300...
380 ore.
I need 300 ore for the refined ones for the base.
Stop building!
I'll just start stealing some.
Just make more furnaces.
Get over here.
Okay.
I'm about to make a lot of ore over here.
Nice.
That's what we need.
Okay, I need to go set up the coal base.
So I'll go do that.
What gender do we need for the Massandra?
Um, Massandra?
What is the petal one?
What is...
What gender is that one?
Do you know what the petalia that you caught?
What was the gender of it?
Female.
Female?
Male.
Okay, I'll catch a male.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know if I...
My game crashed.
Why is it crashing?
It's handicapping us.
What the fuck?
Let me back in.
Guys, I think I might need a new PC.
Probably wait a bit because the coal base is solid so just make a bunch of iron over here maybe.
Bip.
Please.
I was just wondering.
Or you can mine a bunch of iron over here.
Bip.
Just a bunch of iron over here.
Chat, you heard him.
They need a new PC.
Get on it.
Hold it here first.
New PC.
Get on it.
Top top.
I've got a 4080.
Why does this keep happening?
Maybe it's too good.
It's too good.
You're right.
It's just too good of a PC.
You know what I mean?
Nah, what the fuck?
You can't do this.
Wait, where...
Where is the cow?
You put it out.
I don't see it.
I'm just gonna respawn it.
He's somewhere.
Oh, I think this bails that they always walk like a weirdo.
It's a really weird path and they're like five bases ahead.
They're just walking into nothing.
They're like, goodbye, it's time to Brazil.
Our base is just too fucking good, you know?
Like, where is she going?
Or...
But it's, yeah, the PALs just need better walk cycles.
Sounds like a PAL problem.
Come on.
Pal, you heard that?
It's not our fault, it's your fault.
By the way, thanks for sponsoring this tournament, by the way.
Love the game though, keep at it.
Love the game, but...
Love the game, but anyway, it's your fault.
Okay, well I took the beds off the rock for the most part, so they should not get stuck in the rock.
Okay, there's two, there's a male and a female.
That'll help at least a little bit.
But we'll kill...
Oh my goodness, why is he stuck up there?
My eight arrows.
You can do this.
Go, Vanu.
Go.
What are we using the boar for?
I think he's mining.
The miners?
Okay, upgrading base.
That's the female, we don't care about the female.
Oh God, please.
Alright.
Who is a builder who can build?
Alright, this is gonna be rough... NO, GWIRRAK!
Leave me alone!
Okay, I got...
I got the whole thing.
I got Mildessandra!
We basically have what we needed for the other breeding.
Alright, I want to set up the breeding before... oh wait, shit.
We need to make the cake.
Alright, for the cake...
For the cake, I need flour, I need berries, I need milk, and I need egg.
Alright, we need egg.
Does anybody have any eggs on them?
Yeah, I put a lot of eggs in the chest.
Nice.
Alright, I'm gonna grab egg.
I think so.
I trust.
There's something in there.
If there's no eggs, we can just kill some chickens.
Yeah, we can kill chickens or I can throw one in the ranch, maybe.
Alright, I need to find a...
Hey, Vy.
What the fuck are you doing over here?
I have... I caught a misandra, so you can breed it at any time you want.
Nice.
Let it have a good time.
Oh yeah, sure.
Remember to put a petalia in the base whenever you have time.
I'm using her right now.
What?
Why you gotta say it like that?
What are you using her for?
She's in my party.
Mm-hmm.
What is her purpose in your party?
To breed.
Where the fuck is she?
It's a fast travel.
No, it's this one.
It was one.
Okay, I'll make a barrel at the base and that barrel will have the spears all the time.
Alright, yeah.
I need some Giga Spears right now.
Can we make a conveyor belt already?
I think we need circuit boards for that though.
I think we can.
Yeah, we just...
If we can build a...
Oh, we have a...
Oh yeah, we need to make the power generator.
Yeah, we need circuit boards.
Yeah.
Like right away.
Yeah, I think we're all at the level to make them.
Yeah, we just... we need the quartz.
That's literally it.
What's the dungeon we need to do?
Mountain Stream Grotto?
Do we need that?
I'm gonna check.
Mountain...
Oh no, no we don't.
It's sacred.
We need the...
Nah, check.
Dunes, Volcanic and Sacred Mountain.
Yeah, I just checked it's not this one.
Alright.
We need... I need more Giga Spears right now.
I only have four.
I'm just gonna go build the coal base.
I only have four, Lily.
Where are my fire pelts?
Where are my balls, Lily?
Oh, here.
Here are some balls.
In the... in the... what is it called?
The barrel.
In the middle of the base.
Okay.
I'll steal this one too from...
Yeah.
Nice.
He's trying his best to make more.
I'm gonna steal it right now.
I just need more ingots and then I can start making more.
Alright, that should be enough for now.
Where are the other fire pelts?
Oh my god, bro!
Where are they?
Alright, do you want me to put the Massandra in now or later?
Into the breeding?
We don't have cake yet.
Yeah, but do you want me to just put it in... put it in there for now?
I'm gonna replace the dino one since...
Yeah, I can grab it and set it in my...
Yeah, I put it in.
I replaced the dino just in case.
Okay, cool.
I'm gonna do the faction tower now.
I'm gonna do the tower.
Yeah, I wanna start breeding but we don't have cake, so...
How do we make cake?
You need honey and milk and egg.
Oh, eggs?
I can give you guys eggs now.
Yeah, you're just missing eggs, right?
Yeah, I'm just... well, I'm missing honey.
The bee will not stay in the ranch for some reason.
Just chuck him in.
I got some honey.
I'll take honey if you got it.
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna kill some chickens real quick.
I'm gonna go build the coal base.
Hello little chicken.
Do you need to research cement?
Cement?
Cement is made out of bone, pal fluid, and stone, I think.
Do you need to research it?
It's one of the things, yeah.
I can't see it in the tech tree.
Maybe I'm blind.
It should be...
Let me see.
I don't want to just need insta-kill.
I'm gonna go ride my...
Cement is level 19.
Yeah, you guys should be able to.
Also, we have stone structures now as well.
Chicken, where are you, chicken?
I'm gonna kill you.
Stop eating!
Go back to work!
You can't eat when you have worked for it!
Yeah, that's right.
You didn't earn the food.
You didn't earn the food yet.
Yeah.
You heard her.
You can eat when you die.
I'm starving too.
Fuck, fuck, wait, I'm also starving, man.
I'm saying that you gotta preach it.
I earned it, surely.
What did you do?
Oh, wait, can somebody give me... do we have all the tombats out right now?
I want to take one to the new base.
I have two of it, yeah.
Okay, can you put another one on base?
I'll just take this one.
Yeah, I can.
I just need a...
I can fucking pick up... no, you're hungry!
Why are you hungry?
You can starve when I tell you to.
Stop starving!
Stop starving now!
Stop it!
I need water, pals.
I can give you some water, pals, if you need it.
Sorry, I'll throw it.
Surf it.
Alright, I got 16 eggs.
I'm putting the eggs in the...
I'll put the eggs in the chest.
You should have enough now, right?
With the eggs?
Unless you're missing something?
We still need honey, but maybe...
We have a lot of honey.
Like, I put some honey, too, in the chest.
Wait, where's the honey?
In one of the chests.
I put like three, at least three in there.
What do you mean?
I'll take a look.
You have no permission to start.
What a guy.
What?
Alright, I am...
Stop it!
Yeah, there's three honey at least in there.
And there's six... there's 43 eggs, too.
Work.
Okay, okay.
Then I can probably cook.
Make sure you're using the Jormuntide Ignis for smelting.
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah.
We have the Instagram just doing it right now.
Uh... let's see.
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna go do the...
I'm gonna go do the faction tower.
For real this time.
Aight, good luck.
Alright, let's make a mill.
You should put the...
What?
You're not gonna use the egg right away.
You should put it in the cooler.
Yes.
Cause the eggs are... the...
Oh.
The eggs is in the...
It's...
Oh, fuck.
I forgot to get the arrows.
It is in the chest.
The three chests.
That's like on the cliff.
It's in one of them.
Oh, over here.
Okay.
Cool.
Yeah.
I don't think you... you don't have to take it out.
Let me see if I can actually already just make the cake.
You don't have to take the materials out.
We need milk.
I gotta make flour.
Okay.
I'll make the milk.
Any extra arrows?
Anywhere?
On the bench.
There's 363.
We should have loads of arrows there.
I'm gonna... I'm... oink.
Mine.
It's mine now.
I moved the...
The chest.
Alright.
Get the tower.
Get ready to clip this when I defeat this tower.
Also remember to yell clip it, clip it when we...
Shufar, remember to yell clip it, clip it!
So we remember to clip it.
Clip this.
Thank you... wait.
Shoutout to my mods.
Thank you so much for clipping everything yesterday.
You're the realist.
Hell yeah.
Alright, let me in them.
They now have a nickname thanks to Doki Juno.
They're now called the peepee mods.
The peepee mods?
Which sounds like something that should be outlawed everywhere but Florida, but you know, it's fine.
Alright, here we go.
I can kill this guy.
He's like fucking...
What level is he?
I'm gonna reset these.
Go, Vang!
Awww.
They should probably run into less shit now.
Oh no, please leave me alone.
I need an open line.
Nooo.
Wait, where are the wood and the palladium?
Ow, girl!
What the... stop!
I'm killing the faction.
Zoe and Grif...
What level is this?
What level is the second tower, boss?
You guys know?
30?
Okay, so yeah, I haven't done that.
I only got to the first one.
Yeah, that's the first one and I just put down the fucking mechanic.
I'm like, I'm done.
I'm good.
Damn!
I was like, okay, that was it.
I played three days non-stop and then I was like, I'm good.
I'm good to go.
I feel like the bosses just aren't like as worth it in this game.
Yeah, I don't know.
Compared to similar games that we won't name.
I think it's just because like... I guess it's like Dark Souls-esque too.
So it's like...
Yeah.
But like, it's not as rewarding to kill them.
Oh!
Another thing.
If you see any electric that's like large electric eggs, that's another way to get Grisbolt.
That is like less of a hassle if anybody has any.
I have.
I don't have one.
Alright.
Well, if you guys see any priority on that one.
Okay.
Uh, mill.
No, don't kill me.
Okay.
Bat Worm, please!
Stop!
Oh my god.
My Bat Worm got stuck.
I'm gonna be down.
Maybe I should not use a Bat Worm.
Maybe I should use a sweeper.
Fuck.
Oh, why are you hungry?
You're not allowed to starve.
Stop starving!
I didn't tell you.
Wait, where did Lutmon go?
Hello?
My flower!
Stop building!
Get the fuck back here!
These fucking pals!
These pals of Goldcraft Ball!
These fucking pals.
Fuck!
Wait, I've got a new snake bar.
What did I not pay?
This is not what I paid you for because you're not getting paid in general.
Yeah, you don't really get paid but...
You're allowed to survive if you make balls.
Yeah.
Earn your food.
Your use to me is your ball production.
Don't worry, they're gonna be able to make balls faster in a second.
Oh yeah, the assembly line.
Let's go!
Finally!
Assembly line.
Clip this!
Clip, clip, clip, clip!
Boss eliminated!
Clip, clip, clip!
Let's go!
I need a bunch of balls.
We all do.
We're on it.
We all need balls.
Alright, what do I... okay, let's see.
What else do we need?
Let's see.
I can try and catch a Greyhound.
You can't catch a Grizzbolt, right?
Unless we go to the Sanctuary.
Right?
Can you catch a Grizzbolt?
I have no idea either.
Yeah, we need a Grizzbolt.
Yeah, but can we catch a Grizzbolt?
From the Sanctuary?
Yes.
Yes?
But I don't know what level the Sanctuary is.
Okay, I'm just gonna go to the desert and catch a Hound.
I need pallium fragments.
Hold up.
That should have helped the flow around here.
How much rock do we have?
There's a way to easily get pallium fragments.
Not much.
Oh yeah, with the Crusher.
Yeah.
Oh, now with Crusher?
You go to the Rain Syndicate Tower.
And then you just teleport to the cave.
And there's big ore nodes in there.
Oh!
Okay.
And in every cave there's pallium.
Oh yeah, yeah.
So we just find a dungeon, right?
Yeah.
Yep.
Alright, let's see.
What do I need to do now?
I got one of the towers done.
I'm not leveled up for the medium bosses yet.
Let's see.
What levels are the Marketeers?
The lowest level one I know is 40.
40?
Okay, I'm not in range for that yet.
I'm gonna get heat resistant armor and catch a Ray Hound for us.
Ummm...
Okay, I don't have the crafting yet for that.
Let's see.
Where are you?
Heat resistant pelt armor.
Let's get the cold resistant pelt armor.
Okay.
Uhhh... I need more ingots.
Where... I'm gonna help bring my Van Worm here.
Van Worm!
Ingots now!
Ingots!
Catch!
Go, go Van Worm!
Okay, my Van Worm is doing ingots.
Because I need that shit.
I'll farm some ore for us too.
Uh, now that we have the...
Just the assembly line, do we still need the sphere wrench?
I don't think we do, no.
Don't think so, no.
Alright, then I'll just nuke it.
Okay.
Alright, cool.
I just need my... I need like 40 ingots so I can make the heat resistant armor.
Thank you, Pen King.
Thank you, Pen King for the flower.
I think I just need to go collect milk now.
And we have enough for a cake.
I was hoping we have everything we need.
Our pals need like...
Like four more beds by the way.
Why do we have beds for them?
If they have those bags, they won't sleep and they won't work that easy.
Guys!
One has ulcer!
What are you doing to our pals?
No!
No time to cure the ulcer.
We can replace them.
You replace the world, manage your ulcer yourself.
Yeah.
Our comfy does not cover medical costs.
No insurance.
This is a North America tournament, baby.
I feel like a North American tournament does cover for medical costs.
Maybe half.
If you're lucky.
Where the fuck is the repair box?
Do we have any medicine?
No, we don't even have a medicine bar.
Oh wait, I have some medicine.
Hold on, wait a minute.
Let's see.
I'm trying to put away...
I'm putting away...
Mining away.
I don't know what's left of mine.
I mine it anyways.
Minecraft world, so beautiful.
Nice.
That was beautiful, guys.
Mine diamonds!
What will you do a karaoke stream, Sheriff War?
You have the voice for it.
I wonder if I feel like it.
I want you to give your Chad karaoke.
I need to find a way to give reverb on my voice.
That's how you sound nice.
You can do...
Oh shit, nevermind, I can't do this.
Yeah!
It's easy.
I can't do that.
It's so... just get a GoXLR.
Easy.
Last time I got a GoXLR, I plugged that shit in and downloaded the software and nothing worked and I was too lazy so I gave up.
What?
What do you mean nothing worked?
I don't know, I was pressing buttons, there's no thing, I don't know how to make the noises.
There's no thang.
No thang, just sticking out.
Just watch a YouTube tutorial.
Yo, they won't tell me shit.
In the solution to our fox having an ulcer, I replaced him with a different fox.
Nice.
We don't need him anyway.
Medical care?
No thank you.
No, we just replaced him.
Holy fuck.
It's okay, we'll get a scab.
Is that it?
Man, I love capitalism simulator.
This is my favorite game.
Welcome to capitalism.
Scabs are allowed in this company.
Jesus Christ.
I've been mining this whole time.
I thought you were supposed to power level.
Yeah, I need balls for that.
I'm trying.
I'm gonna try to collect a bunch of shit.
I'm heading to catch a Ryehound now.
Oh sick, we got another Bushi.
Alright, come over here, it's Ryehound time.
Am I heading the right way?
Does anybody have any eggs?
The incubator is empty.
Nope, not on me.
There might be one in the chest.
Oh yeah, we don't have electricity, so we can't make balls anymore.
We can have electricity already.
I can make one right now.
Yeah.
Hell yeah, brother.
Oh wait, no, we need 100 ingot.
50 ingot, that's what I was waiting for.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
We need it though, so...
Just make more furnaces.
That's our only answer.
Make more.
We don't even have enough firepower to kill him.
Take care of the furnace and make more.
Should we?
We should...
Ah, no, it's kind of a waste of mats.
I was gonna say, we can make the better furnace, but we might as well just wait until we can make the electric furnace.
We should like...
How much are we from leveling up the base?
What do we need for base level?
Right now for base level up...
Give me a second.
We need the power generator, so we need... I'm just waiting on the ingot.
Okay.
So if we can hold off on balls for a second, I just need to...
I need 50 ingots.
Dude, I sure for we need 50 ingots.
I need the balls.
I can't level right now.
You're gonna have to kill everything.
Where the fuck are the...
Captain, what about my balls?
...ryhounds?
I have a heat resistant armor now.
I just need to find...
Make ingots.
...the ryhounds.
Rhyhounds, where are you?
Uh, is the wheat ready yet?
Yes!
Cool, okay, I can start breeding.
What are you trying to make with the ingots?
Uh, I need to make the power generator.
So I need 50.
I don't know if I need to go for it yet.
I have 41.
I think we need more mining pals.
We're kinda behind on rock and stuff.
Yeah, agree.
I think you have to mine it yourself at this point.
It would be really good...
The mining pals don't dig, like, at all.
They're like losers.
If we can get the dig toys, can't we do the...
If we can get the dig toys, we need to catch them in the desert.
Isn't dig toys still bugged?
They're bugged?
Every mining pal is bugged.
They don't fucking work.
I thought they were a turtle.
Fuck's sake, Matt!
Oh yeah, everybody in my chat says, dig toy's bad.
Okay.
Yeah, it's super buggy right now.
Dig toys is good if you use it yourself.
Yeah, yeah, but not as like a mine thing.
Well, no pal is good at mining.
Like...
Yeah, it's just... they're all bugged in general.
Trying to make auto farms is useless right now in this game.
I made one with like a different mining pal.
It works so well.
Like, it doesn't respawn fast enough for them to have much to do.
What, you actually got your pals to collect all the shit?
Yeah, like, it works flawless.
I have so much iron.
It's just the EU div.
It's the EU div?
It's the EU div.
We should have had our servers in EU div.
You guys, it would have worked.
Whenever I had my pals trying to collect stuff, they would just pick it up, drop it, pick it up, drop it, and there'd just be giant piles everywhere.
I think it just depends on how your base is set up too.
Because I've had problems with pals picking up my shit.
Because also I did...
I made a very specific base to... yeah, avoid all the pathing issues.
Like, I built like walls and pathways and stuff specifically so that I can path easier.
Cake!
Alright, we made our first cake.
Now, breed.
I guess we'll start with Anubis, because he's the most useful for the base.
I'm heading over to... Can Anubis mine?
Anubis can do handiwork.
And then you can replace the breeding pals too, because some of them are useless anyway.
I'm heading over to this waypoint.
Where the fuck is the Ryehound?
I need a female Ryehound, right?
Because we have a male Massandra.
Yeah, if we're gonna make Grisbold that way.
Yeah, I can't find him.
Oh, I made the electric thing.
Oh, you made it already?
Nice.
Okay, cool.
Now I just need a pal that can power it.
Oh wait, you made it?
Is it being built?
Okay, okay.
Thanks.
I'm trying to find the Ryehound wherever you are.
Wait, Anubis also has mining?
We might wanna consider making mine.
Yeah.
Just to get the mining under control.
Because it slows down the ball production a ton.
I have to just mine manually the whole time.
I'm just trying to find our little dog in this sad world out here.
Yeah, I feel like the base being 50% Anubis is actually the play.
Yeah, honestly.
We just breed a couple of them real quick.
Electric.
Electro.
And then some handiwork.
The rest is mining.
That will solve all the ball issues.
Oh, that would, yeah.
Honestly.
Oh my god, Lily, you're brainstorming!
I'm brainstorming!
Your brain is enlarging right now!
I'm doing it!
My game crashed.
Alright, next one.
No!
Why?
You're cursed!
I'm cursed right now!
Someone cursed my game!
Stop being happy!
I just want the right hound!
Please!
Let me in!
Where am I?
Okay.
High quality hot springs.
We need...
So when you start making cement...
I can make cement.
I can't make the hot springs though.
And we need a weapon assembly line.
So whoever is level 32 and 31...
I can get to level 32 soon after I fucking...
I will make cement.
At the moment, surefour has the balls.
He needs to hurry and power level.
I have no balls!
That's the problem!
Are we not at range yet for the ingots?
Well, we need power.
And then we also need this and we need that.
Oh my god, we need so many things.
And we need this and that.
Am I in the right area for fucking the Ryehounds?
I haven't found a single Ryehound.
Uh...
I put their location on the dock but I don't know where they'd be.
Like the... like am I...
I'm pretty sure I'm in the area for it.
Yeah.
This has to be the area for the fucking Ryehounds.
Chat, am I in the right area?
I can never tell anymore.
All I see is tocos.
And you'll never freaking know.
I'll never know.
God, the cake takes so freaking long to cook.
Probably.
Oh, apparently it's daytime only.
Okay, that makes sense.
I'm gonna dazzy.
Is a dazzy good?
Can't believe it's daytime only.
Now I'm stuck here.
I have like half a day.
I can't believe I wasted half.
I'm gonna catch this then.
I'm gonna catch these then.
Please don't take all the damage.
I have a electric power.
We can...
I can give you a dazzy soon.
I have one.
I put one in.
Woah.
These guys hurt.
Holy shit.
How did I miss?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm just stuck here making fucking cake.
You know what?
I should just go do something else.
The spear isn't working on dazzy level 30.
Try using a better spear.
Wait, what?
The Giga Spear doesn't work on a dazzy?
What?
What the fuck do you need?
Giga Mega Ultra Spear.
There you go.
I just need to damage more.
Oh thank god.
I was like there's no way.
There's no way it doesn't work.
Come on.
Yes.
Alright, nice.
I'm level 30.
Okay.
Let's see if I can...
I'm gonna catch these tokotokos.
Okay, cool.
Cool.
Get over here tokotoko.
Alright, we need to make more wheat.
Ooh.
Okay, nice.
Oh fuck.
Oops.
Guys, I'm lucky.
I'm cooking.
Why do they have to sleep at night, bro?
Are you using the Ignis?
You...
You have it.
It's not on base.
It's on base right now.
Oh.
What?
I just make it cook real quick.
Oh shit, it's hot.
Oh no, it's hot now.
No gathering.
You must make ore.
You must...
No gathering.
Make ore now.
Ore.
Now.
If you want pure ingots, you can teleport to the other base I have and then just mine that.
Oh no.
How am I missing?
Give me that tokotoko.
Yay!
Do we not have...
Wait.
A better workbench?
We should.
No we do.
It's right over here.
All we do here.
Sorry, there's cement on it right now.
Don't worry.
I'll try and work with it.
Alright.
I'll just keep cooking cake.
Raihoun, where are you?
I should be able to make the...
What do we need the...
Uh...
What do we need in level 32 and 33?
We need to make the...
hot springs, the better hot springs, and we need to make the...
Um...
The weapon assembly line.
Okay.
I'm almost... I'm like level 30 now.
Nice!
I should get to level 31 soon.
I...
Find the goddamn Raihoun.
Boom.
Cement them.
It's day time!
Where are you?
Hit em with the cement!
Alright.
Okay.
If cement is already in the thing, then we should have everything, I think, to build the...
The thing?
The hot springs?
Yeah.
When we're thing-ing the thing?
Oh yeah.
Exactly.
It's so easy.
Oh god.
I can't fly.
Why is it all just a die?
These dogs are the hardest shit I've ever...
The hardest shit to find.
Oh hey, there's an electric egg.
Wait.
This egg could hatch it.
If it's a grizz, then...
Wait, what size is it?
I haven't found a large electric egg.
I don't think this is as fast as it is.
No way.
I'll try and find a dog just in case we don't...
Guys,
am I in the right place?
Chat!
My back seat is...
I am!
You're level 36?!
Okay, this is awkward.
Okay, I did not realize you're level 36.
They're big boys.
Wow, they're... yeah.
This is bad.
I don't think this is fast enough.
I might die.
Uh oh.
Thanks.
Hopefully that electric egg is just a grizz bolt and then we're done.
Yeah, but if I die, we won't get the electric egg.
Oh no.
I'm gonna see if I can catch one.
I'm gonna try my best.
You know what?
Uh...
I'm just gonna... I'm not testing this.
I'm gonna bank it all on this electric egg.
Fuck this.
Actually, unless... There's one!
I can separate this one guy.
No, you!
You're gonna one guy him?
I'm gonna one guy this guy.
Oh my god, please don't run away.
This guy's level 34.
Wait, what gender do I need them to be?
I forgot.
What's the relaxotaurus gender?
It doesn't matter, just get him.
No, the relaxotaurus?
I would need to ask.
Sure, I think...
I have one too.
Is that male or female?
Pretty sure I only killed the relaxotaurus.
I have one as well, so...
Yeah, we need him, but...
Let me see.
It might be on the other side.
I'm taking a quick look.
You have to throw him.
So, we need the masanda.
But I think we have masanda...
We have a male masanda.
Yeah, we only have male, then we need a female.
Wait, sure, for Wastey?
Put him on our team.
Put him on our team?
What do you mean?
Yeah, but if I have him, I already have Incineroar on my team making the ore.
Oh, okay.
I think it's the location.
Wait, I'm gonna try this down and rebuild this.
Like, much further into the farm.
I think it's too far outside.
I'm worried you got this.
I'll feed you.
What the...
Woo!
No!
There's so many people trying to kill me!
Oh my god!
Please!
There's so many people involved now!
So, it sounds like things are going really well for Doki right now.
No!
Things are...
It sounds amazing!
It sounds like... man!
Oh my god, alright, I'm gonna bank on this...
Where's my invite?
What the fuck?
I'm gonna bank on this egg.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try to get up to... fuck me up.
Holy shit.
It literally... five pals came up and just killed the two rayhounds I had.
It was crazy.
Come on, cake!
I just want the zanubias!
I'm just gonna bank on this one egg I have.
I'm just hoping it's not a drassie.
What size is the egg?
Large.
Alright, then maybe.
Fingers crossed!
I got third party so hard.
There he is!
Oh my god.
Can you call back the asynaram?
Yeah.
There he fucking is.
Alright, I'm coming over.
Alright,
I'm heading over.
I... can you in just a second...
rebuild the...
assembly line?
The palsphere assembly line?
But like...
attempt to find...
I can chop down some trees to make it more in base.
I think the location was just...
Oh my god, he's so big and broken.
It's fine.
Alright, I put in...
I can put it in front of the beds, but I think that'll fuck things up.
I moved the beds mostly out of the way, but...
Can you just put it...
anywhere in... oh shit, that's the beds.
We can rebuild the beds down below, but they don't...
seem to understand how to go down the...
Yeah, what if I put it here?
It's like in between the beds as well, but...
not so much in front of them.
Yeah.
Alright.
Nice.
Time to breed.
Do you have any hyperspheres around?
Um, I only have...
gigaspears, sorry.
I can't make hyper.
I was focusing...
on giga, cause I figured...
I'm gonna... you catch high level shit.
Just gonna... Yeah, we need giga.
You need giga?
Okay.
I can give you some of my gigaspears if you want them.
Um... What do you got?
I can drop 15.
I dropped 15 on me.
It's next to the berries.
They're from right here.
There's so many names...
Where am I?
Here.
Thank you.
Here's some giga.
Oh, I'm gonna go...
catch some...
Let's see how much you have.
I'm just gonna make some normal.
I'm gonna power level a little bit.
Wait, come the fuck back.
Come back.
So I can catch the... Yes!
The new assembly line works.
Nice.
Nice!
They're working on it now.
Alright, cool, cool, cool.
Alright, I'm putting Bushi in the breeding booth.
Oh my god, please.
Let me get down...
from the fucking... vanworm.
And I'm gonna go grab Pen King.
Uh...
Oh, what the fuck just died?
Where's the assembly line?
Go ahead.
It's like...
It's breeding time!
Where is it?
The brick stone rock thing.
The brick big stone rock thing.
Yes, the big stone tooth coming out of this...
facility.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I'm gonna... I need some...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I need to get some normal...
Skulking around.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, go!
Go!
Fall in love!
Make babies!
Plop, plop, plop!
What?!
Eat the cake!
Make babies!
I don't think pressuring them...
How long does it take them to make babies?
Oh my god.
I think maybe stop watching?
Stop watching them and then maybe...
Sometimes... Is that... Is that a...
requirement or a request?
Really?
What did you say?
Do we have something to make palladium fragments?
Like the...
Um, the crusher.
The crusher.
Yeah, yeah, just... We don't.
We should make one.
We... I'm about to make one.
Okay.
Alright, I'm just gonna construct these.
Oh, yeah, wait a minute.
For the crusher...
I wrote down this yesterday, but for the crusher...
Uh, can we get that...
boss, the... What is his name?
The...
The little water noodle guy.
One of the bosses.
I have an azeroth.
Yay!
I have one.
Yeah, can we put him... Can we put him out for the...
for the crusher?
Yeah, I can do it.
Which do you want to get rid of?
Let me know.
Not the miners.
The miners are like essential right now.
Okay.
Uh, well once Bushi and what's his name, like, uh...
stop going at it, then...
we can put them away.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, just let me know.
And then I can put the azeroth in there.
I'm just... I'm gonna...
Oh, shit.
I'm going to go power level a little bit.
I need... Cause you guys... I need to get to level 2 and 3...
Level 32 and 3 for us.
You could also just start making some...
mega spheres.
Okay.
Alright.
We just need some fragments.
We don't have enough wood for a crusher.
That costs less material.
Well, it's a good thing there's a bunch of trees around here.
Yeah, yeah.
Good thing!
That's what the base is for!
I can...
I can chop down some trees off there.
Yeehaw!
We gotta get to level 20!
Where the fuck are the other pals around here?
I need a power level...
It says 33 for us.
This is the most empty area I've ever seen.
Pals!
Oh, there you are.
I'm gonna catch a frock.
Okay...
Is it enough?
If I can get a bunch of mega spheres, I can probably... No, it's not enough.
Wait.
...power level pretty high.
Umm... We need wood for mega spheres.
Alright, I'm gonna... I'm gonna have to put the elk back in here to make wood.
We need...
Uhh...
We just need wood.
So I mean...
Uh...
Flannel's not doing anything right now, so I'm just gonna swap her.
I mean, just start cutting some trees right now.
By yourself.
On it.
And then make some mega spheres for true 4.
Alright.
Because...
Once I get to legendary spheres, all you need is...
Legendary spheres only cost palladium and iron, I'm pretty sure.
Do you guys need more tombats?
Or...
Oh, they need carbon fibers.
Tombats are always good right now.
But I think we have an Anubis soon?
Okay, so you don't need tombat then.
It looks like another 2 minutes until the first egg comes out.
Nice.
Uhh... And then, did we have...
Did we have the right genders for making the Lylene?
I forgot.
Yeah, we do.
I got a Missandra.
Alright.
I will need the pet whatever then.
Missandra's...
Surefour, you may give...
Give her the bataleo.
Pretty soon.
Or Lylene.
You probably got about 5 or 6 minutes.
Augie.
Get over here, Fwock.
Why are none of us lucky enough for lucky palettes?
I haven't found one yet.
Yeah, well I'm never gonna find one.
Keep that.
Surefour, why aren't you lucky?
You know, my stats got rolled differently when I spawned.
What did you get for your stats?
I don't know, like...
Like, my hands?
Your hands!
Alright.
Okay.
See you.
Deforestation sounds.
Deforestation ASMR.
Nice.
I love deforestation in-game.
Deforestation ASMR.
You said that with such like a nice ASMR voice though.
I'm committed!
I'm in the role now!
Yeah, we're being immersed right now!
I'm being immersed.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, stop trying to break our immersion.
Oh my god.
Mom, oh my god, you're embarrassing me!
Stop!
Industrialization ASMR.
Alright, Crusher is made.
Do you want me to just make a bunch of Palladium fragments right now?
Yeah, cause that's what's holding back the bold right now.
Alright, I'm starting production.
We're gonna be wiped out of rock, but that's okay.
I'm on my way to make more rock.
Alright, maybe the baby is born.
The baby is born!
Yes!
Clip, clip, clip!
Is it clipping time?
It's a huge rocky egg.
Is that what Anubis comes out of?
Oh wait, no clips.
Sorry, no clips then.
I thought you meant the baby's hatched.
No clip, guys.
No clip.
False alarm.
My water broke!
Nevermind.
False alarm.
I'm gonna leave them in there to make another Anubis though.
Okay.
Wait, just kidding.
It takes 40 fucking minutes, but we're not doing that.
Oh no, not the dog.
Alright, then I will need...
pet...pet...pet...
pet...petile.
I'm coming.
I'll let them make a second egg while I'm waiting for it.
What's the lowest level Anubis you can catch?
That shouldn't take 40 minutes.
If it's like a quick, you know, Yeah, yeah!
I put her in the box.
Thank you!
Do I have to be level 32 or 33 for the crafting thing that you need?
Uh, 32 and I'm running 33.
I'm running 32 then.
Okay, I'm gonna take...
Oh, did you put her in here?
Yeah.
I think...
No, you have to put her in the base.
I can't see your box.
Yeah, she's in the box.
Wait, everyone has their own box?
Yeah, everyone has their own box.
You have to put in the...
You have to have her working.
Yeah.
Okay, so I'm just gonna get rid of this ghost bitch then.
Sounds good.
Alright, I catch an extra person for the viewing thing.
Thanks.
Because we need a view, right?
Do we know how many people we have already?
Uh... humans?
Yeah, the humans.
Yeah.
We can count them real quick.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5... wait.
I'm short by element.
Their element is nothing, so they'll show up at the top.
I have 8.
Okay, I think I have like 5 right now.
Because we need 20 in total.
The viewing thing can be made from level 14, so it's not hard.
Yeah.
I just want to make sure we have enough for...
Um...
Actually, I'll just build it.
Enough for the viewing thing.
Because we need 20, right?
Yeah.
I have... okay, sort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
I have 7.
You have 8, right?
We should probably make it at the end, because it'll fuck up all of our base shit.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just wondering how much we have.
You need an azerob, right?
Uh...
You need...
Yes.
I wanted to use him on the base, just because he's better at water than anybody else.
I put it... I got azerobs in there.
Okay, uh...
I'll grab him and I'll switch him.
Uh...
Put you on the crusher.
Like, serpent's alright, but...
Azerob should be way faster.
Um...
What do you need me to do?
I need a power level stone.
Get some freaking stone.
Get stone?
Okay, I can grab stone now for us.
I'm getting stone.
We need more.
So much more.
More stone.
Unlimited power.
I'll go mine stone for us.
Can I have my buddy's five?
We should have enough...
tree... tree bark for a while.
Tree... tree fiber.
There we go.
Tree sustenance.
The trinussi.
Rock and stone!
Stone!
Okay, I need to make more cake.
Oh my god, all I'm doing is making cake.
That's all we need.
Bruh.
Okay, there's some stone and...
There's some stone right now.
I quickly mined 17.
I'm gonna go power level some more.
Oh yeah, we need level 32.
Okay, what do we need in level 32?
Uh... We need raw milk.
Uh... Assembly line?
Did you build the hot spring?
We need the weapon assembly line.
Oh, you need the high quality hot spring?
Yeah, high quality hot spring and the weapons assembly line.
Okay, I can milk make that now.
Where do you want?
I'm gonna put this randomly.
We need... okay, we need stone for that.
And then...
Where's high quality assembly line?
Where is that?
I'm making another cake.
Nails.
We need nails.
Ten more nails.
I'm gonna make ten nails right now.
Or put it in there.
Nails.
Uh... Is Ignis out here right now?
He's stuck in a tree.
Oh, I'll get him.
Silly little guy.
Silly Ignis.
Get back here.
Someone fucking do this and then...
I'm gonna put him on my team for a second so I can control him.
Where the fuck are the rock ones?
Um...
Sweep, sweep, sweep?
Work on that.
Okay, there.
Make the cake.
Go and do the rock stuff.
Dumud, no!
Dumud, come over here!
Wait.
I'm a genius.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, chat.
I have the breath.
Watch this.
Oh my god, what are you doing, Lili?
What are you doing?
I'm gonna farm the rock with my boar, which is pretty fast.
And then I'll get it all into base.
In one go.
Abusing the wolf charge.
Oh, that is so big brain.
Because then I don't care about the weight.
I don't have to go back and forth every time I'm cucumbered.
I can just do it in one big longer trip.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
You're like a gamer right now.
I made an improved furnace so we can make a fine kettle.
Oh nice, that's good.
Let's go!
Alright, then I need to go make the coal.
Okay.
We're cooking so hard right now.
Our cake is done.
I need to make another coal.
We need milk, berries, flour.
Cooking!
Alright, I have a lot of stone for us.
I have a lot of stone for us.
That should be close to...
Actually, I'm close to...
100.
Stop!
Why are you getting tired?
Keep working!
Just work, man!
You have nothing else to do in your life?
Oh shit, it's damage.
Alright, looks like the crusher...
They're not doing anything on it anymore, which maybe means they're dead.
I mean, done.
They're dead?
Give me like 10 more minutes and I'm bringing home loads of rock.
Okay, yeah, they...
They made the 61 palladium fragments.
Nice.
There's no labor loss for pals.
You think there's pal rights?
What do you think this is, summer camp?
No pal rights.
There's no pal rights here.
If there were pal rights, they would not be stuck in the fucking ball.
We need two Anubises, right?
Oh, we need cement.
We need 20 cement.
If someone can make that.
Okay, I'm gonna get the...
Petili, whatever her name is.
Get out of here, you're so annoying.
How do you make cement?
We need 20.
Cement is bone, pal, wood.
I think it has been a special workbench.
Oh, okay, I'm gonna see if we can make cement right now.
Because we need...
Oh, I think we need...
Oh no, we need 20.
Have pal fluids too.
What level... where the fuck is cement?
Oh god, there it is.
It is time to breed.
Cement.
There's so many crackers, which one's the right one?
No, stop.
Stop being useful, go breed.
There you go.
Oh, it makes 10.
I need 20.
Okay.
Please breed.
Thank you.
Job's done.
Yay.
Thanks.
Alright, wait.
Do you think you're at your high enough level to do the hard pals now?
For day 2?
Day 4?
Ummm...
What are the average levels of those guys?
They are level...
40.
Nah, those guys are level 40s.
I'm gonna try to make as many spears.
Oh man.
I've been on it this whole time.
I know, I know.
We're all struggling together.
We're trying to make as many spears as possible.
We just need a shit ton of stone.
Then a bunch of gigasfears can start being made.
Gigasfears.
I am bringing a bunch of stone.
Wait, did you guys make some stuff just now?
With stone?
Someone must have.
Yeah, cause there's like 5 now.
I had 80.
What?
No, back to mining.
Let's see, let's hope this is a grizzbolt.
Let's hope it's a grizz.
Is it a grizzbolt?
It is a rayhound, which is fine.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
We got it.
It's fine.
We got what we need.
Rayhound, grizzbolt, it's the same.
Alright, cool.
I yearn for the mines.
We can put more people in.
We want somebody who can do this, right?
Okay, let's see.
Where's my stone?
I need eggs too, so I'm gonna split out this fucking chicken.
There should be like a lot of eggs.
Okay, I'm bringing almost a thousand.
Unless like you, unless like spy aid.
Well, I had to make a bunch of kegs.
So, hold on, let me check.
Oh no, sorry.
Milk is what I need.
I don't need eggs.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I fucking brought out a ton of eggs.
My bad.
Sorry, I didn't mean to doubt your egg making process.
The stone farm at the base sucks.
That's fucking right.
I know the best about eggs.
You're really good at laying eggs.
Don't worry about it.
I know everything there is about eggs.
I got like a thousand stones in 15 minutes time.
The stone base at the base doesn't seem to get the bonus from like the extra bonus.
Make sure the hot spring now.
I'm gonna put it all the way here.
So they have to travel down.
Boom!
A thousand stones!
Holy shit, they're all...
Why is there so many hungry people?
We need, uh...
berries if people have any that they've gotten on the road.
We don't really use our berry farm.
So...
This is fine.
I'm building the hot spring now.
What's wrong with the hot spring?
Why are you saying it like that?
This is fine!
Are we doing some OSHA violations over here?
It's fine.
They don't care enough.
They don't care.
It's a water slide, exactly.
It's a water slide.
Did you put it on the side of the map?
I don't know.
All of this work for one stone.
Wait, unless...
Unless?
Can I mine it with my board?
Maybe you do, yeah.
Okay, we got the hot spring.
Weapons?
Checking what else I need for it.
We need a lot.
We need a hundred ingots.
I found a stone.
I made power spheres in the working.
I will get ingots done.
I need a hundred ingots.
Let me know when we've reached a hundred.
Okay.
That's all we need.
Ummm...
I need milk.
Flour should be okay, I just need milk.
I'll go kill the birdash now.
The bee is not really making a lot of honey.
Which is concerning.
I'm gonna go kill the birdash now.
If someone just goes and kills bees, they just drop honey off the deck.
True.
Alright, it's this way.
Oh yeah, the bee is doing other shit.
What is...
Okay for...
Right now.
No we're not.
Oh wait, yes we are.
We're good.
The birdash is close by.
I think I'm leveled up enough for birdash.
He's like level 34.
For sure.
Okay, it's this way.
Sure, what level are you at?
I might kill some bees right now.
Nice.
Actually, I can kill bees here.
How many...
How much honey do we need?
I think actually for the amount of breeding we're gonna do, we're actually probably gonna be okay on honey since it doesn't expire.
Oh okay, well...
We could use another bee though.
Use another bee or do you want...
Don't we need that queen bee for something?
No.
You have the queen bee boss.
That's what I'm thinking.
Elizabeth Bee or whatever her name is.
She was on the achievement list.
Oh god, oh god.
Leave me alone, leave me alone.
No, wrong one.
It's my fucking thing.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we need so many more miners in the base.
No one is mining anything.
At all.
Nah, we stream on Twitch.
We don't really need miners in chat.
I don't think.
I don't think we need any more miners.
I think we good, I think we good.
I think we good.
You gotta be 13 and over to be on Twitch right now?
I'm just saying.
Stop typing I'm 12 in the chat.
I swear to god.
I'm just saying, 13 and over.
Where is...
Where is Ash?
Germantide is here.
Oh wait, it's like further up.
Oh my god, they were so close to making the egg.
No.
They went to sleep.
It's alright, we got...
Wait, do we need the queen bee?
Do we need the queen bee?
It's a kill.
We have to kill.
I'm also day one achievement I think.
We have to kill and then the lies to be?
It's not priority.
Or the boss.
The boss or the normal?
Oh, okay.
Alright, cause I found there's a normal Elizabeth here.
We also need a little bit of milk.
Alright.
Guys, do not type that you're 12.
You can actually get banned.
You will actually get banned.
Don't type that.
Don't type it.
They want to be freed.
You will literally get banned like immediately.
They want to be freed from their cages.
Yeah.
Cagy wagey freedom.
Don't do it.
Don't do it bro.
Okay.
Uh...
How much time do we have left?
We're at the three hour mark by the way.
Yup.
Wait.
Oh, there's three hours left.
Oh my god.
I thought you said we've already been doing this three hours.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I was like, oh my god.
Can you imagine?
We only have like one clip in three hours.
That'd be so sad.
I started to panic.
I was like what the fuck.
I've done fucking nothing.
We've just been like trying to efficient size the base and got nothing else done.
Uh...
Okay.
For the weapons assembly line, where are we at with that?
Um, I'm just...
Do we need more ingots?
We need ingots.
We need a hundred ingots.
We have everything but...
I am making 184 ingots right now.
Yeah, like that's clearly the only thing we're missing.
Just the ingots.
Alright.
Do we have food?
I'm starving.
I'm on HP.
Something's gonna sneeze on me and I'll die.
Just like...
Fine.
Just don't get invaded.
Yeah, in that moment we get raided right there.
Yup.
Those five berries are for our pals.
Okay, they gotta split it between the 14 of them.
Well, now it's too bad.
Now they have zero berries.
Because I'm starving.
Lily's life matters more than the pal.
Exactly.
Oh wait, I can get some berries real quick.
I think it's done.
Surefour can make it.
Are you at the base right now?
Surefour or no?
I can make it.
I just need to catch this...
Catch the burr dash and then I can come over and make it.
You're good.
Whoa, get away from me.
Come on, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Real quick.
Where did this wheat come from?
Who's hungry?
Mind if I roll wheat?
Oh god, are they stuck somewhere?
I'll grab them.
Come on.
Come on, daytree.
Come on, Surefour's daydream.
I think.
That I still own for some reason.
The trade you had.
You had my chickpea and I got your daydream.
They're going to need to learn how to share real fast.
We got five berries.
Wait.
Oh shit.
You're level 22.
I think you'll be fine.
Actually, no.
You will not be fine.
Alright, we've got all the ingot are cooked.
Oh shit.
What?
What the fuck did it hit me?
Okay, I was like 200 miles away and it still hit me.
How much charcoal do we need?
Let me check.
Charcoal, charcoal, charcoal.
We need 100.
Alright, I'll just make it right now.
I need 100 of these.
Okay.
Go.
Wait, why am I making him in that?
Whatever, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It'll be fine.
Everything will be fine.
It's fine.
Mike baby?
Bubby.
Mike baby please?
Are we rehacking everything for the babies yet?
Uh, I just need one more cake.
But the cows ain't giving me milk.
Oh no.
That's the worst part.
They're not giving the milk.
They're on strike.
Oh shit, we're good.
We're good.
8%.
That should be enough, right?
Oh my god, why is it 8%?
Oh no, they're all hungry.
Alright, clip, clip, clip!
I got it for a dash!
Clip, clip, clip!
We got our first medium bosses.
Let's go!
I'll do it manually.
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip!
Alright, who's the next boss?
That is a level 38.
I am not high enough level for this shit.
I am only a level 33 baby.
Uh, did anybody grab the flowers?
I made like three of them, but they're not here.
They might be in the chest somewhere.
I didn't grab anything.
That's okay.
Panking!
Alright, let's see.
Oh, nevermind, it's working.
Okay, cool.
Just kidding.
I'm gonna replace you now.
Alright.
Cook!
You pelted a bad no.
Do we have the ingots?
Enough ingots to make the weapon now?
Alright, we do.
I'm gonna make it.
Do you want me to place it?
Where do you want me to place it?
Literally anywhere.
Maybe down the hill?
Alright, I'll place it down the hill.
I'm putting it down here.
I'm putting it at the edge of the barrier.
I can't fucking...
I can't use the barrier.
I'm using the boar because I'm making...
I'm using him to make pal's fears.
No boar.
I am...
Manual labor.
I'm building the weapon assembly line.
It is done in 20 seconds.
Done!
Alright, I'm putting berries in.
So they'll stop being hungry.
37 whole berries.
Nice.
There you guys go.
You don't even need to share.
Everybody gets one berry and a little bit.
What level is the...
To cook the food?
Do we need to unlock for the electric kitchen or whatever?
Also... 41.
41?
Sure.
What level are you now?
41.
Wait, we can make it now!
Come over here and make the pot whenever you're free.
I'll subgrade the base.
Those were two conflicting statements.
By the way, we can make a third base now.
Lilene, now I've got to make the grisbolt.
We have a...
We have improved furnace too.
Grisbolt time.
Let's go!
We need to build large pal bed.
Nice!
Let's go!
What level is large pal bed?
I'm gonna make grisbolt now.
We have improved furnace.
We need to make the big pal bed by the way.
The big blue one.
Well, sure, 4K can make it.
That's like the level 15 one.
So we need to make high quality cloth.
Which we should be able to do.
We should have enough.
Yeah, that's sure for a job.
Nice.
I'm gonna... which one is tower 2?
I'll try to get to tower 2.
Tower 2...
Powered.
Get the fuck back here.
What level is Lilene?
Awesome music.
Get the fuck back here.
Go back to the tent and breed.
What are you doing?
Stop running.
Go to the breeding station.
I think Azerope is stuck.
Assume your station.
Hold up, I'm gonna resummon Azerope.
She seems very...
There you go.
There.
Not productive.
Okay.
Um, can you please...
How long is your resting for?
Take care of the fucking berries so that people aren't hungry.
Thank you.
Stop resting.
Go work.
Okay, are they breeding?
And were they the... oh god.
What are you doing?
What are you doing out here, buddy?
Why aren't you breeding?
Are you guys both...
Wait a minute.
Is one of you a girl?
Nope.
Okay.
Uh, wait.
Do we have a...
Do we have a female panda?
Uh...
Trug.
Do we have one of those?
True gay.
Wait, do we have...
Can we get a moss...
A mossander who is like a lady?
I'm back.
Where do they spawn?
That's why the panda space is going extinct.
What?
What's going on?
Uh, we need a female mossander.
We need a female?
Why?
Because the wolf...
To make the Grisbolt.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
I do.
Because we're trying to make the Grisbolt.
Oh, so you need a female...
I need a female mossander.
Okay, I can get one right now.
We only have a male.
Do we have a male Mausanda?
We've only got male.
And we need a wolf with it?
We need a...
So we're trying to make Grisbolt.
I can find one right now.
What's the secondary?
The house.
The house and Dire house.
Rayhound.
The Rayhound.
We hatched a Rayhound, so...
Yeah.
Mausanda would be easier to get.
I can find a female.
I can find one right now.
I'm actually literally in the forest right now.
Okay, cool.
I'm Lily in the forest.
I'm in a forest right now.
Lily's in the forest?
What are you doing there?
I'm in the forest right now.
She's in the forest right now?
What's the order?
What time?
I'm trying to find Lily right now.
Lily, where are you?
Deforestation!
I can hear her.
She's...
I've been trying to find you for 20 years, Lily.
I'm trying...
Alright.
I'm at the Mausanda forest.
Cool, cool, cool.
Cool.
I just need to get a female.
I need to make more cake.
Let's see...
Uh, milk and flour.
Okay.
Need more milk.
I just need some milk.
Mausandra!
There's a lot of Lizabees.
Flying around.
So many Lizabees.
More milk please.
It has to be Mausandra here.
What do we need sure for to do it back at base again?
Oh, we need to make the large pal bed, but I don't...
You might be able to be that.
No, I'm not.
I'm not the level.
I mean, I could get there eventually.
Also, we have 60 gigas in base.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna come collect them soon.
Yeah, level 36.
We need to make high quality cloth as well.
When does that recipe unlock?
That's well, obviously below 480.
Let me see if I can make any.
Oh, we need a cooking station.
Yeah, we need sure for it to be back for cooking station so we can make the burgers and stuff.
Yeah.
High quality cloth is also 36.
I think like priority right now is the cooking station because that's like two achievements done.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you can come back with that.
But the cooking station requires us to make like, hold on.
The cooking station is like, you have to get the circuit boards to make the electric kitchen.
You have to be level 41 and then you need to have refined ingot circuit boards.
Well, so it's...
You got refined ingots?
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
Circuit boards is the main problem because you can't like pure quartz.
You have to kind of just like get.
That's getting taken care of.
Okay, pure quartz.
Okay.
I...
Yeah.
And that's in the ice area.
Ice pile.
Yeah.
Okay.
I can get that later.
What is wrong with this pile?
I found four fucking dudes.
Where are the female Masandras?
Holy shit.
This is why pandas are endangered.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many fucking bees.
They have no bitches.
They got no bitches.
There's no bitches anywhere.
Where did all the guys come from?
I'm literally just flying around trying to fucking kill them.
Find the bitches.
What do I need to build while I'm here?
Pallet bed and high quality cloth if you can.
The large pallet bed.
Both at level 36.
We need two large pallet beds and also cloth.
Do we have the material?
Oh no, we need the high quality.
You're the only one who can make the material and the bed.
We need to make two of them as well.
Do we have enough wool?
Yeah, we have a lot of wool.
Yeah, we're fucking good at wool.
Just like in real life, it's so hard to find women.
Am I in the area for this now?
No comment.
Maybe that's like a Malzandra Tinder or something.
Just swipe a bit to find a female.
Wait, what are you going to say sure for?
We have a bunch of coal to make carbon fiber.
Have we been making coal?
I think we... I just dropped like a hundred coal.
We have.
No?
We need to make more.
All charcoal, fuck.
No, I've been... I've been making... I've been doing all breeding.
I should fly out and just get that started though.
Oh, we don't have coal at all?
Oh shit.
Once I make... once I make this cake, I will go down there and start making it.
I'll go make the base for coal.
I guess I don't care if I get hit.
I need to make a tropical outfit.
Oh shit.
I've basically become a glorified pal.
Because all you're doing is working.
The past hour and a half I'm just like, yeah, I'm mining and chopping trees and working the pal spear bench.
Yup.
My favourite pal, Lily.
That's my favourite pal.
Don't worry, that's how some people are on other teams too.
You're not the only one.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure about four people in each team.
Yeah, he was like, well, one of them at least is banished to pal the room.
Alright, I'm gonna... since we don't have the mossandra, I'm gonna fly out and start making the coal base.
Yeah, yeah, just go make that.
Finally!
I'm just gonna keep trying to find a fucking mossandra.
What a type of hands.
Oh shit, Vanworm, you're fucking dying.
Vanworm... better than Vanworm, they've got the... what is it called?
The beacon?
Oh, but I'm not level 34!
I'm not level 34.
Okay.
That sucks.
Where the fuck are you?
All I see are the fucking gorillas.
Alright, I'm gonna leave... I'm gonna leave Ignis here.
And take back this fucking panda.
And let me grab...
My worm.
There has to be a female somewhere!
Alright, uh... you suggested the place by the Anubis.
Um...
Let me just take a look at my thing.
No, don't shoot him, please.
Oh, the first one is where I built my base.
Hmm.
But this...
I found a...
The one near the Anubis is the base one.
Yes!
Oh yeah, you go anywhere.
The Anubis is technically in like a less dangerous location.
It's only got six nodes.
They said that there's a place in the deep sand dunes that has eight nodes.
And it's like a little bit of a cold, but I don't know if it really matters that much.
Well, the first picture I linked is a place where there's a waypoint.
And you can fly to the top left mountain.
And you don't even need to make a base.
Oh, okay.
That's convenient.
Alright, I'm just gonna try to get over there then.
Cause I don't have any waypoints out that way yet.
Yeah, just head there.
Negative 125, negative 84, negative 125...
125, 84...
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I got the...
Please don't be dismal!
Oh!
Alright, I got the female.
I'm just gonna put it in base whenever you're ready to breed it.
I don't...
I'm just gonna...
Actually, I can breed it for us.
Oh, you got it?
Yeah, I'll do the breeding for us.
Oh, we can breed it then?
Yeah, yeah.
Put it in the...
I've got the wolf.
I'll put the wolf up.
I did it.
I got the female.
Now I can...
Fuck!
Okay, I got the wolf.
Give me a second.
Alright.
Thank you.
I'm just getting... heading to the waypoint and then I'll pass over... pass it over.
Is that all we need for breeding?
Or do we need anything else?
Yeah, yeah.
Nope.
That's all we need.
There's cake in there already.
Um, we just need them to make a grizzbolt.
Alright.
Heading down.
Making my way downtown.
At the two hour mark, we should just do the dungeons.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Alright, I gotta go... I gotta leave base for a bit and go make the other base.
Alright.
I'm just going to put...
Actually, you can... you can do the breeding right now since you're here and I'm here.
Okay.
Alright, cool.
Um...
Who do we get rid of?
You can get rid of... I'll just move this guy out for right now.
There you go.
Open spot.
Alright, I'm gonna go do the second tower.
No, come back.
No, come here.
Where you going?
Let's do the second tower.
Come back!
Okay, I got him.
Faction tower.
Faction tower to location.
Let's go.
Let's go breed.
It is time for you to breed.
Powered.
Where the fuck is the second tower?
Can't be assigned?
What do you mean can't be assigned?
Yes you can.
What do you mean?
Sometimes the hitbox seems to clip over other shit.
Breeding failed.
The what hitbox?
The like when you try to assign the power sometimes the hitbox seems to overlap.
Yeah?
with other shit.
Oh.
What the fuck does that mean?
Hold on.
It can't be assigned.
That's weird.
With breeding where you have to take out... you have to like put two females in and to like make it unbug.
I don't know the bugs are really annoying.
Yeah that sounds really annoying.
It says it needs it's not compatible with cooling.
Wait what?
I don't... what the fuck does that mean?
What?
What does that Are you fucking kidding?
What the fuck does that mean?
There's three misandras in front of me.
I fucking...
Okay.
I literally just found more misandras.
Now it says nobody's at the breeding... okay.
Just take them out and put it back in.
Yeah I'm taking them out.
And that should fix it.
I assign you to a tree.
I assign you to literally whatever.
Just get out of there.
Okay.
Again.
Go Lily.
Go Lily Go Lily pal.
It keeps saying I can't put the the panda in there because of instability with cooling.
Huh?
Yeah just try and put like two females in there.
That one is a female though.
Just unbug it.
Just unbug it and then see what happens.
Yeah the panda is a female though so it should be able to...
Okay.
If it says that coolant it usually means that they're on break and they need to wander around for a bit.
That's what some of my chat says.
Oh okay okay okay.
They're too madged to fuck.
Yeah.
They need a break.
Can I like force them to sit in the old tent?
Whoa.
Whoa whoa whoa.
Love is supposed to be natural.
Hey hey hey.
Consent is sexy.
I said to go on a spa date.
I said go on a spa date.
I didn't say that.
Whoa.
I don't know if you're a right fit for this team now.
What the heck?
After all I've done for this team?
HR needs to speak to you real quick after that.
When did we hire HR?
Ever since you talk about consent.
Man.
Not again.
Alright.
I'm gonna see if I can fucking do this boss battle.
Okay I can put her in here now.
So that's it.
That's like a good sign maybe?
Wait I wanna take my cake back.
Alright.
I don't know if I'm high enough level for this but we'll see.
Back to start.
We don't have a choice.
Trust the process chat.
Trust the process.
Trust the pal.
Trust Lily.
She is a certified pal.
Best pal.
I'm a certified pal.
I've been accepted into the pal world.
Look I'm one of them.
I can't even tell the difference.
I don't know if I'm like high enough level for this boss.
Alright.
Maybe now they don't need a break?
We gonna find out.
67 ,000?
Okay wait maybe?
Oh my god I'm fighting Lily.
Don't fight Lily?
Lily?
Join us?
What's happening?
We're just mad!
Come on, let's go!
Yo, beat them the fuck up.
Yeah, I'm gonna beat the shit out of you.
Beat the fuck up.
So I need to talk to HR, but that's fine?
Look, I've been...
Look, you're too new here to do that, you know?
You don't know that I am, but...
You're too new here right now.
You have to be more established to be able to beat up Lily.
Alright, it looks like it unbugs.
Aw hell yeah!
They're in love!
Whoops.
Wait, no, I'm not trying to pet you right now.
Please let me Orion you, what the heck?
Just kidding, I think I just put both of the...
Wait, yes!
Hell yeah!
Alright, cool.
They're making a baby.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
While they do that, I'm gonna go make the coal base.
Please.
Please, Lily.
Leave me alone.
Oh no.
Alright.
Oh no, I'm poisoned.
I need some food for myself, and then I can go...
Can I make another cake?
I actually don't know if I can kill this in time.
Oh no!
I need egg!
I need egg.
Oh no, we need fucking... what the...
We need so much stuff.
It's never done!
It's never over!
It's fucking never done.
Now I know what they feel like.
Now you know why they have zero rights.
Now you know.
Now I know, what the fuck?
And they'll never get rights.
This is terrible.
This is capitalism.
Welcome to capitalism.
Enjoy your stay, cause you have no other choice.
I enjoyed my stay, I enjoyed my time.
Thank you, capitalism.
Oh my god, I don't think I can kill the second tower girl.
She's way too strong.
She wicked.
My fucking towers are too fucking weak.
She's like, oh no, she's too strong.
Oh god, sweeper please, sweep sweep sweep.
She's like, oh no, she'll beat me up.
She's gonna beat me up.
Sweep sweep sweep.
I would hate to know where that tower is where this girl's beating you up.
I just want to know so I can avoid it.
That sounds terrible, you know, like oh my goodness.
Come on sweeper, you're so tanky.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
I'm at 40,000 out of 70.
We're slowly getting there.
All right, cool, cool, cool.
All right.
I'm so close.
Go penking.
You're our last hope.
Do we have the other, the Anubis yet?
Uh, they're both hatching.
They're still not hatched?
No, they take 40 minutes each.
Jesus Christ, they're so fucking tanky.
I know, that's why I've been stuck at the base.
I've just been doing breeding.
Wait, is the Anubis the longest one to breed?
Or is the others?
The large eggs are all the same.
They're all the same.
We've got one more minute left on the first Anubis egg.
Okay.
Which is true.
I think that's good because then I can put in the next egg.
So...
Which is the...
Because we need to make sure we have enough time to breed the other ones too.
Yeah.
I think we're gonna be like giddy giddy okay.
It just depends on...
Well, we can make a third incubator.
We need one for the Grizz that I'm trying to hatch.
Okay.
I can make it the moment I fucking beat up this Lily.
I'm gonna have to walk the fucking walk, fam.
I see.
Why are you so tanky, Lily?
Yeah.
Just die already.
It makes me a very hard to walk chopper man.
Lily, I need these points, Lily.
Do it for the team, Lily.
Can't even get the proper beating here.
What the fuck, man?
Oh my gosh.
These are the worst conditions I have to live with.
All
right.
Wait, we're gonna check it.
You guys ready?
You ready?
You ready to clip?
Three, two, one.
Incubation.
Incubation complete.
I'm pulling out the huge rocky egg.
If it's not Anubis, I...
Hey!
Clip, clip, clip!
Anubis!
There's our first Anubis.
Clip, clip, clip.
All right.
Oh shit.
This is the last tree that I chopped 1500 wood.
Jesus Christ.
That should last us a good 10 minutes.
.
I need more.
I really need eggs.
Did I say you killed Verdash already?
Yeah, I killed Verdash already.
Verdash is the only thing I killed.
Or like captured.
Verdash is the only one I captured.
Gosh.
Hell yeah.
Okay, cool.
All right.
I'm leaving that cake.
I'm gonna grab the egg and then I need to go do coal.
Oh shit.
Oops, daydream.
Bye bye.
Please have baby.
Okay, they're gonna go to sleep.
Yeah, fuck that.
I'm gonna go.
Oh shit.
Come on, Vanworm.
Do we have the crusher to make fragments?
Yeah, we have the crusher already being used.
Nice.
Oh my god, 20k.
Come on, 20k in four minutes, please.
What the heck is it?
Not the life.
Is this the crusher?
Yes.
All right, pals.
I respect that you need food.
But I also need food, so...
We're always gonna need food.
I'm gonna just take some of that.
Oh shit.
I'm back to rock.
Back to rock you go.
Back to being a pal.
Yeah.
I love being a pal.
Go, go Lily, go.
All right, flying out.
Please.
Why are you so tanky?
Wait, do I need tropicals?
Probably need tropicals.
Chandra outfit, no.
Back to rock.
I need my tropical clothes.
How much rock have you farmed in total?
I'm actually curious, Lily.
Oh my goodness, like, I will pay good money to have someone go back and count all of what I've farmed.
Just accumulate everything.
Oh no.
Just so I can feel accomplished.
My dad is a fan.
We're done because I wanted to know how you're doing.
Well, we got the Anubis now.
And he's like flying through rock.
Nice.
That's good.
So that should help a little.
Oh no, I can't even aim anymore.
What the fuck is going on?
No.
Noob down.
Who's that?
Better pals for mining?
I don't know.
I'm level 23.
What happened, Sherpoi?
I don't have any options.
I was saying you're a noob to keep an aim.
Oh no, I'm not a noob.
I'm almost killed.
I almost killed her.
I have two minutes left to kill it.
Sherpoi, why are you hungry?
He's like, mother, I crave sustenance.
We don't have time for you to be hungry right now.
Oh god.
Oh man.
I am basically a farming pal.
Wait, can I just take Anubis and manually farm with him?
Is that gonna be faster than Rush War?
I have no idea.
Maybe.
I feel like this is the fastest Anubis is the fastest.
Clip, clip, clip!
I finished tower two!
Let's go!
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Okay, my entire team is hungry.
I didn't name these palts.
Oh my god.
If I named him, he would be called yeast infection.
What?
Did I explain?
Excuse me?
Is there something that randomly popped into my mind?
What can I say?
It's just a little fun name I came up with.
So fun.
You can change it if you don't like it.
It's very fun.
So fun.
Yeah.
It's festive.
I don't know.
We can name him like UTI or something.
Oh yeah.
That's a really good option.
What is going on with your life right now?
I don't know.
HDMI cable?
Question mark.
That's a good name.
Is everything okay?
I think so.
Yeah.
Why are people worried?
I'm a little worried.
I mean I wasn't 30 seconds ago but I will admit.
Whoa.
Come on.
You're convinced now.
Like it's a fitting name.
Let's see.
Oh wait now I saw food in this.
Yeah man I'm so upset my parents didn't name me UTI.
That could have been my life.
You could have had it all.
I don't think VTubers exist.
I need like 9...
Let me try and find my...
Where the fuck is the crusher?
I really want it to be called Samsung Galaxy man.
S7 Edge.
I need to try and find the...
Where's the crusher?
Is that the bottom?
Crusher is in the corner close to the cliff.
In the back?
Yeah by the large cliff.
By the large cliff.
I'm going to try and find the crusher.
Uh...
Where the fuck?
Oh there it is.
Alright I can make...
Another incubator.
Nice.
If you guys need it.
Also I had to leave...
Before they finished breeding because it's night time.
But if you're there...
In the daytime can you grab the egg?
Um...
We need another incubator.
What eggs?
Is there any eggs right now that can be...
Put in the incubator?
They're really close to giving birth.
But they went to sleep.
Okay so...
Wait no there's an egg here.
Oh sweet alright.
Can you pop that in the...
Make another incubator if possible and pop that in there.
A huge electric egg.
I'm putting that in.
Alright here we go.
And then we just have to hope that it's the right gender.
Otherwise we gotta get another relaxasaurus too.
Alright.
I mean relaxasaurus is easy to catch.
So I'm fine with that.
Alright let's see how much time.
Seven minutes till...
Okay...
I'm trying to look at what we need right now.
Um...
Shurifor what are you doing right now?
I'm doing stuff.
Oh...
I don't have to cry.
It's okay.
It doesn't have to be first place.
I am.
What are you doing?
What are you doing right now Shurifor?
I was trying to see if the high quality cloth was finish making but it's not.
Now I'm waiting for day time.
And I'm leveling.
You're leveling?
What level are you right now?
I'm 44.
44?
Actually that's the max we need for the base so...
Let's see...
I'm trying to see...
How many hours do we have left?
We're 23 minutes till the 2 hour mark.
So we need to...
Let's see...
Trying to see...
Maximum...
I'm trying to see what I have to do right now.
I'm going to try and catch some of the day 1...
I'm going to do some of the day 1 bosses then.
Um...
Just to faster level up.
Because for the higher level...
Bosses I need...
Ultra spheres I think.
Yeah.
Wait what am I doing?
Okay.
Let's see...
I'm going to do the day 1 stuff so I can level up to at least level...
Level 40?
And then...
Okay you didn't get the...
Prawn cherry right?
I don't remember which ones we...
Have we done nightwing?
Oh there's a list somewhere in the discord.
Actually my mods might be able to post it again.
But they have a picture of all the stuff we did on day 1.
Yeah can you show me what we were missing in day...
Can PPMOD show me what we were missing in day 1 for the day 1?
Yeah.
So I can like breeze through it real quick for us.
Um... I know like the prawn cherry we haven't...
MVPPs.
Alright let me look up...
You're my MVPPs.
Thank you.
The global...
Events whatever the most points anyways.
Did we get the fen lope?
Have we done the fen lope yet?
Fen lope was bugged when I tried to...
Oh yeah I remembered.
Okay I'm gonna get the uni vault then.
You haven't done the uni vault yet right?
I don't think so.
Alright I'll get that.
Uhhhh the uni vault is...
20 points.
That's 20 points that we can get.
Oh wait I need to get my...
I forgot to grab my...
Fucking...
Vanworm.
Vanworm are you done healing yourself yet?
No.
I have one more.
Alright I guess I'll stay here and...
Help out with the wood.
Do we need wood or rock?
More.
Let me see.
How's Anubis pulling?
He's doing amazing.
Let's go!
I'll get some rock for us then.
While we...
I'll get some rock cause I don't have enough.
I don't have my vanworm to...
Grease through.
Actually I'll just fucking ride the dog.
I won't waste time.
I'll ride the dog over.
Oh shit.
It's broken.
Uhhhh...
Oh crap.
Baby you do much.
For now.
Oh please don't fall vanworm.
I know you can make it to this cliff.
Someone can hatch the other Anubis right now.
The other Anubis can be hatched.
I'm not at the base yet.
So Lily you should hatch it.
Alright let's go.
Chet says he's butter mining as well.
Go make him work.
The moment he's born that's his job.
The moment he's born.
Hello baby anyway.
Into the mines you go.
Into the mines you go baby.
Put up the yearn for the mines.
You guys are laughing.
You guys are laughing but that's what they did with children on farms.
Put up the yearn for the mines.
That's true.
Into the mines you go.
Into the mines you go baby.
As soon as you're twelve you're gonna be working on the farm.
As God intended.
Perfect for the mines.
Alright.
Look if God didn't want them to work in the mines.
Then kids should not exist.
You sure?
I'm 100% sure.
I think I went past where I was supposed to go.
Wait no I didn't.
Yes and my parents should have put me in the mines.
Born to roam free.
Forced to mine.
You see it hasn't been a bad thing.
Also if we have the eggs we also need to make one more cake.
If anybody's on base.
And can make a cake.
I can probably queue one up if you have one.
Okay.
Yeah I'm just.
Oh wait we have a cake.
Oh I'm going to get the relaxaura.
You guys can catch the relaxaura.
Catch some because then if we don't have the right gender.
It won't matter.
Yeah yeah somebody.
Lily's there.
Lily it's your job.
It's time Lily.
I kept the balls away.
There's more balls in the base.
I'm dead.
What you're dead?
I'm fucking dead.
I'm on level I just one shot me.
I fell through the map.
Lily no.
What happened?
They've got the list in discord by the way.
Okay nice.
Under the sea.
She's swimming but she dead.
I have a uni vault if we need it later.
To the shadow realm.
Wild but only good.
You sure about that?
Yes.
Mine.
Back to work.
Work work.
It's time to get back to work.
Work work work.
Ow.
Sweep sweep sweep.
Sweep sweep.
That was fun.
Let's have some more of some time in some time soon.
Okay you really do sound like the voice from the game though.
You really do sound like the voice from the game though.
You can fess up.
You can just tell me that you're the guy from...
Dude I would be a sick voice actor.
You have 88 balls.
Get a voice reel right now.
And apply.
I don't know how that fucking works.
Don't I have to join like some voice actors guild or some shit?
No I don't think so.
I think... use your clout.
No I ain't got clout.
Just be like I'm a voice actor.
I'm a voice actor.
Done.
It's that easy.
It's just that easy.
If you never try...
If you never try you'll never get employed.
I don't wanna try.
Why not?
I just want everything to be given to me.
Alright I gotta talk to Cole.
Spoken like a true content creator.
I just need to make sure he doesn't fucking die.
Alright come on.
18% Clip clip clip.
I got the uni vault.
I got uni vault.
Nice.
How to become a voice actor.
Step 1.
Declare intent.
It's just that easy.
Amazing.
I am voice actor.
Hire me.
Done.
Please accept me.
I'm so happy for you dude.
This is my follower count.
I'm pretty sure we have enough dragon types to do the dragon petting thing.
I think we have enough water dude.
I think we have enough water too.
I'm pretty sure.
I think we should start petting at an hour mark.
I think at 2 hour mark we should do dungeons.
I met somebody's dead stuff location.
Are you high enough level for the...
Oh wait you might be at my dead stuff.
You are that's my dead stuff.
Oh you're in my guild so yeah probably.
I don't know if there's anything useful in there.
I've recovered ever since but you can scout.
I'm trying to look for a waypoint.
A dive of like pretty much nothing.
What do we need for hyperspears?
Oh yeah I took it all.
What mats do you need for hyperspears?
Let me see.
I'm looking for...
Cement.
How do I make cement?
6 coal 1 stone.
6 coal 1 ore.
Okay okay.
What mats do we need for hyperspears?
I don't know what you're sure for.
I got a cover but I can't kill a mob.
I will just make sure we have the materials.
There's no fast travel over here.
Wait what?
Also your mods said they made a list but where is it?
Uhhhh...
There's no list in here.
I can just copy paste it.
I think they didn't even post it.
No I think they...
I think they posted in the wrong chat.
There you go.
Okay.
Alright I need...
Chill it?
Can you give me a list of those we need to do?
Cause that's easier for me.
For day 1.
Cause that's easier for me to keep track.
I'm gonna capture 2 black mercuteers.
For us now.
Cause that's something I can do.
Let me take a look at the DM.
I'm gonna set the base now on the coal spot.
Once I get a shot then some...
Twilight Dunes.
I need the boss.
Well I have...
Twilight Dunes is on this little ridge.
88 gigaspears?
I can't make hyper.
Yeah yeah.
Once I get the refined metal I'll make the hyper.
How do you get refined metal again?
We need coal.
We still need coal.
Alright.
I'm about to mine so I'm gonna say I can.
I'm gonna put away...
Okay back to stone.
Nice.
I'm gonna put all this in.
Black Mercuteers are tough.
Well I have to do it for the team.
Sandworm.
I know I'm starving.
I don't know.
Whoever told me it's easier to manually mine with Anubis.
I feel like you're...
I feel like my boar was more effective.
Maybe you're not doing it right.
I feel like this should get all of these stones.
Maybe.
Okay hold up.
Wait let me put him into the base cause I feel like he's more useful in here.
I'm starting.
To do the stone mining in here for now.
While I'll get my manual stone.
Wait that's not...
That's not coal.
Um.
They don't need this.
So I'm gonna eat it.
Oh no stop being hungry.
Isn't he a low level?
That shouldn't matter for mining.
He's not fighting a pal.
He's just mining.
Ohhhh.
Hold on my boar.
Where is one of the black marketeers?
Let's see.
141?
141.
404?
It's supposed to be right here.
Hold on.
I'm trying to like figure out where the black marketeers are.
There's one right below our base.
Oh wait.
Yeah I'm trying to.
Oh it's this thing right here.
Okay I got it.
Okay I see it.
I found the spot.
Is this it?
Is this the marker that?
I think so.
Alright I'm gonna see if I can catch him.
Uhhh.
No that's not you.
Alright.
I don't know what level they are.
What level are they?
The one underneath is 40.
The rest are like 50 I think.
I'm 36.
I think that'll be fine.
It's fine.
It shouldn't be that bad right?
Oh.
Well that tokotoko is dead.
Yeah.
Where am I?
I'm walking the wrong way.
I always fly the wrong way.
Cole can't be assigned.
What?
I need some wood.
I need hyperspears to catch the marketeers.
I'll get you wood after.
Probably.
Does a gigaspear not work?
I'm getting some right now.
It might just be a really really really low chance.
Uhhh.
You know I'm gonna risk it.
I'm gonna risk it.
It'll be fine.
I have enough gigaspears to fucking risk the catch.
Wait what the fuck?
I have a grenade?
Throwing granata.
Nice.
I tried to go to punch and then a grenade came out.
I was like ugh.
Back to you.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Hello.
You got her stuff?
You're welcome.
Alright here we go.
It's time to risk this.
We'll be fine.
Alright.
Cole.
I put a pal box out here.
Now we've got a fast travel.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Go do your thing.
I was told we need wood.
I'll get wood.
Oh he has a pal too?
Yeah.
And a machine gun.
Oh my god my pal's almost dead.
Alright I stopped risking it.
You know, sure this is your job.
I'm not doing this.
How many jobs do I have?
Shit.
This one too.
Alright.
He is way too strapped.
I'm so good at mining that I've got in my party right now.
Wait.
Can they not mine the coal?
I can come mine the coal.
I put Tom bat out here but Tom bat's not doing anything.
I need more nails for the large power bed.
You need more nails?
Okay.
We need ore for that right?
Yeah.
Just iron.
No we need ingots.
Ingot's okay.
You can queue up some ingots.
I held off because I wasn't sure how much we need for the refined.
They can mine coal but you have to take away the mining station.
I just made a bunch of refined ingots.
No you need level 3 for coal.
You need level 3 pals.
Mining.
That's what they said.
Okay okay.
Who can we get that's level 3?
I'll just...
Anubis?
Anubis is but I wanna try something.
Okay I'm gonna need one of the Anubis's here to start getting coal.
Where can I make Palmer?
Palmer?
On the map.
You'll need tropical clothes to come out here though.
You need Palmer?
Sure for?
But I have your stuff so if you had tropical clothes then...
I did not have that.
Okay.
It's time for Google.
I'll just very quickly try something and see if that works.
I have chat.
You have chat?
I have indeed mine coal so if you can make me clothes I can already get started.
Alright let's go.
Okay I'll make you that.
Alright.
Okay.
What's that?
PP mud!
You... information is not correct!
You're in for...
Wait actually...
Wait Univolt.
Yeah we captured Univolt.
Yeah.
What do you mean you don't see a clip?
I said clip clip clip!
Your mod...
Your mod fucking missed the Univolt.
Here Shy Lily I'm just gonna give you mine.
Okay okay.
Can you bring it to me?
Yeah I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna drop this... I'm gonna like drop it on the ground.
Eh.
Oh god.
Is everything okay there?
Come on!
You can do it!
I'm Q-Comfort!
What the fuck is this game?
I'm gonna fly back and I'll come back and make some stuff.
What do we need here?
I'll finish the coal and I'll return to base.
Okay.
And then I'll do rock.
Okay okay.
I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna make...
another trap of it.
Sweet!
Can you guys link the...
the clip of me catching...
Univolt for the mod?
Oh niggah.
Alright.
How's it going with the breeding?
Uh...
Well I'm not there.
I'm fucking doing bosses.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm taking a look.
Okay.
The Narcissist is here.
Alright.
So we have...
We already have this one going.
We've got a Grizz that's set to hatch.
Uh... So I think we're good.
Let's see...
I'm getting the Lunaris for us.
We're at the 12th place right now.
But we also have like not been getting...
doing a lot of points of...
Trust the process!
Give me your fucking meat.
My pal team's hungry.
Alright.
Uh... Now that they bred...
We don't actually need this one out anymore.
I can't believe Surefour and I have not found a single lucky pal.
I'm not lucky.
I've established this state.
Yeah but I haven't either!
I've not heard a single Shiny!
This is actually crazy.
We haven't heard anything.
Alright.
I'm gonna take one of the Anubises.
We've got two Anubis right?
Yeah.
Wait.
Lily do you think I should bring one of the Anubises out there or no?
Honestly just let them do the stone.
Cause we are also low on stone.
Like chronically always.
And I'll be getting this cool...
done before respawns.
Alright.
Yeah if we had time it'd be great if we could make...
a second... like another Anubis.
But we just... there's no way.
It takes like 40 minutes minimum.
Oh shit that's crazy.
Cause you can make Anubis like...
breed with Anubis.
And we have a female and male Anubis.
But it's not gonna happen today.
I don't think you guys have time for breeding...
an Anubis.
No way.
Absolutely not.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I am basically an Anubis.
True.
We're Anubis.
You're basically the pal.
Anubis at home.
Wait.
Uh...
Sure.
Can you make the large pal beds?
We don't have the nails yet.
Oh we don't have nails?
Are we low on nails?
Yeah.
Okay I'll do that.
We should have lots of ore that we can make into ingots.
I didn't touch the ingots yet.
Cause I'm pretty sure we need higher quality stuff.
So I can queue up stuff.
Yeah we need to make...
That's what we're getting the coal for.
That's what the coal's for.
Alright.
Come on fan worm.
Come on!
I need to repair some of my stuff.
Okay nice.
Should be it.
Oh shit I'm so fucked up right now.
Bro I'm so fucked up.
I'm so fucked up at the moment.
I am so fucked up right now.
Oh my god.
I have the board hit.
That's my most crazy.
My pal world is so intense.
Shut up.
I'm so fucking liiiiive.
No I'm actually almost dead guys.
Oh no.
I just touched it even though it was lagging.
Oh please.
Bro gamer.
It lagging so hard.
Okay I'm good.
Okay clip clip clip.
PP bots clip clip clip.
I don't know what to say again.
Clip clip clip.
Thank god Lunaris.
Holy shit.
That was like one HP.
Not even close baby.
Wait.
Why am I doing this?
You should be.
I'm waiting.
Come here you big guy.
What are you even doing?
What are you doing?
Come here.
Okay he's stuck.
Oh no I'm too far.
Nice refined ingot.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Am I close now?
Ah.
Dammit please I'm busy.
Dammit please.
Dammit please fuck off I'm busy.
Oh my goodness.
There's an Anubis walking around.
Oh wait.
That's a boss.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Get away from that Anubis.
He's fucking 47 now mate.
Don't get close to that one.
Oh my god another Anubis.
Another Anubis.
What the heck.
You guys.
You guys catch this for us?
Oh my god.
Like I'm not even lying right now.
But I just saw an Anubis.
Oops.
I pressed the wrong button.
We're going to the skate park.
I didn't want to go to the skate park.
Okay.
Oh my god where the fuck is...
I'm trying to find like a...
waypoint so I can come home.
Okay.
Let me bring some stuff to you.
How we doing?
How many coal have you already gotten?
I have mined all the coal.
I'm picking it up and I'll let you know how much it is.
I'm going to start looking for the dungeons now.
So we can get the dungeons done.
Okay.
We have the brown cherry.
There's actually a couple areas with the coal ore in that area.
If you actually just want to like go and mine the rest of them.
That would actually be super duper freaking helpful.
Let me send you...
The map is already in the discord but I'll grab it again.
Okay I have 800 coal.
Okay.
Oh 800 coal.
That's a lot of coal.
I told you I'm a pile of...
We need more coal for...
For sure for like...
Gun stuff don't we?
Okay yeah yeah.
I don't need too much coal for that.
Holy shit.
That was what I was most worried about.
That's why Lily's our best pal.
Don't worry I'm best pal.
Best pal Lily!
She's our level 50 pal right there.
Right there.
Do I count?
Can we like...
Sign me up for achievement?
Level 50 pal?
Level 500 points right there?
Right?
There's not actually a good part but like...
You know.
Alright we need quartz.
Alright then what should I do right now?
This egg is gonna hatch.
And next I need to make the orcerc.
So once we have Grizzbolt hatched.
How long till Grizz hatches?
Grizz is in five.
Yeah.
But we will clip in 20 seconds.
Clip clip clip!
I got Bronsherry!
Bronsherry's done.
Okay we need to start making a bunch of refined ingot.
Like basically we just have to make like a fuck ton of refined ingots.
How do we make refined ingots?
I'll take care of that.
Yeah that's like the number one thing that we need.
We need... how many refined ingots do we need?
We need like hundreds.
Okay I can start with 87 for now.
Alright.
Lylene was born!
Clip clip clip!
Oh Lily's... yay!
Successful breeding!
We got another Lily!
Let's go!
We can replace her!
Alright we're gonna swap out this inferior Leah with this superior Lily.
Oh my god we can finally replace her!
Yippee!
Your position has become redundant.
Now it doesn't matter he gets sick.
You have become...
useless.
No worth.
Thank you.
Goodbye.
You don't get a pension after.
Rest in peace you won't be missed.
We need milk and egg but it doesn't really fucking matter so it's all good.
Alright next thing we need to breed!
First off why have you just been in here doing nothing?
Fuck off.
Do we have enough time to breed the rest or?
Yeah!
Yeah we're good.
We're gonna be good.
Cause we still have to do the other stuff so...
I'm just a little worried cause...
The last thing we need to breed is pretty much once this grisbolt is done in four minutes.
If we have the correct sex then I can immediately breed the last one.
If we don't then I'm gonna need somebody to get another relaxosaurus.
I'll show you... I'll see what relaxosaurus I have.
But I'm gonna maybe go try to get pure crystals maybe?
I have a male relaxosaurus right now on me.
Maybe you guys need a male.
So hopefully this is a female otherwise...
Let's see...
I need to fucking replace some of my pals in here.
Univolt...
Lunaris... I do not need...
I need 40 nails.
Don't do it.
Let me see where they're at.
We're at 26 nails.
Uhhhh...
I think I can do another...
I can do a...
I can kill the mammorast right?
Yeah I can.
Let's see...
Where is the mamm... Is the mammorast the one in the beginning?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well let's see if I can kill it.
Let's see if I can kill this.
If you need help...
Um... Good luck.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
If you need help...
No one can.
Good luck.
No one can help you but if you need it...
Goodbye.
Let's see... Go VanWorm!
Go!
It's alright.
Alright nails are done.
Put him in the box.
It's fine.
Uh... Apparently...
It's not... Are they in a box?
I'm about to put him in a box.
Yeah.
Oh okay.
I... The box was full.
Okay they're in the box now.
Alright I'm just gonna put this somewhere.
Oop.
Oh this boss is easy!
I'm so fucking tanky now!
Or my pals are tanky.
Go pal go!
Go!
Whoa!
I'm so good at Dark Soulings now.
I'm so good at Dark Souls.
Two minutes on that one.
Alright we need to make circuit boards so I'm just gonna go get some Pure Quartz.
Yeah.
Chat do you know if there's like any particularly really good spot for Pure Quartz?
Or is it literally just wander around the mountain?
Oop.
I know there's that lake.
The unthawable lake has a lot of them.
Alright I'll head to the lake.
We'll see.
Please.
Please Unifold.
Why are you so weak?
Okay and then we...
Okay two pal beds I'll help build.
Leave me alone.
Oh my god please!
You built two of them right?
Yeah.
Did you build two of these pal beds?
Okay cool.
Getting upgraded now.
We should be able to level up the base now, right?
What level is our base now?
Alright, we're like...
The build for 19 will speed up how long it'll take for us to do 17 and 18.
I did the math last night.
And it's just better to just do the 19 base objective first.
Alright.
Come on.
Alright, base upgrade done!
Alright, refined metal chest.
Nice.
Come on, Memorous!
Let me check refined metal chest.
Refined metal chest.
Okay, we need a refined ingot.
Nail it.
Nail wood.
Okay, can you build us the refined metal chest?
What level is it?
It is level 39.
Okay.
That should be fine.
The next thing we're gonna need, we're going to need a bunch of circuit boards and refined ingots.
So I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna get the grisbolt situation figured out first, but then I'm gonna go try to farm the quartz.
I'm just trying to catch my Memorous.
Why is it 5%?
Holy shit.
This Memorous is taking fucking forever.
Well, it's not a Memorous active.
It's a Memorous.
That's why it takes so long.
Jesus Christ.
I'm still at...
Oh my god.
I think I definitely need a hyperspear or some shit.
What are the mats for hyperspear?
I have a lot of them.
We have all the mats.
I just can't queue them.
We need circuit boards.
We need circuit boards to build the sphere assembly line too.
Okay.
So Memorous is caught.
Clip, clip, clip.
I got it.
Feed your pal.
Oh my god.
I did it.
Never mind.
Clip, clip, clip.
Alright, cool.
Now...
I'm gonna try to find dungeons for us now because we...
Next is production assembly line.
We need to do dungeons at the two hour mark and we're at the two hour mark.
So I'm gonna try to find dungeons.
I'm gonna try to find the dungeons and you guys do your thing.
Check your...
Um...
All our eggs are incubated.
I'm gonna hatch them.
We can make a third base by the way so we can teleport everybody to the dungeons.
We got Grisbolt.
Do we need a Grisbolt?
Let's go!
The Grisbolt and we got...
I'm hatching the Scorching One.
Alright, what is the gender of the Grisbolt?
The Scorching One was a...
I'm gonna check now.
Uh...
Grisbolt is a female.
And we have a male Relaxosaurus.
Let's go!
Alright.
Let's put them out.
Who do we get?
Who are we replacing?
Can you take them out?
Can you take out the ones we're replacing?
They're all sleeping so it doesn't matter.
Um...
Yeah, but I don't...
I'll just take out...
I'll take this guy out.
Okay, Relaxosaurus is here.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, cool.
No, no, don't sleep.
No...
I'm gonna get HP for once.
Get up!
Okay, I just have to wait till it lands.
I can't put them in there.
I'm trying to look at what the dungeons are.
Caverns of Dune dungeon.
Okay, I know you put that with dungeons.
Caverns of Dune.
Okay, that's...
It's in the desert.
Okay, it's level 38 dungeon, which is fine.
I'm sure if we're in higher enough level.
Alright, breeding is gonna be fine.
We're good.
Nice.
Yeah, I just need to get the circle boards so I can make the spheres so I can get the hyperspheres so then I can...
Oh yeah.
Start catching the bosses.
I'm gonna get the materials for bases so you guys can teleport to me to do the dungeon.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Okay, we have...
I can like...
Then you can also start teleporting us to those islands.
Yeah, yeah.
So how much refined ingot do we need?
I have 87 and I can make 330 more.
It'll be a hundred refined ingots to make the sphere assembly line and then for the balls, it's...
So I'll just max it out so you can queue all the balls later.
Five per ball.
Okay.
We just queue up all the ingots.
The major problem with the balls is that they're not as good as the spheres.
Actually, it's probably...
It's just circle boards.
It's probably better if...
Can I make polymer yet?
I make pal metal ingots and then I make legendary spheres.
I just need cement and carbon fiber.
All right.
We also need to make polymers.
I'm not level 33 so I need to get up a couple levels before I can do that.
So if we can make a bunch of cement, that would be gook.
I can...
We have 80.
I can make like a lot more.
Okay.
I'm in the right area.
If I can just make legendary spheres, then it'll be way easier to catch the motherfuckers.
Where are the Anubis?
All right.
I'm gonna start reading.
I want to slave them to make a rock.
You guys do that.
I'm just gonna find us that fucking dungeon.
Where the heck?
Let's take him down.
Wait.
No.
Not you.
I don't need you.
Wait.
We have no more Anubis in the base?
We have one Anubis.
We should have one.
Where's the other one?
I'm gonna start making some.
I'm gonna put him back.
Okay.
Yeah.
No.
It is this guy.
And Griswold.
Okay.
Last breed.
Ooh.
Where the fuck is the dungeon?
Okay.
I am looking at the...
And then grab Griswold.
...back to rock.
Trying to find the dungeon spawns on the little guide you made.
See.
I hope it was helpful.
I mean, I'm so happy.
I like, got really, uh, like, I started looking into all the stuff I needed for breeding and then it just led me down a rabbit hole of all the other things I needed.
No, that's not it.
Oh.
The dungeons.
Right.
Breeding time.
Breed, breed, breed.
Wrong mouth.
It's so hard to find the dungeon.
Alright.
There they go.
Fall in love.
I'll leave you to it.
I'm gonna go find the dungeon.
Good luck with the breeding.
It's that easy.
Just do it.
It's easy.
Good luck with the fertilization.
Why are you trying to make it complicated?
You're like, all you need is a cake and then they'll fall in love.
That's all.
No!
Stop falling down!
Well, I hope it's not exhibitionism because I don't want to stand over there and watch Okay, at the one hour mark, we start petting.
Yes.
Yeah, we start.
Okay.
We start petting together.
I don't know why that makes me laugh every time you say it.
I'm just like, okay.
Wait, we just do group petting?
What's so funny about that?
Yeah, what's so funny?
This is a serious thing.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Sorry.
I had the giggles.
My bad.
Oh my god.
How dare you laugh about petting?
Right?
They're like, group petals.
Ah, yes.
My favorite Pal World hobby.
Group petting.
Of course.
It's perfectly weird.
People need a pet.
I want a pet too.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're so right.
You're so right.
What the hell are you guys talking about?
Can I be patted since I've been doing Pal work?
I feel like I deserve...
It's called Pal World, not Pat World.
Okay, you're...
I'm not responding to this statement.
You calm down.
You're just like, please.
Please.
Shut the fuck up.
You're just sitting there like, oh my god, please stop talking.
I'm the only male here.
I don't want...
I'm on...
I'm running water here.
I got big dick energy if that makes you feel better.
You have big dick energy?
Hell fucking no.
Whoa.
You were like, I'm gonna try and make you uncomfortable.
And then you just made yourself uncomfortable talking about like, what was it?
Like the anal fissures or something?
Anal fissures.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm just being the straight man of the group because I'm an RP God.
Oh my god.
Is it RP or is it real?
We'll never know.
It's roleplay.
Is it though?
Is it really RP?
I'm flying.
I'm out when I have a little punny.
Do I need to wait for anything?
Yeah, I'm gonna wait for the egg.
I'll wait for the egg and then I'll go.
What can I do to be useful right now though?
I'm still trying to find the fucking dungeon.
This dungeon is so hard to find.
Holy shit.
When we need to butcher pals, by the way, we should butcher the cow.
No, we need to butcher chicken.
It's only chicken.
Oh, it's only chicken?
Yeah, but we have a lot of them.
Oh.
Because I need the meat from the cow and I need the meat from the boar.
Not right now though.
I mean, we don't have the kitchen yet.
Wait, you're a high enough level to do it now.
We just don't have the materials.
We just don't have the circuit boards.
Nah.
Alright.
Yeah, I gotta fly out of here then.
I'm just trying to find the dungeon.
Guys, am I going the right way?
Guys, we're trying to find the cavern of the Dune dungeon.
I don't know.
Excuse me, sir?
Do you know where the cavern of the Dune dungeon is?
There's no holes anywhere!
Where the fuck are the holes?
I'm over encumbered.
Oh, also, uh...
Lily, this applies to you and me.
Make sure that you have at least 40 pals registered in your decks today because there's a big difference between 30 and 40.
You get like 20 points versus 50 points.
I have 22.
We can probably just drop them to each other.
No, no, you have to catch them.
Wait, open up this egg then.
Uh, hatch this egg.
Whatever this common egg is.
Wait, I think I found a dungeon!
I think I did it!
Alright, let's go!
Okay, I don't know if this is the right one.
Oh my god, please, for the love of god.
Okay.
Please.
I'm gonna make some common...
...pal spheres.
Okay.
I found it!
Alright, I'm making a base right now.
I still need to get...
...three more pals to get the 50 points.
I'm putting the base up now.
So I need you guys to get over here.
Can you give me one second just to get the last agony?
Not yet, because I'm trying to get...
Wait, wait, wait, we have three bases?
Yeah.
So you can just put it down.
No, but I can put it because I cannot be able to get any more bases.
Oh wait, do we have a third base built?
Oh yeah, you can just destroy mine.
Fuck it, we'll vault.
Someone destroy it and then we do this dungeon right now.
You can destroy it.
Where is it?
I can't.
You can destroy it.
Wait, what do you mean you can't?
I'm literally in front of the dungeon, what do you mean?
Oh, this one?
Okay, I'm gonna dismantle it.
You can hold V on it.
Alright.
Let me know when I can build it.
Is everybody ready to do this dungeon?
No, I'm trying to get quartz.
Let me put the egg in.
Last egg, last egg.
You need coal?
Don't we have enough?
No, quartz.
Oh, quartz.
Okay.
When are you done, Sher4?
There's an egg for you.
If you want to open up that egg.
Yes, let me do that.
Get over here right now.
Right now.
It took me five minutes to find this dungeon.
I'm gonna fast travel around.
Find some shit to catch that I didn't touch yet.
Okay.
I'm good.
Are you guys all ready?
I'm getting quartz, Doki.
How many times do I have to say it, motherfucker?
Finish your quartz!
Oh, wow.
We have so many refining.
We're doing great.
We're gonna get this.
Bates is gonna be 20 in no time.
All we need is the circuit boards.
Faster!
Alright, I'm gonna try and find...
Let's go!
Oh, no.
He's broken again.
I'm gonna fucking catch more stuff then.
While I wait.
I'm gonna try and find...
Oh, no.
I'm stuck.
Why am I always stuck?
There we go.
Can I catch this?
Level 35.
I should be able to.
Okay.
I'm gonna check that off the list.
Uh... okay.
So, all of the breeding stuff, I can just hide.
I don't need this anymore.
Hide.
Oh, we can still make a dire howl, but I was kind of like...
Wait, did you clip the...
We're waiting for it to hatch.
Okay.
But the dire howl... Is it worth doing?
No.
You have to get the three passive moves.
If we have the right things.
Because it's only a pod and egg, so it's like fucking 10 minutes per egg.
Okay, if it's 10 minutes per egg, then that's fine.
I guess I can try to...
Do they need cake though?
Yes.
Okay, then let's not do it.
Let's not do it.
I don't think it's worth it because I feel like we should put our time in something else at this point.
Yeah, let's do something else.
Yeah, because we really need to catch up on some points since we haven't really uh...
been farming points.
Once I get legendary spheres, I'll be able to catch all the bosses.
Let's go!
Yeah, that's a lot of points.
Alright.
Okay, are we ready to go to the dungeon?
I'm getting quartz.
He's getting quartz, we had.
Alright.
I'm gonna come get quartz with you then.
Yeah, help him get quartz.
Can you actually... oh wait, we can't drop a base anymore.
Alright.
I mean, I can destroy this base right now.
Nah.
I mean, if quartz is just something you mine, you just drop me in and I'll mine it in no time.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm gonna destroy the base then.
No, no, no, it's okay.
It's okay, I can just fly over.
It's... it's fine.
There's a town?
Where's the town?
Okay, cool.
Give me a compass direction.
Chat, I need a compass direction I can grab the town.
Oh, there it is.
Nevermind, I see it.
It's right there.
Wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
No, no, what the fuck?
I fucking died!
I went to the Anubis and I didn't have the tropical armor on.
And I fucking just died instantly.
Because I took it.
I died for quartz.
That's okay.
It's alright.
It's fine.
I'll just make myself a new armor.
That's fine.
No.
Not like this.
I'm ready to go to the boss.
Are you fucking...
Okay, I'm coming for her.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm just saying, I might as well go.
Alright, head over to the dungeon.
When everybody's ready, head over to the dungeon.
It'll take me one minute.
Just one minute.
Okay, it's okay.
I'm grabbing the fast travel in the town.
For later.
I'm just gonna go pick up my shit.
Okay.
There we go.
You know what though?
That was actually a speed strat.
Because now I don't need to eat.
Yay!
That was intentional by design.
Alright, I'm back at the base.
Whenever everyone's ready.
I'm ready to fast travel.
I'll wait here.
Alright.
I'm in.
I'm coming.
Are you close?
I'm very close.
Where is she?
Oh, there she is!
I was like, don't worry about it.
Why are you here?
Did you die?
I died.
I'm catching paths I don't have yet.
I've skipped so many.
Oh my god, you're naked!
Don't worry about it.
Okay, okay.
I'm fine.
Don't worry.
I'm just going to kill these guys with flamethrowers.
Alright guys, don't die.
Don't die to these guys.
Just run.
These are very high level.
We have to get to these.
We have to get to the dungeon as fast as we can.
Or they'll die.
Just keep running.
As long as everyone has a wolf, it should be fine.
Oh fuck.
I've got a flying thing.
Just don't die.
We need you alive so we can get this done.
Fuck.
I don't know what way it is.
Oh okay, I don't know.
I was following you.
We're doing it live.
I love doing this live.
I can't even get up!
Okay, I got it.
Oh no, I'm alone with the dudes!
Oh yeah, it's over here.
Okay.
First try, baby.
Wait, I'm about to get fucking flamethrowered to death.
No, you're fine.
Just run past them.
Yeah, just...
I'm almost there.
Just keep on trucking along.
We're basically at the dungeon.
Sure, we can try and kill it together here.
Wait, I'm not there yet.
Okay, we'll wait.
It's a pyrene.
I'm gonna put my...
Univolt...
Alright.
You guys ready?
No, we need small peepee.
Where's small peepee?
I'm sorry, my small peepee is really busting it to get over there.
Where is she?
I don't even see her.
I've got anxiety.
Come on.
You're almost... Are you stuck?
I'm stuck.
I'm getting off.
I'm going.
Yeah, I'm stuck.
It's okay, I'm coming.
Okay, we're here.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Alright, let's go.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
I've arrived.
Alright, here we go.
So sorry.
I'm here.
Do I have to hit it for it to count?
No, no, no.
We just have to...
You just gotta witness.
Don't die from this.
I'm witnessing a murder, it's okay.
Just stay far away.
We just have to kill it, but you can capture it if you want to.
Alright.
You wanna capture it, Turf4?
I can try.
I don't know what the percentage is though.
I don't know either.
If it's like super low, we just fucking...
kill it.
Oh my god, my uni bullet.
Go, tanking!
Oh, he's almost dead.
I'm retreating mine.
It's 6%, just kill it.
Just...
Okay.
Grass type versus fire!
What's the worst thing that can happen?
It didn't want to join the family, now it must die.
Yeah, now it must die.
Alright, nice.
Picture, picture!
We did it!
Clip, clip, clip!
I hereby confirm I have witnessed the murder.
I was here.
I participated.
I am guilty.
Alright, next dungeon?
Next dungeon, well I need to find it.
Alright, you guys can leave now.
You guys can leave, I'll go find the next one.
I'll do courts then.
Let me know when you guys all leave and I'll dismantle this.
I left.
You should let me dismantle.
Okay, yeah, you can dismantle it.
Okay, I'm gone.
Are you gonna dismantle this here for?
Yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna fucking head somewhere else then.
Smoke Peepy's still at that base.
No, I'm out.
She's out.
I'm out too.
I'm gonna go find the...
I'm gonna go to the other sanctuaries.
And then...
I'm gonna make...
I'm gonna make a base near the courts.
Yes, please!
That'd be super helpful.
I'm gonna make... I wanna make...
Actually, we can do the photos later then.
I'll just find the other dungeon.
Do I have any food on me?
No...
Is there any food at base?
Or no?
Check the pal food thing.
There should be at least some honey and some other stuff.
Cause I'm done with the cakes.
I don't need to make any more cakes.
I'll eat the honey then.
Yeah, we're not breeding anything.
Sounds like what is it with flesh tubers and quarks?
I mean, if you can avoid eating the honey, I mean, if you can avoid eating the honey, that's probably the harder one for us to...
Okay, I'll get the egg.
I'll get the milk then.
Okay, cause my pals need milk.
I...
Yeah, if we wanna actually just fill the ranch with like, Yeah, if we wanna actually just fill the ranch with like, chickens, we can just have a fuck ton of eggs.
Or fill it with the cows and then we can have milk.
We need a production assembly line.
Let's see, what do I need?
Dude, I'm gonna find the other...
I'm gonna go find the other dungeon.
Okay.
Uh...
Volcanic cavern dungeon.
That's a level 40.
That is all the way down here.
On the edge.
Where's the...
How the fuck do I get there?
Trevor, are you okay with like, destroying the base later, when I find the dungeon?
Uh...
Yeah, I mean, just let them farm some quartz real fast.
As long... as soon as you have the base just let me know, and then I'll get the quartz.
Just like this way, okay?
Alright,
here I go.
I'm heading over to the volcanic dungeon.
Oh hey, there's some chicken I can kill for food.
Oh yeah, we need to take that photo
There's a statue in the middle of the crater.
We have to take a photo with it.
We all need that advanced armor.
I just don't think it's worth it.
You can live.
If it's one second, you'll be fine.
We can live for a hot second.
Yeah, you just need a photo.
Just a little burn is not too bad, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like what?
You're some coward?
Alright, I'm making the pal box at the...
...
I'll kill you so I can eat your meat.
There you go.
I got enough meat now.
Alright.
Tirok, go!
Heading for the other dungeon.
Where the fuck that is?
The courts are on the pal box.
Oogie.
How much time do you need, Tirok, for it to get the hard bosses?
I need the better balls.
That's the only thing that's stopping me right now.
Leave me be!
And it's just the courts, right?
The courts that's stopping you from making those balls?
Because I need the circuit boards.
But I got some...
Yeah, we need to make the oven first before we can use the circuit boards for anything else.
You think we can get that?
You think an hour is enough for you to catch the bosses?
What the fuck is that?
Yeah.
I mean, they die fast.
Alright, so we just...
Just getting to them, that's the problem.
We just need to make sure we get everything ready for sure for in an hour so then he can speedrun catching the hard bosses.
I'm working on it.
Yeah, he just dropped me at the courts.
I'll...
Yeah, I made the base there.
Alright, Lily, it's time.
Go, pal.
Go, Lily, pal.
Go.
I'm going.
Wait, let me go, too.
A fast travel point.
Okay.
I'll be right there.
Do I need a special armor to survive there?
Just Tundra.
You need the cold armor.
Oh, just kidding.
You need cold armor.
Then I'll have to make that first.
Unless you don't need it right now.
You can just drop it for me.
If you have any... If you have a fire resistance armor or anything, I can buy you two shirts.
I do have a fire resistance.
Wait, what's the...
This is a heat resistance.
Oh, I found the dungeon.
I found it already.
Oh, nice.
Okay, sure.
For it's time to destroy that base.
Not yet.
We need that court.
But I found it.
Or I'll just go mine the courts.
I don't give a fuck if you found it or not, bro.
You want me to catch those legendary or what?
Okay, I'll mark it.
I'll mark it.
Where am I?
Wait, what the fuck?
I'm going to mark this right now.
It's like 250 minutes, so we have like lots of time for this.
Uh...
E...
That was fast though.
I didn't expect to find that.
Alright, I'm gonna really quick just get this fast travel.
Alright, I found the...
Oh, there you go.
No, that's fucking ore.
Oh my god, this one was...
Okay, I'm at a fast travel.
I'm all out.
There's a town along the south coast.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I found that here.
Then...
Is that the one?
Why?
Legendary or first?
Guys, I'm not high level enough to do a legendary.
Surefire is the only closest one.
Yeah, I don't think I'm going to be killing a legendary.
Yeah, and if he can't kill a legendary, I can't kill a legendary.
I mean, I can probably kill it.
I mean, we can get points from killing it.
Yeah, we still get half points from killing.
Yeah.
I mean, 180 is better than nothing.
Okay, I die already fast in the cold.
180 is already hard in the base.
I can mine it, don't worry.
I can give you really cold...
You need like cold armor, right?
Cold resistance.
Okay, I can give you... I can get you one.
I'm going back to base and I'll make you one.
Nice.
I have the quartz in no time.
10 minutes.
Let's see.
No, this thing is so long.
Let me see.
Let me see if I upgrade.
Is a normal Tundra outfit okay?
I think so.
I don't know.
Trevor, is a normal Tundra outfit okay or does she need like the...
Alright, I'm just going to make a normal one.
Then maybe it'll be fine.
I know I can buy two undershirts.
I know if you have heat resistance, I can buy two cold undershirts.
I do have heat resistance.
Yeah, then I'll just go buy the two undershirts.
It would be Bingqiling.
Actually, I don't know.
Chat says high or low protection is better, so I'll give you...
I'll make it a normal one then.
It's okay.
I'm making her a pelt right now.
Okay.
Oh no, my pelt's hungry.
Wherever I can find the higher crafting area because this is a fucking mess right now.
I'm just...
Where is it?
Climbing.
Oh, there it is.
Cold resistant pelt.
Man, I'm not having any luck here.
I thought that there was going to be a bunch of...
Alright, Lily got you.
...forts here.
There's none.
Here.
Where are you?
In the base.
Drop.
There you go.
Boom.
Thank you.
Wham bam.
Now you can go farm stuff.
Back to palling.
Let's see.
Oh shit.
Just palling around.
Just trying to see what I can put away.
I have a lot of eggs, but I don't think we need to hatch anything.
I'm going to fly back to b-b-b-bay.
Oh my god, there's a lot of worms I need.
Let's see.
Checking.
I want to see.
I want P.A.
to see.
I'll catch the valet then.
Where the fuck is the valet?
Okay.
Alright.
I am so close to being able to make her.
Legendary balls.
Legendary?
Almost there.
Tell me more about your legendary balls.
What?
Valet.
Pal.
World.
Location.
I'm Zoe.
I forgive you.
I don't actually want to know about that.
That's what I thought.
Make sure you check for lumps though.
Have you checked your balls?
It's important.
Check for your balls?
I would say check for them yourselves, but you guys don't have balls.
Oh man.
No balls.
I'm sorry.
I have loads of ballage.
I do have loads of ballage.
What the fuck did I just do?
Loads of ballage.
Okay.
It's fine.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
I'll catch the valet right now.
We didn't.
We didn't want to have.
It's over here.
We didn't want to have a lodging site.
That was.
No.
I'm almost there.
How much polymer can I make?
Hey dude.
Could you get out of the way?
I'm sorry.
I still haven't found any lucky pals.
We're not lucky.
I can't believe it.
We're not lucky enough!
I haven't even seen Uno.
Why aren't you lucky?
Because my stats on spawn...
I fucked up.
Alright, I should be able to make legendary bowls soon and then I can...
Start catching them.
Alright, alright, calm down.
How are you hungry right now?
Calm down?
They're legendary.
Calm down.
We heard your first time.
I'm going AFK 20 minutes.
What did you do, PP?
I'm so sorry!
This is it.
We're kicking.
We're kicking now.
Stop calling HR on me!
We're kicking.
We need a teammate replacement right now.
No, I need to... alright, I'm moving the logging site.
I'm so sorry.
Ow.
Oh shit, no, this is not good.
This is not good.
I'm not dodging.
Okay, do we have a rough idea of how much coins we need in 150m?
Holy shit!
Fuck.
I think we might be fine, actually.
Oh shit, at night it's very cold.
Oh my goodness, I think I'm dying at this pace.
Wait, what?
What happened to the cold pill?
I guess at night it's just too cold.
It depends.
PP, do you still need... quartz for anything?
Uh, yeah, so we need to make the circuit boards.
Let me see.
So we need to build the production assembly line.
Um...
Which requires, I believe, 10 circuit boards.
So we need the quartz.
I think we already... and we need polymers, too.
But we should have enough high quality pallet oil to make at least...
No!
Uh, what's 36 divided by 2?
We can make 18.
We can make 18 polymers.
So we can, I think, make that already.
Uh, but we pretty much wanna skip past it because we don't wanna make the... wait, did we already make an advanced furnace?
Oh, nevermind, we already made it.
Yeah, I made that.
Okay, okay, yeah, then we just need to...
Okay, cool, then we just need to make the production assembly line, or the... whatever it is.
Uh, the production assembly line 2.
The level 2 version.
I need 20 nails then.
Hmm.
And I think if we just get a few more quartz, I think that I need to get some palladium fragments and some more iron ingots.
Whew!
Okay.
Or, is it ingots?
I think I just need ore.
You just need ore.
Yeah.
Because then I can make the legendary bowls.
Okay.
Uhhh...
Okay, we have 200 quartz now.
Oh shit, that's a lot of quartz.
That should be enough.
Way more than enough.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Um, circuit boards are what level?
I don't know if I can assist.
Uh, but...
Circuit boards...
Circuit boards are from...
Level...
Level 35.
Okay.
Unfortunately, I cannot help.
Wait, there's no palladium fragments in here?
Alright, uh, get ready to clip, I think, one of these eggs.
Wait, no, not this one.
Can you make more palladium off of the... the mill or whatever the fuck?
Gung-do, hold up.
Just kidding.
Go, Lily, go.
Don't need to clip it.
Wait, what...
What happened to clipping?
Uh, wrong egg.
Nooooo!
The egg I needed is still 20 more minutes.
Yeah.
I know.
Sorry, I got your hopes up.
Not...
No, clip, clip, clip!
No clip, clip, clip, I'm sorry.
No clip, clip, clip.
I'm so sorry.
I feel so lied to.
Please forgive me.
No.
No forgiveness.
That's fair.
Okay, as soon as the night is over, they're gonna make the fragments.
I'm gonna farm some manually in the meantime.
Just leave me alone.
I have 40 now.
I don't know how much you need in total.
Maybe 100 almost.
Just a bunch, you know.
Alright.
But I'm gonna go manually farm.
I'm about to get a bunch of palladium fragments.
Okay.
So mostly, mostly just try and get iron ore.
That's what we need.
Alright.
Iron ore?
Well, I can have a lot.
I'm gonna finish this cement.
Should we take the bat off of the mining station and put him on ore?
I think we can just mine the ore.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Manual?
Yeah.
Manually.
I'm on it.
I'm getting pinged so hard right now.
I'm getting...
Cause we also need the rock for like the fragments.
So I'm like, ah shit.
Turns out it's a rock.
We're gonna try that around.
Mining away.
No I told you.
You can move the base whenever now.
Okay.
Let me see if I can catch this fucking Valen then we can do that thing.
Oh, please.
Please just don't kill me.
I'm so low.
Gonna force this.
I can't.
Don't be kidding me.
Wait!
What?!
I cannot aim right now.
Alright.
Please don't kill me, please don't- No, no!
I wanted to make the Chillette saddle.
That was scary.
Chillette, the best a man can get.
I'm trying, please.
It's 5%!
I have 37...
I have 37 balls!
37 balls?
I have 37 giga balls!
I will force this!
It's 5%!
You're gonna force it- force your balls?
Get in here!
Get yourself in here, you stupid bug!
So close and into your balls is unhealthy!
I'm sorry, there we go.
Clip, clip, clip!
I got it!
That's gotta be an OSHA violation.
I'm calling HR right now.
Alright.
Okay, anyway, I'm gonna go- I'm gonna repair and then we can do the dungeon.
Are you guys all ready for dungeon?
Yes.
Yep.
Alright, alright.
I'm just mining ore.
I need wounds.
Clip, clip, clip!
PP bot, I did it!
I got the valet!
They're so proud of you!
They're so proud!
Alright, where are you guys?
Okay, I'm gonna repair my armor and then we can do the dungeon.
Alright, I'm gonna take half of this milk.
I need the milk.
Wait, no, fuck that.
I can- I can live without milk.
I'll take half the berries.
What?
There's like, lots of frozen- I'm gonna hatch these.
Why am I aiming- what?!
We got a mouse, mouse, mouse, cat, mouse, cat, christ?
And, uh, another mouse, christ.
Okay.
Ohh, where the fuck is the repair bench?
Okay...
Ohh...
There's two repair benches.
Okay, I got it, okay.
I'm gonna go make the base now for us.
Okay, cool.
Alright, let's...
We only need 10 circuit boards, right?
Uh, we need a lot!
But, we need 10 for right now.
I need some more...
Did you guys destroy the base yet?
Did you destroy the base yet or no?
You're able to do that yourself.
Oh, I should be.
Oh yeah, and I get the materials automatically, right?
Okay, so for the electric kitchen, if you want to make that right now, sure, we only need five circuit boards for that.
And then for the exception, for the assembly line two, we need ten.
So we need to make like 15 circuit boards.
We need more high-grade oil then.
I put some high-grade oil in the chest because I fucking killed a lot of people.
Wait, do I have... am I holding some?
No, I'm not holding any.
We have 17 minutes and then an hour left.
Sorry, we have like one hour and 16 minutes left, so...
We need to like speed run some stuff after that mark.
At an hour mark, we should start taking photos of like petting the pals.
Yeah.
Just to be sure.
Do you want to go to the dungeon now then?
Yeah, I'm heading over there for us.
Okay.
And getting that dungeon.
Alright.
Where the fuck did I put... oh, it's over here.
I'm gonna destroy...
Where is the other base?
Okay, I'm dismantling the quartz base then.
It's the one...
Shit, where is this?
We're good on quartz, I think.
It's the one next to the quiver, right?
Is that the base?
The one next to the quiver?
Uh...
I don't see the map, but it's the one with the buff.
Anubis?
We still need the Anubis one, I think.
I don't know what that was.
It's the one above Anubis.
Uh... the one above Anubis.
Can you guys like head there so I can see where it is?
Because I'm worried I'm gonna get the wrong base.
Uh... okay.
The one that's like...
Do you see the quiver?
Yeah, I'm at the quiver.
The base that's near the quiver?
Don't destroy that one.
Oh, okay.
So the one above the...
Yeah, the one above.
The highest one, right?
Yep, yep.
The highest one you can destroy.
Okay, I'll destroy that.
Yeah.
All right.
Yep.
Okay, I'm making the base now.
Oh... is it near anything?
We'll be base level 20 once we do pretty much just the production line, I think.
And then... because we already have the electric.
So we should be automatically level 20.
All right.
Which is the thing I needed to make?
Head over.
Assembly line and the electric cooker.
Electric kitchen?
Yeah, electric kitchen and the assembly line.
All right, guys.
You can head over now.
I made the base.
Also, we have 400.
400 ore.
You can kill whatever you need while we do the dungeon.
Nice.
Suit.
All right, I'm waiting.
All right, I'm looking for you at the base.
Okay.
On my way.
We're here waiting.
Wing my way.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Cool.
I'm here to wait.
It's pretty over here.
It's up here, PP.
All right, I'm just gonna grab this left monk.
I'm gonna check what the last dungeon that defined.
Oh.
It's mega pretty over here.
I see the sacred mountain dungeon.
What level do we have to be for that?
Level 45.
I think I can keep that.
Yeah, I think we can pull it off.
Well, sure, Fora and I can, but you guys might get insta-dived.
Yeah.
We'll just be in.
You've got a shield, right?
A shield?
No.
Oh, I lost it.
Should've made you a shield.
You had my loot.
My shield was in there.
Oh, no.
All right.
I'll just wait.
Oh, wait.
Does that mean...
I've got your shield.
Wait, hold on.
Here, I'm gonna drop it.
Are you near me?
You...
Yeah.
Let's see.
All right.
Here's your shield.
Let's go.
I do have a shield.
You got a shield!
Oh, my God.
You have a shield!
Shield, shield!
Let's go.
What level are you right now, Surefour?
47.
Oh, you're almost 50.
We have one of the achievements to get to level 50.
Yeah, a pal to level 50.
Yeah.
I'm coming over there.
All right.
Second.
Just gonna wait.
Let me see.
I guess after that, I'm gonna go travel to the sanctuaries after that.
I'm here.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what happened?
Uh, I'm...
Oh, where is that?
I'm gonna go inside before I die.
Inside?
Yeah, just get inside.
Yeah, let's go inside.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, let's enter.
All right, let's go find...
Let's go find the...
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah.
We just don't...
Make sure you don't get hit.
Just keep running.
Wait, did you get a wolf finally?
Pee-pee.
I forgot to fucking bring it though.
Oh, boy.
Pee-pee just...
I might die actually.
Pee-pee, no.
I'm so sorry.
Just fly.
Just keep flying.
I'm looking back.
So if she does get down, I'll fucking run back to her.
I'm running.
Oh, the lava.
I'm so sorry.
I made the saddle and everything, but I forgot to grab.
No, it doesn't hurt.
This lava doesn't hurt.
Oh, shhh.
Oh, is it here?
No, not this way.
No, okay.
It's okay.
They're all a little bit borked right now.
It's not this way, so we're turning back.
Okay.
It's so bright.
Jesus.
Fucking flashbang.
It's like...
Yeah, I know.
Oh, shit.
Which way did you guys go?
Um...
Look for it.
This way?
Okay.
We'll find out.
We'll find it.
We'll try and find it.
Oh, wait.
You don't have any pallet with saddles?
No.
Oh, no.
Well, no.
Yeah, I do.
I've got wyvern, so I can fly.
Okay.
Just fly.
Not this way?
Okay.
Yeah, just fly.
I think it's just convenient at that point.
It's just doorways.
It's only doorways.
I think it has to be this right side then.
Yep.
Should be at least.
I'm heading over.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's here.
All right.
Cool, cool, cool.
It's here.
Let's go fight.
Are we all here?
Just gotta wait for the pp.
Yep.
I'm right here.
All right.
Let's go.
I am consenting to witnessing a murder.
All right.
Here you go.
Let's go kill this.
I am consenting to witnessing a murder right now.
911, please.
There's a murder happening right now.
Oh, my God.
I have no arrows now.
All right.
Go, Panking.
Go, Van.
Go, little guy.
You got this.
Well, I'm just gonna watch.
I don't have any fucking weapons anymore.
No.
Okay.
Murder.
Yay.
Woohoo.
You gonna catch him?
No.
Oh.
Clip, clip, clip.
Pp bar.
Let's clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip.
We got it.
All right.
Nice.
Yay.
Woohoo.
Let's see.
I'm level 39 now.
Someone fucking opened this.
Yeah.
I made the palcifice.
I put my pail out there to die.
I'm gonna go to the wildlife sanctuaries for us.
All right.
That sounds like a good idea.
Let's get out here.
I'm gonna try and start catching the boys.
All right.
Where's the...
What are we doing?
Did you build the electric cooker already?
Where's the...
What?
You built the electric cooker?
Or do we not have enough still?
We got...
I built the electric kitchen.
Oh, okay.
I think like either Peepee or Lily...
Oh, no.
There's not enough electricity.
Yeah.
Should work on the cheeseburger and the hot dog then.
We need to...
Yeah.
We just need to get...
You guys work on that.
The stuff built and that's it.
We do.
We got the kitchen now.
You got the kitchen now?
Yeah.
But you already built it?
Okay.
Yeah.
So you guys can...
It's fucking...
It's Chris' fault.
I...
Sick.
All right.
Okay.
Let me check my notes.
Sure.
Four will get the hard bosses.
I'm gonna go get fly to the sanctuaries.
Okay.
Maserina cheese.
We need milk, flour, and tomatoes.
So we need two tomato seeds.
We can get the tomatoes.
So we need two tomato seeds from the wandering merchant who's in the sand area.
So actually, we might need to go back there.
Can anybody go to Dune Shelter and buy three tomato seeds?
I don't have the fast...
I don't have money.
Where's Dune Shelter?
I have money.
I can do it.
I can buy tomato seeds.
Okay.
Let me give you money.
I have tomato seeds here.
Oh, you got tomato seeds?
I have six.
All right.
Six!
I have six tomato seeds.
I'm gonna make some arrows real fast.
Why can't I pick it up?
There we go.
All right.
I'm gonna make tomato...
Oh, tomato plantation.
Can we get more coal?
What level do you need to be to do the tomato plantation?
I can go get more coal.
Thank you.
Do we still have the coal farm?
Okay.
So Lily, go get coal.
Uh, pee-pee.
No!
I'm one level too low to make the tomato plantation.
Okay.
I can make it.
Can you make lettuce plantation too while you're at it?
Yeah, I can.
I'm just gonna get my arrows and then I can make it.
And then after that...
Okay.
Thank you.
Before I do our jobs or other jobs.
Okay.
What level is lettuce and tomato?
33 and like 30 something.
35.
35 is not bad.
36?
There is...
Nope.
It's 33.
38 is lettuce.
I can't find a tomato.
Tomato is 32.
Sorry.
32.
32 and 36.
38.
Um, does it matter where I put it?
Does not matter.
Okay.
As long as pals can reach it.
It doesn't matter.
Tomato...
Uh, we don't have...
Can you pass me the tomato and lettuce seeds?
Yeah.
I don't have lettuce seeds.
Okay.
I can buy lettuce seeds later.
Can you give me a tomato and I'll just...
Yep.
There's a tomato.
We can get the burger done first then.
Uh, alright.
For the tomato...
For the mozzarella meat, we need two tomatoes, flour, milk, and we need to kill a mazarinna.
Um, I can kill a mazarinna.
I'm putting the tomato plantation at the bottom.
No, you can...
You should focus on other stuff.
I can go kill a mazarinna.
Yeah.
I put the tomato plantation at the bottom.
There was no more space.
Okay.
And then I'll go get the...
Sounds good.
Lettuce.
I'll go...
I'll go manual it.
Do you have a general idea of how much coal you need?
I'll just grab everything.
Yeah, just grab whatever you can.
Uh, wait.
Did we make the production belt too?
Not yet.
Okay.
I need more high grade.
Uh...
Do you need more...
Here, I dropped the tomato seeds behind me.
Thank you.
Alright, I'll grab them.
I'm trying to go kill the bosses while I have time.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Do the bosses.
Sure, 4.
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
I'll take care of the food.
I just need the lettuce plantation.
That's all.
Um...
I can buy the lettuce plantations, right?
Yeah.
You can buy lettuce seeds, I think, from the same vendor.
Uh...
Just like this...
It doesn't matter which town, right?
No.
Well, hold on.
Let me take a look.
I put it in the notes.
Uh, lettuce.
Lettuce.
Uh...
Okay.
The wandering merchant in Dune Shelter.
It's the guy...
It's like the desert one.
I might be fucked here.
I found it.
Oh, boy.
Just run.
You can live.
I'm cucumbered.
Wait, I don't have money.
No one gave me money.
Let me give you money.
Do you need money?
Yeah.
No one gave me money for this.
Goodbye.
Okay, here.
I'm dropping.
I'll drop my money.
Okay, I have 400...
Holy shit.
Okay.
You know what?
You're so slow.
Okay, I'm going to buy this.
Make sure you get three.
Three minimum.
Okay.
All right.
We'll near this bitch.
I'm gonna butcher...
Wait.
I need to make a machete.
Cause I see a rush roe over there.
So I'll just...
I'll go get that meat right now.
Get that meat?
Wait a...
Is he gone?
Nope.
Um...
Machete.
Nope.
You okay?
Oh, I don't think she's okay.
Hey.
She sounds alright.
I was like maybe that disappeared if I teleport back and forth but um...
Yeah.
We're killed.
How many wandering merchants are there?
Okay I got some food.
I earned some stock.
Lettuce!
We're gonna go- wait do they have to be alive to use the meat cleaver?
Or is it a dead situation?
Yes.
Alive.
Okay.
That's why it's inhumane.
Gotcha.
Cause when they're dead it doesn't taste as good.
Chat it's important- chat you need to watch this cause it's important to remember where your food comes from.
I'd be very thankful.
Alright I got the- I'm gonna plant the lettuce stuff then.
Ummm... three right?
I got three.
Noooo!
Oh you stinker.
Eventually they'll despawn right?
That's okay.
I got the farm.
I can just get berries.
I actually- I rode our whole base.
Ummm...
Lettuce!
Oh my god there's like- we have like barely any space to fucking put this now.
I can get rid of the breeding.
We're not bringing it anywhere.
Okay.
Yeah can you get rid of it?
Yeah.
And then I can plant this.
Uh... disassemble.
Nice alright.
Okay.
Disassembled.
Alright.
There you go.
Thanks!
I'll build it.
Okay now I can help you build.
Alright I'm gonna go fly to fucking sanctuary for real now.
Thank you!
I'll cook!
For real, for real!
I got you!
We finished the breeding, now we just gotta do the cooking.
And then base will be done.
And then surefire's gotta speedrun catching the bosses.
Yep.
I'm working on it.
Yeah, you guys should focus on bosses.
Yeah, I already got all the mediums.
I mean, I'm missing one more medium, but I can catch that later.
I'm just gonna work on getting the sanctuaries first, because it's not that difficult.
Let's see...
It's right... here.
We have... we're almost at an hour mark.
Maybe at the 45 minute mark we start cutting.
I haven't had anything to drink in three hours.
Oh my god, go hydrate!
Palworld is like the worst game for my health, because I forget to drink, I forget to like...
I like shrimp, I just like...
Holy shit!
Holy fuck, hydrate!
That's not healthy!
I like literally become like a Sword Art Online protagonist when I play Palworld.
Oh god.
Just like forget my... I have a body.
The worst thing to be.
Bro, honestly...
I'm like three T's in, that's gold.
Alright, hold on.
I'm gonna take...
I'm gonna take like a big one.
Just for my favorite pal, Lily.
Yippee!
Our best pal!
Alright, I killed one of the bosses.
Best pal!
Wait, you killed?
Not captured?
I captured.
Oh, clip clip clip!
Surefour captured!
Wait, which one did you capture?
I drank a lot of water.
I'm gonna have a pee pee problem, and...
like a second, bro.
You are... you are the pee pee.
Cybelex?
Okay.
How, how do you have pee pee problem?
Wait, Cybelex?
Oh my god, my throat feels so much better.
It felt so bad, and I was like, why do I feel terrible?
They're still here, no fucking way!
Why do I feel so bad?
Alright, pee pee mod.
Surefour caught a pal, Cybelex, clip clip clip.
Remember the clip clip clip.
Yeah, they already did it.
Just to be sure.
Hot dog.
What?
Alright, just need that lettuce.
And then I gotta get that cow meat.
Where's the nearest cow?
It's where the vanworm... vanworm... where we caught the vanworm.
We're 10th place right now.
That's not...
Top 10!
I think the moment we take pictures of petting the cows, we will skyrocket.
Cause that's the one thing that we haven't really done.
We gotta make our little petting zoo.
We gotta put out all the humans too at the very end.
When we're ready to just say like, we don't care about materials anymore.
I think... no, at the last 10 minutes we can do that.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Alright.
Okay, do we require more coal?
Or do we...
Sure, do you need more coal?
What do you need?
I need more...
I feel like hypersphere materials is like the thing we need the most at that point.
Right?
Yeah, I have seven legendary spheres queued up.
Iron ore.
Lily.
Okay.
Iron ore, got it.
Let me just grab one Anubis.
And the palladium fragments.
Those are always gonna be two.
Yeah, yeah.
I need those two later as well.
Let me know whenever you're...
Whenever you're ready to do the black market, I can do it with you.
So I can aggro it together.
Dude, that's hype.
I'm excited to see this done like legit.
Wait, people do it... wait, what?
I didn't know you could do it any other way than like the exploit way.
What?
People do it... there's an exploit?
No, not in this game.
There's no glitches in this game at all, ever.
There's an exploit for the black market?
I have to catch it legit?
What do you mean?
Me?
People don't do it legit?
Cause I guess normally you would use the... you would use the... the... the... fire.
Well, I didn't know that.
I fucking... fucking did it the hard way.
That's why you a pro.
Oh, come on.
I'm very slowly flying over there.
I'm just gonna... you know, I'm just gonna...
Alright, I'll go get... I'll go get a... a pal.
I'm gonna go catch one of the... or kill one of the... cows, I guess.
Last hour.
Stop.
Me.
At the clock.
Stop.
I'm a sliding pal, but I'm three seconds later than light.
What if I pick up this berry though?
Alright, you get ready to clip.
Get ready to clip.
Here comes the last breed that we're doing.
Ozark was born.
Let's go!
Clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip!
Alright, I got Jormuntide.
Clip!
Sure, four, two!
Clip, clip, clip!
Oh my god, I'm still hungry.
Jormuntide, lord of the sea.
Lord of the sea.
Alright.
We got Jormuntide and the breeding Ozark, whatever his name is.
Okay, um...
Lettuce.
Lettuce and then I can make the hot dog and then I'll just make the... the cheeseburger.
I just need two mazarinameats.
Oh my god, I've been flying forever.
Where did he go?
Stop!
Okay.
Leaving your post!
Don't!
I just...
I'm flying out of here.
Legendary balls, I swear!
Please!
I'm gonna catch this guy just for now.
Alright.
Was it over here?
For the PAL register.
Was it the only one?
No, I don't think so.
Stop killing everything!
Back to mining.
Okay.
Mining away!
Over to the here.
Okay, directly... directly west.
Alright,
I'm gonna go kill myself a cow.
Nice.
Come on, Bessie!
Are you fucking...
No.
I'll get you in the way.
Come on!
Swimming cow!
That's gonna be some good meat.
Come on!
I should've been flying to the sanctuary but I wanted to catch this for a registered CAL!
Wait, what the fuck is wrong with that cow?
Can I get a different cow?
Oh, fuck off!
No!
Oh shit, cow.
Why are you so hard to fucking catch?
It's like the cow knows that I'm trying to kill him or something.
Maybe it's cause you shot him?
Nah!
That can't be it.
I don't know!
Maybe cause you shot a cow.
Nah!
I don't think so.
There's the sanctuary.
Come here, dude!
Yay!
Extra meat.
Alright.
Cool, we out.
Peace.
I'm almost there.
I feel like I've been flying for 50 years.
I don't know how to get to the volcano thing.
I feel like I can give you my armor and then you can get... you know where it is.
I've never been... somebody in the base building competition built a base there.
That's why I know it exists but...
Yeah, I don't know where that is so I don't know how to get that for us.
Talk about it.
What?
Cheer for?
What are we talking about?
The volcano.
The center of the volcano.
The volcano effigy.
I mean, I can find it on the map pretty easily but I don't know if I can traverse the locale to get there.
I mean, I can give you my heat pelt armor and then you can get... we'll do that later cause I'm trying to...
Alright, I'm making the food now.
Okay.
I can get to all the other team photos just not the... just not the volcano one.
Alright, be ready to clip.
We're making the cheeseburger.
Double checking, not a hamburger, definitely a cheeseburger.
Alright, cheeseburger, start production.
Yay!
Order up!
Cheeseburger is done!
Clip, clip, clip!
We got the cheeseburger.
And for those who are not interested in cheeseburgers, we will also have some nice hot dogs for you.
Just one second, I gotta harvest the lettuce.
Why isn't the lettuce on the cheeseburger?
Why isn't it on the hot dog?
Different strokes for different folks.
Do any of you eat hot dogs with lettuce?
No.
I mean, there's some...
I put like onion and stuff on it.
Japanese hot dogs with lettuce.
Oh yeah.
I've had some of those.
So I'm at the...
Are you guys ready to come over?
I'm at the wildlife sanctuary.
Ah, one second, I'm just harvesting the lettuce.
I'll be on my way.
What about you, Sheriff War?
No, I gotta kill this boss.
Alright, we'll just wait until he's ready to kill that boss.
I'm just gonna wait for him to come over.
I'm gonna put the base here first.
I have harvested a couple more ore.
I'll get a rock after.
Alright, base is done so you guys can come over whenever.
Alright, one second.
It's gonna be about 30 minutes.
Yeah, no, that's fine.
Just wait until Sheriff War is done with his boss.
I'm just gonna...
What?
Alright, I'm gonna do...
Alright!
Let's see...
Okay, lettuce get...
How much meat?
How much more do we have for our base to get to level 20 anyway?
All we gotta do is build that line 2 and we're done.
Line 2 and then we...
Yeah, just need high quality pal...
Pal oil?
Fuel, yeah, oil.
You can get that from farming the...
What was it?
The penguin?
Relaxosaurus.
No, that's the other one.
I can farm that later after...
Okay.
We're making the hot dog now.
The legendary pal...
Cone up.
...spheres are done.
Legendary what?
Legendary...
What is spheres?
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip!
One on your hotdog is done!
One sure hotdog is done!
Hotdog's done!
Cooking is done!
Cooking done!solel Uh... Beep, beep, mon!
Hide..
Hide sheet, don't need it, well, fourteen.
Hide, don't need it.
Fifteen hides, don't need it.
Let's see what I need to do.
Hide this!
I don't need it.
Uh... Hide, I don't need that either.
Yep, all we need is the...
Paline.
Aber?
Do we...
I can make that.
I'm gonna buy- how much pal oil do you need, Surefour?
Do you know?
High quality.
How much?
An amount.
How much is an amount?
Fuck a final, man!
What?
You're the one making it!
Bro, there's so many things I have to do right now.
You think I'm gonna remember all the fucking exact numbers?
I thought you were perfect!
What happened?
Yeah, I'm perfect at the things I wanna be perfect at.
Then that's not being perfect!
I'm perfect in my world.
Okay, uh, other ways to farm high quality pal oil.
I'm buying some right now.
The Wallipops.
Wallipops drop as well.
Uh, da muds drop them.
Digtoys drop them.
So I think actually the Wallipops is probably the fastest and easiest way.
Alright, I got menacing.
Menacing?
Clip, clip, clip!
We got menacing!
Let's go!
Mod!
PP mod!
We got menacing!
Make sure you clip it!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see...
I'm going to...
I dropped some...
I got five.
I just got five.
So I'm not sure if that's enough.
I don't think so, but like I just put five in there just in case.
Palmer takes two high quality each.
Two high quality.
Okay, so I put five in there.
Um, oh shit my team's hungry.
Alright.
Just go to the pal deck, look for relaxasaurus.
Yeah, yeah.
I will.
And kill those guys.
Um, do we have...
Are we good to go to take a photo now?
After I travel to a fast travel spot.
Okay, we'll just wait for sure.
I'll kill dummits in the meantime.
I'm gonna go kill some walley pops in the meantime.
Well, sure.
We're gonna be able to be done soon.
Coming back soon.
So we should just head over now.
Okay.
Since he's just flying over to fast travel.
It's to the far left.
Is it hot or cold?
Um, I don't...
I can't tell.
My thing isn't showing.
Oh, there it's medium.
Actually, I have heat pelt on.
So I don't know.
It could be cold.
Oh, let me grab my chillit.
So I'm not super fucking slow this time.
I have heat pelt on.
It's just a photo.
It's not a dungeon.
Oh, JK.
Okay.
All right, I wait.
I'm here.
All right, we're just missing Lily and Surefour.
He's still...
He's still trying to find the fast point.
I know where it is.
I just have to get there.
He's coming over.
I'll be on my way then.
I'm coming.
I got six oil in the meantime.
How much oil do we need?
Suzaku?
Fucking one of them.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, he is.
Might as well just kill this guy real quick then.
What the fuck?
We're waiting for you.
He's on the way to the fast travel point.
What the fuck do you want from me, man?
All right, then we can just do other stuff while he does that.
All right, let's do that.
I'm literally just about to catch him.
Did you catch him?
He's in the ball right now.
All right, okay.
I'm down back here.
I didn't even believe.
I can fly back.
I caught him.
All right, clip, clip, clip.
We got Suzaku.
Oh, you know I got to catch this Lovander though.
What?
Suzaku caught.
Clip, clip, clip.
Pee pee bun.
All right, so Lily and I are here.
Lily and Pee Pee.
Lily and I are here.
Hello.
I am here.
We're here.
I'm sorry.
I'm just trying to stay away.
I'm yellow.
I'm so fucking late.
We're almost there.
One hour left.
You signed up for this war soldier.
You have to finish it.
You got to finish it.
Oh, I'm working.
I'm mining.
Mining.
She's trying her best.
She's mining.
I'm mining.
Now I hit the button again.
All right, let me know what you got.
I'm going to go.
Eight place.
We're in eighth place right now.
So cute.
We're just waiting for you.
Let's go.
I'm slowly watching him flying to the fast travel.
He's almost there.
Almost there.
Travel across the fucking desert.
Also, I'm registered 40, by the way, in case that becomes relevant later.
Yeah, I only have 29.
If we want to clip that.
Okay.
We want to clip that.
I'm still catching a lot.
So I'm good to go.
I have 50.
So that's like 60 points.
Yeah.
Because I think it's like there's like a big leap between 30 and 40.
It was like 20 points versus 50 points.
All right.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Sure.
Four is almost there.
I'm literally watching.
All right.
Clip.
We're here.
Bye.
Bye!
I'm heading to the third one now.
I'm going to try to get some poly waps or whatever the fuck they're called and get some high quality power.
Where the fuck is the last.
Because once we do that, we'll be base level.
Oh, it's cold.
How much do we in total?
I just got six while waiting.
Good question.
Really good question, actually.
What are your jobs right now?
Shit.
Don't hit me.
I'm getting high quality quality.
I'm trying to get high quality Paloal and farm whatever people tell me to.
Okay, what about you, PP?
What's your job at the moment?
I'm flying back to base, hold on.
I'm trying to get high quality Paloal so we can finish the base.
Okay, so both of you are going to do that, alright?
Yeah, I'm killing Dammit and I think she's killing Woolly Pops for it.
Yeah, but they're not out right now because it's nighttime, so I'm going to come back for a sec.
I think Dammit still spawns at night, I'm not sure they care.
You can also go to the Anubis base where they've got the dig choices and the other one, they also drop it.
Oh, there, two Dammits.
Wait, if one of us beats the tower, does anybody else have to be there or we don't?
No, just one of us.
Yeah, I already did two towers.
Alright, perfect.
Oh no, I'm hungry.
Alright, I'm going to go to the Anubis base.
Wait, do I have to catch the Mammoth?
Oh, Lily!
Hi Lily.
The Mammoth?
Hi.
I already... I did... to my Dammit farm.
Oh shit, I'm freezing to death.
Yeah, I already did all the mediums, except for the Botan.
Botan?
Or the Botan, yeah.
Your Oshi.
Why am I cold?
Actually, my Oshi is Hosho Marine.
Why is the desert so cold at night?
What the fuck?
What happened to Botan?
He used Oshi in her too.
I discovered Hosho Marine.
Hosho Marine, this is...
Okay.
Wait, where are we?
Oh, it's all those... oh my...
Yeah, you did discover a Marine.
There she is.
Okay, I got six more.
Dang, she's so hot though.
She's so hot.
Why'd they make her look like that?
I'm starving right now.
I might die before...
Don't make me act up.
I could do anything.
Shit.
Oh wait, there's a... waypoint here.
Okay.
Oh no, help!
Can someone revive me?
Lily, help.
I'm coming to you.
Absolutely.
I got... I was defeated by this hot lady and I couldn't... I couldn't help myself.
I'm so sorry.
Wait a minute.
I hear a shiny.
It'd be a shame if I...
Oh my god, shiny!
...catch her while I'm reviving you.
Oh no!
That's okay, it's better...
Oh my god, she's behind you!
She's behind you!
Fuck!
Oh shit.
She's behind you.
Are you guys okay?
Oh my god, please stay in!
Are you guys all okay?
What's going on?
She's behind you.
Okay.
Okay, holy shit.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
Oh, Andel's done its perfect timing.
Oh yeah, let's kill him.
Let's kill him.
Okay.
Okay, banworm.
Yeah!
Uh, high quality pal oil three.
Sure, for... did you... are you lucky enough to catch your lucky pal?
I wanna keep one!
I wanna keep one.
Yeah, I got it.
Fuck you!
Oh, Clip!
Clip, Clip, Clip!
He didn't wanna be kept, so he can die.
Clip surefors, uh, lucky pal.
Ayyyyy!
Congrats!
Keep him up!
We really have not seen a lot of lucky pals.
Surefour, you did it!
You're finally lucky!
Oh my god.
So proud of you.
I wanna die.
Uh, alright.
Lily, can I have all the high quality pal oil you have right now?
I'll just take it back to base.
I have nine on me.
Alright, I'll take it.
Why do you wanna die?
You have so much to live for!
Here.
Where are you?
Just falling down.
Like what?
Oh!
Like marine!
Oh, thank you!
I got it.
On the fat picture!
She doesn't know me, little bro.
Thank you!
But if you live long enough, she'll eventually know you, right?
Anubis, why are you so fucking tall?
Oh shit.
I said, hail!
Oh no, I had a boss battle with him?
Uh oh.
Hey guys.
Well, I don't want that.
We're the fucking relaxesauruses, man.
Um...
We already got- We got a lot of pal- We might be- Uh, they've been doing- Peepee and Lily have been doing pal- pal- I'll come back.
Mm-hmm.
I'm grabbing some more.
I've got, uh...
I just got another damnit.
I've got twelve.
What?
Oh, what the fuck?
No, I don't wanna fight him.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Guys, are you guys free for the third sanctuary?
Cause I'm already here.
Yeah, I'm getting the hell out of there.
Anubis was attacking.
Okay.
I'm gonna be there in...
I'll finish this damnit off and then I'm ready.
I'm gonna be there in, like, uh...
30 seconds.
Yeah, I'm just running back to base with, uh, the oil.
Alright, here we go.
How many, uh...
Sure, do you know how many we need?
Uh, pal oils?
He does not.
Okay.
Alright, I'll bring you what I got.
Alright, I got the...
Oh, I didn't get my pal oil for a kill.
Oh.
Where's...
Let me disassemble this base.
Okay.
Putting it in.
I got base ready for every- Oh, I got it.
I've got this.
On my way.
I'm joining you, buddy.
Making my way down down.
More and faster.
Flying very slowly at medium speed.
I'm flying very slowly.
It's at the very top, right?
It's not really that quick, but I'm trying my best.
Uh, the base is at the very, very top, right?
Bap bap bap bap bap bap bap bap bap bap bap bap.
I'm ready whenever.
Okay, alright.
My pals are starving.
So I need you guys to get over here.
Okay, coming to you.
Oh, shit.
Oh shit!
It said top right, top left.
Oh!
Oh, I see you.
Okay, I'm flying away because...
Let me know when you guys are there.
There is a...
I just came into danger!
What's happening?
Okay, yeah, there's a pal that's very angry.
So I need you guys to all be there at the same time.
Okay, are you guys all heading there?
I'm here.
I'm on my way.
Okay, I'm just waiting for sure before they get there.
Mammoth dropped 10 ore to kill by the way.
Okay, that is my line however.
Alright, click up, click up!
Click up, click up, click up, click up!
Alright, bye.
That was a nice vacation, Bob.
Alright, we did it.
We got this sanctuary.
Okay, I'm fucking...
I'm going home so I can...
Okay, uh...
Clip, peep, peep, bye.
Alright, so I can get the...
Alright, I'm taking a look at what we need.
We need some more palladium fragments.
We need more palladium fragments?
You need some?
Okay, yeah, he needs some now.
Can we get Ignis out of the ground though while I do that?
If they're at the box.
Ignis?
Yeah, he's like stuck in the ground.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I can.
He's back now.
Picking fragments.
Um...
Let's see... how much time do we have?
You guys wanna do the petting now?
For now?
Just to get that over with?
Cause we have like...
All of us come over here.
Let's do water first.
Let's just go in order.
And do water.
Alright.
Um, I'm bringing out the...
I'll do penking.
I'm bringing out the Flock.
Are they only water?
Yeah, only water type.
So they can't be mixed?
I think they can, right?
They should be able to.
There's... oh.
It doesn't say.
It says of the same element.
So I have the Flock out.
Ezra...
I don't think it matters if... I have a Broncherry Aqua.
Should we ask?
Admin.
Pause.
At...
At admin... Can we...
Can the...
Pals be mixed type?
For pal petting?
Like water and grass?
Okay.
You're gonna kill Anubis?
It's gonna be so fast!
Sure for it!
Okay.
You know how much time we have left?
It's called time efficiency.
Alright, fine!
Go kill Anubis!
Wait, where the fuck is Anubis?
Bro!
Why do... Why are these...
No, the fucking boss Anubis.
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
They can be mixed!
Get back here!
I... I... I... Get back in here!
How do we pet?
I forgot how to pet.
And what the fuck is he?
Who was he before?
Alright guys!
We are... Let's go downstairs and pet them because there's too many pals here.
Wait, did you bring them downstairs?
Wait, what?
No, no.
I'm going down to the mound so we can all like get the...
screenshot of all of us.
We got all these other pals blocking it.
You guys ready?
We have to do this.
Alright.
I have mine.
How do I pet?
Does anyone remember?
I have mine.
You press the... Oh wait, sorry.
I don't know how to do it on keyboard.
You're playing on controller?
Yeah.
Woah!
Okay, Trevor, do you remember how to pet?
Woah, thank you!
Hell fucking no.
How do we pet?
Hold 4, hold 4, hold 4.
Yeah, you hold 4.
Okay, I'm petting.
I'm petting him.
Okay.
What do I pet right now?
Wait, no!
We're all...
Get there!
Get closer!
No, I got it.
I got it.
Do we have to save the photo?
Yeah, yeah.
I wasn't even there!
You didn't get anything!
Get back here!
Get downstairs!
That's enough.
All of us.
Now Shy Lily has to be down here.
Yeah, Shy Lily's not even... Lily's not here!
What do you mean?
I'm not even there!
Lily's not here!
You guys are still petting them and Shy Lily's not here yet.
Yeah, I was like how did you get all of us if Lily's not here?
It looks like... it looks like Donkey's going absolutely crazy.
3, 2, 1, go.
There you go.
Clip, clip, clip!
Alright, water's done.
Okay.
Now what?
Okay, and then we need grass, grass.
Alright, good thing my Boncherry is grass too.
So you can pet your Boncherry again.
True!
Um, I got the Kanzi.
Oh wait, no, I'm gonna use my Verdash.
Alright, I've got a Petalilia or whatever name it's called.
Let's see... Alright, I'm down here.
Alright, I got Verdash.
Okay.
I'm ready.
That's not grass.
Alright.
Oh my god, why does he look like such a handsome man?
Are you guys ready?
Okay, I'm petting.
It's pet time!
Clip, clip, clip!
Alright, grass is done.
What's next?
Dark type.
That's enough, stop petting.
Get out of the way.
Get out, get out.
We need dark type.
Do I have dark type?
I'm ready.
Instant around.
Is he dark?
No, that's neutral.
That's electric.
That's dragon.
Wait, what does dark type look like?
Oh yeah, I do!
Vanworm is dark type.
You can also smoke by element.
Yeah, I smoke by element.
I'm gonna do Vanworm.
Vanworm will be my fire and my dark.
Okay, I have the... I have a Hoot for it.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I have a Taunt Bat.
I'm using the Hoot.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah.
Alright, we're... Alright, petting.
Alright, petting.
Clip, clip, clip.
Ice.
I have sweeper.
Wait, does anyone have an ice for her?
Let me double check, but I don't think I have ice.
Oh, come on.
We're getting raided.
Oh no, I have... I have penguins.
He's ice too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
That counts.
Yeah, yeah, that counts.
Well, we're getting raided right now, so...
It's alright.
The... the...
Our base will take care of it.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm ready too.
Okay, we're not ready.
We're not ready.
Are you all ready?
Yeah.
I'm coming down.
I can't clip.
Alright, I'm ready.
3, 2, 1, go.
Sorry, I'm petting, I'm petting.
It's alright.
We don't care.
Just clip this.
Clip this.
In the middle of a fucking war.
What happened to us?
It's fucking dying.
It's okay, we got the clip.
Did we get the clip?
Yo, someone pick me up.
Someone pick me up.
I can't get out.
Where are you?
Someone pick me up.
Why are they level 40?
What the fuck?
I'm rezzing.
Go move.
Go rezz me over here.
Okay, we need...
I'm rezzing.
They actually in-cap everyone.
I'm fucking gonna vomit.
Okay, are we good?
Help me.
Help pick me up.
Where are you?
I'm getting fucking dead.
On the fucking rock.
I'm trying to get to you.
Oh shit, I'm fucking bugging out right now.
Where are you?
Where are you going?
I'm fucking away.
See you.
Everybody's dead.
Everything at base is dead.
I don't need anything because everything's dead.
Okay, we got...
Let's just keep petting until we're done with this.
Let's keep petting.
Earth type.
I'm gonna grab the sick ones and put them back in the box so they can heal.
Okay.
I'm getting the earth type right now.
Ground.
Grass.
Where the fuck is he at?
Oh, my dragon and my ice was...
Is ground earth?
Or is there a separate...
Okay, I got the...
I got the fuddler then.
I have fuddler.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
I'm at the bottom.
I have my trust in ground.
Okay, sorry.
Give me one second.
Earth is ground.
I'm gonna grab all the pals now.
Okay, earth, fire, electric dragon.
I'll grab...
I'll grab dire howl.
Wait, is that earth?
No.
No, dire howl is neutral.
I don't have an earth one.
I don't think...
I can give you an earth...
Rush war?
Rush war is earth.
I think he's dead right now.
He's dead.
I have a rush war here.
I put it in the base.
You can grab that.
Okay, cool.
I'll take it.
Okay, nice.
Thank you.
Alright, let's go.
I have my fuddler.
Let's go to the bottom.
I'm ready.
Alright.
You guys ready?
I'm ready.
Pet, pet, pet.
Wait, you both have fuddlers.
You both have rush war.
One of you guys have to change it.
Okay, I can give you another one.
We have to redo this one.
Wait, it has to be different?
Yeah, it has to be different.
What is bushi?
Is bushi...
No, it's okay.
I have an extra.
There's a duma.
Duma is...
I'll take duma.
Alright.
Okay.
Grab some fuddlers.
Okay, are you guys ready again?
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Pet, pet, pet.
Oh, he's so happy.
Clip it, clip it, clip it.
Clip, clip, clip.
Alright.
Fire.
What's next?
Fire?
Fire.
I got fire and dragon.
I'm gonna grab fire right now.
Do I have...
I'm doing a wire rim or whatever it's called.
Vanworm.
You got vanworm?
Okay.
Yeah.
I got the fox park.
I'm using instant around.
I'm getting fox park right now.
Pet, pet, pet.
Are you guys ready?
Yup.
Yeah.
Pet, pet, pet.
Clip, clip, clip.
Oh my god.
Alright.
What's the next one?
Next one is electric.
Okay.
Alright, beacon.
I'm doing beacon.
I have a mini...
Are we gonna try and do the kill achievements with the unique skills?
I don't think we have time for that.
Those are like not a lot of points either.
Two.
Yeah, I think we just focus on the other, the easier ones first cause that might be too much.
Do we all have electric?
Someone has my electric like the little...
I'm petting.
I'm petting beacon.
Wait, no, no, no.
Lily needs one.
I can steal grisbal.
Oh, you have grisbal?
Yeah, you can have it.
Just take him from the farm for now.
Alright.
I'm ready.
One over here.
Pet, pet, pet.
Let me see.
Yeah.
Pet, pet, pet.
Alright, dig it.
Clip, clip, clip.
What's next?
Uh, last one is dragon.
Yep.
I wonder if I can use the same pet for a different type.
Yeah, you can.
We'll find out.
Alright, let's go.
I'm ready.
I don't have dragon yet.
Let me grab my dragon.
Let me see if I have a dragon.
I might need someone to drop me a dragon.
Yeah, we might have to drop you a dragon.
Oh, I have a quiver.
I'm getting a quiver for mine.
Okay.
Um, wait.
Can you use...
You can use a...
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna use chillit for mine.
Sorry.
Vanworm is not a dragon.
Yeah, Vanworm is not a dragon.
I'll use chillit.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
You're fucking huge.
Yeah, I need a dragon.
I don't have a dragon.
Oh, yeah.
I have a dragon.
Okay.
I can give you one.
I'm putting one... Oh, I can use azurobe.
I can steal azurobe.
Yeah, you can use azurobe.
Is azurobe dragon?
Yeah, probably.
Okay.
Nice.
Ready?
Yep.
Pet, pet, pet.
Oh, my god.
You can barely see anything.
Click, click, click.
You're just gonna have to trust in us.
Trust us, yeah.
Trust the process.
Believe us.
Alright.
PB Mod.
You should have two, four, six, eight clips.
All of them.
You should have eight clips there.
Alright.
There we go.
We did it.
Alright.
Back to killing bosses here for it.
Back to work.
Okay.
Um...
Wait.
Can you make the...
Can you make the thing?
Did we bring it?
Yeah.
Did we bring you enough?
Or the...
Uh...
You have enough for high quality pallets?
Yeah.
To make the...
Polymers to make the...
Conducting line two?
Yeah.
I need six more refined ingots.
Five circuit boards.
Six more refined ingots?
Alright.
No problem.
And 21 nails.
Wait.
What was the second one?
Five circuit boards.
Okay.
I can make five circuit boards.
Where the fuck are my nails?
I need the nails and the refined ingots.
And then we're gooch.
What is palmetal ingots?
What the heck do I make nails for?
Oh, that's for the other thing.
Oh, I can't make nails.
Those are for the legendary spirits.
Alright.
We're gonna need to get those off the line.
To make more refined ingot.
Alright.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
I need to steal some food.
I'm fucking hungry.
We only need six refined ingots.
Yeah.
We're having a little bit of a problem in that everything died.
Okay.
Well, we have like 30 minutes.
So you guys...
Let's try to speedrun this.
Surefour and I can finish the rest of the bosses.
I'll try to build the...
We need to be at level 20 as well to make the zoo with 20 people in it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Trevor, do you want to do the black marketeers right now with me?
Okay.
After that.
Then I'll...
You and I will do the black marketeers thing.
We need to know where the second black marketeer is though.
Oh.
We can find...
I can find one easily.
I have the...
I'll find the second one right now and then try to market.
Okay.
Where am I?
What do we need?
I did the nails.
Okay.
There's one here.
Can you go get some more pal oil?
Yeah.
You get the pal oil.
Thank you.
There's one.
Okay.
I don't want to do...
Guys, I don't want to do the... That's my pal.
Do it with so many people around us.
So, there's one here that I know.
Let's see.
I have nine more pal oil.
I can deposit.
We need to butcher chickens as well, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Now we can do it really fast because we have so many chickens.
Yeah.
Okay.
How much pal oil do we still need?
Do you know?
I'm not sure.
How much pal oil do we need for the polymer?
None.
We're already done with that.
What materials are we needing?
Boards.
So, we don't need that.
Six or seven refined ingots.
Twenty-one nails.
Nails are done.
We just need to get the...
Now I caught the Suzuku.
I found the black marketeer.
Level 40.
I found another one.
Refined ingot.
I'm going to make as many as it'll make.
I can kill them.
And I'm also almost level 50.
Alright, nice.
Ingot will be done by the time you get back.
It's already at seven, eight, nine.
So, if you just come, you'll have enough.
Now someone can clip the real Suzuku.
So, are we missing anything then still?
Clip, clip, clip, Suzuku.
No, actually, I think we're good.
We don't need high quality pal oil.
PP mod Suzuku.
We just need the refined ingots.
If you can just go catch a couple of pals so that you're...
Yeah, because I'm going to...
Yeah, Lily, you just go catch pals.
Go catch pals.
Sure, Four and I are just going to focus on...
Black Marketeers right now.
Okay.
I'm waiting for you on one of them.
On me.
Yeah.
Do you have the waypoint for this?
I'm about to find out.
Let's see.
Oh, shit.
At the ten minute mark, we can do the chicken and the human thing.
I'm looking at the global just to be sure.
How hard is tower three?
I'm at you.
Okay, let's go.
Follow me.
It's like right here.
There.
Dig toys.
Ow.
Here we come.
Over here.
Do you want me to make more of the pal metal ingot?
I don't think you can.
I can.
Oh, can you?
Yeah.
Just make as many as I can?
Okay.
I'm ready whenever.
Alright.
Fuck him up.
Let's go.
We gotta capture him.
Oh my god.
He's getting fucked up.
I'm a little over encumbered at the moment.
Alright, be careful on the deets I guess.
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
My shotgun does a lot of damage to him.
My van should kill him.
That sounded really good.
I'm gonna reset him now.
Yeah.
You can catch him now.
Okay.
Fuck, which spear should I be using?
I have no idea, but we need to catch this fucker.
Okay.
Come on.
Nice.
12 percenter.
Let's go.
We got one of the black marketeers.
We just need one more.
Clip that.
Clip, clip, clip.
Clip us catching that one.
Then get it later.
Alright, let's go for the other one.
I marked it, so just follow.
I think we need more spears.
Come back to base and build the thing then.
We have all the materials you should need.
Oh, okay.
You go build it.
And then...
I can set up the jail with the humans in it.
Can you build... No, it's not gonna show for...
Can you get more spears for sure for them?
Yeah.
I have to start the thing.
I made the pal metal for you.
I don't have the recipe for the spears though.
Alright.
I'll go to the other marketeer whenever he's ready so he'll know where it is.
I need palladium fragments.
Palladium fragments are done.
Let me grab them.
I'm gonna get to the other one right now.
How many do you need?
As many as you can.
Okay.
Alright.
I've got 17 right now.
I should have had 46 but I don't.
Go power lover!
Palladium fragments are in.
Go!
I'm gonna get the potion.
Okay.
I'm heading to the second marketeer.
What?!
Okay.
He's on the crusher again.
Lily's just catching pals right now guys.
She needs all the pals she can get.
I just need pals.
Preaching to the choir.
I still need the nine nails.
And...
Oh, I need like...
Four nails.
What do you need?
Nine nails.
Wow!
Put them in a box.
Okay.
In the box.
Wait, no.
That's a dungeon.
It's not working.
I still need nine apparently.
Wait, did I went the wrong one?
Is this the wrong area?
Yeah, where do I put this thing?
Anywhere you can.
I can get rid of the shit down here.
We don't need these two farms anymore.
This one right here?
Wait, which one?
This.
The production up here.
To your right.
Up here.
I'm jumping on.
Oh shit.
Fucking on.
I'll just put it down there.
Fuck it.
Sorry, I became over-encumbered.
Eeeeee!
I went the wrong way for the black marketeer.
Wait, it's inside the dungeon?
Is that...
Did I actually mark it correctly?
It's not a dungeon.
It's...
Okay.
Which one are you going to?
I don't know.
I think I went the wrong way.
Yeah, you should come to me.
I know where there's one real close.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I might just go catch it right now.
Yeah, you can go catch it.
You don't need me, right?
I can do the rest of the build if you did it.
Alright, then we're good.
That's fine.
Yeah, I went the wrong way.
I found... I just...
I just need luck.
Yeah, there's one underneath the desolate church.
Yeah, you can get that then.
I'll go... I'm going to look at what else I can do.
I'll go get the...
There's still 20 minutes.
I can kill this other boss then.
Okay.
Oh...
Alright, I'm going to upgrade the base level.
I'm hungry.
Fuck.
Okay.
Is there more food?
Back at base?
Wait, was that assembly line 2 or was that assembly line 1?
That was assembly line 2.
You need a 2 to upgrade.
Why isn't it registered?
Hold on.
Eh?
It says that it's not built.
Uh... let me head over and see.
I mean, you can look at it.
It says...
Yeah.
No, I got it.
You're bugged.
I got it.
Base level 20!
Clip, clip, clip!
Thank you!
Clip!
PP mod!
Let's go!
Base level 20!
I'm going to build... You were just bugged out.
I'm going to build the prison.
Okay, build the prison.
Yeah.
I'll...
Yeah, alright.
Alright, viewing cage.
Okay, let's go.
Let's see... Oh shit, viewing cage needs to be fucking huge.
Alright.
Uhhhh... I'm going to go catch...
Do we actually need this production assembly line?
Or can I just get rid of it now that we made it?
The number 1 or the number 2?
Uh... the number 2.
Because it's faster.
Just get rid of number 1 then.
Alright.
I need a big open space.
Can you make carbon fiber on it?
Uh... yeah, maybe.
Let me check.
Powered...
Oh wait, no, I don't have the recipe.
So, no.
Uh, you should have it.
Or you should be...
For carbon fiber?
Yeah.
It's right here.
Okay.
The fuck is my shit?
I've got mines...
Offensive walls...
Uhhhh...
Wait, I need a...
Fucking... fuck, I need a...
We're in 5th place right now!
Yoooo!
Sorry, carbon fiber's level 35.
I can't make it.
I can make it.
I'll make it.
It's okay, Trevor.
You go do your bosses.
I'm working on it.
Alright.
I...
I can put it.
Where's the high quality crafter?
I'm gonna just try to make space wherever I can.
Oh my gosh, there's so many crafters.
This is just a regular assembly line, right?
Where's the assembly line so I can make the fiber?
Um, down below where the trees are.
Alright, I'll set it up.
Okay.
Uhhhh... Is it just carbon fiber?
Right?
With coal?
Yeah.
How much do you need?
Just... a bunch?
I'll do thirty.
Okay, I'll put thirty up.
Okay, first try black market at your 7 percent, baby.
Nice!
Okay, clip clip clip...
We got two.
Clip.
Put the both of them there.
Cause we have two clips of us catching two.
Um, I'm taking ten of the tomatoes cause I'm fucking hungry right now.
Uhhhh...
I'm gonna go kill this one guy.
Oh yeah, I'm definitely bugged.
I'd have to re-log.
That's alright.
I think it's alright.
I'll make it work.
It's this way.
Anubis was bugged, so I couldn't kill him.
No!
I don't know what we're supposed to do about that.
I don't know if they'll give us free points or not.
Message... message...
I said Anubis is bugged and they ignored me.
Just do the other bosses then.
Alright.
I'm gonna try to make a holding pen somewhere.
Well...
The holding pen is really big, actually.
It requires quite a lot more room than I think we have to work with.
Just put it at a different base then.
Yeah, yeah.
Actually, that's a good idea because we need to put 20 anyway in there.
Yeah, good idea.
Good point.
Alright, I'm gonna go to the Anubis base.
Okay, Anubis is back up.
Nice.
Scary.
I'm gonna go.
Wait, I forget what element Earth is weak to.
What do I need for the thing?
Let's see.
How much time do we have left?
We have 17 minutes.
Do you think we could do the tower 3 together or no?
Probably.
How much more points do we get for that?
Power is 3.
3 is...
That's 150 points.
Okay.
I can do that after I kill Anubis.
No.
I need to figure out... well, I need to kill this one too.
This other... the fucking...
Where the fuck is this boss?
Is it on the other island?
Guys, where's the boton?
It's on the other fucking island.
Oh no.
What?
Are you level 50 yet?
No.
If I kill some more bosses, I probably will be.
Okay.
I don't think I get levels from the...
What?
You get levels from the tower bosses?
Yeah.
You do.
Okay.
Building the holding pen.
Should be close now.
I'll put in as many humans as I can.
Lily, do you have humans on you?
I have a ton in my box.
Yeah, yeah.
Can you go to where...
Go to where Peepee is and then put some humans in there?
Because we need 20.
Let me just on my way catch this Lupemon.
Wait, I think I already have one.
They're all just fucking passed out.
Uhhhh...
I don't think I can do anything to them while it's nighttime.
But we can just throw them all on the ground.
And that should be good enough.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Wait, we can only put 15.
How are we supposed to put 20 of them in there?
Wait, what?
Clip Clip Clip!
Oh, you put them here!
Okay, wait.
Yeah, nevermind.
We're good.
They'll just fall in.
Clip Clip Clip!
Peepee mod Anubis!
That's wild.
Are you able to get to that dungeon place?
Because I can just TP there and do it.
What, tower 3?
Yeah, the tower.
I don't know where tower 3 is though.
Oh, wait.
Sure.
Do you have any humans you can put in this box?
Since you're right behind me anyway.
Yeah, just put them in there.
How many more do you guys need for 20?
Right now, we only have 6, 7, 8, 9.
We've got 9 people in here.
I have 8 on me.
I just want any of the killed...
Oh, sorry.
We've got 10.
Okay, I have 8 on me.
But I want to kill this one.
Oh my goodness!
I might just go to the tower then.
Yeah, you go to the tower.
I'm gonna do...
I'm trying to find the fucking last boss here.
For medium.
Well, we'll leave our 10 humans in there for right now.
It's right here.
Okay.
Yeah, whoever puts the last human in, just clip it.
It'll be me.
Wait, where you at?
I don't see you.
I'm at the Anubis space.
The fuck is the last guy?
Why doesn't that show where you are?
That's so weird.
Oh, because I'm bugged right now.
Oh.
Yeah, come to the Anubis space.
And then don't use the pail box.
Use the actual cage.
Just come over and press X.
And you can put him in there.
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna go kill Botan.
One.
Two.
I keep thinking you're talking about Yu Yu Hakusho.
Every time you say it.
Alright.
Holy shit.
Oh, dang.
That's some cute humans.
What number are we at now?
I can't see.
It's kinda buggy for me.
It doesn't really show it.
There's a raid up here.
Wait.
12, 13.
Wait, wait, wait.
14, 15.
16, 17.
We still need three more.
At the 10 minute mark, we have to butcher the chickens.
Okay.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
6, 12.
We need four more pails to get 40 caught.
Yeah, we need three more humans.
I killed Lily already.
I already did it.
That's tower two.
Wait, where the fuck's tower three?
Tower three is a volcano.
I'm gonna leave here.
I don't wanna fight these people.
I'm gonna die.
I guess so.
Yeah, tower two was Lily.
Okay.
We need three more humans and we're good.
Okay, yeah.
I have three.
That's fine.
I'll head over there.
It's being raided.
I just kinda left.
Wait.
If it's raided, then they could destroy the human pen.
Oh.
Well, I can't fight all of them.
Oh no.
Okay.
I'm almost done.
A little pause.
Oh no.
I saw maybe if I left, they just wouldn't be interested in you.
Let's go!
Catch it!
So the four...
Oh my goodness.
That's a hundred points if you catch it.
I can't defend the base.
They're destroying the pail box.
I don't really know what to do.
There's like literally 20 of them.
If you just leave, they don't attack.
Yeah, just leave.
Just leave.
I got it!
Let's go!
Clip!
They're chasing me.
Just teleport away.
I got too far away from the pail box, so I'm just gonna fly away now.
Ah!
Fuck!
Alright, I'm dead.
Well, you know what?
It's fine.
Clip!
I got Botan!
Alright.
Okay.
They all left our base, it looks like.
I'm gonna head over and put the...
I need to find a fast travel.
Yeah, I need to find a fast travel right now.
Awesome!
And then I can do it.
Yeah, and then just clip it while you're there.
Let's see...
Stupid!
Brr!
Alright.
Submit already!
Be caught!
Are you still catching the lucky pow or just regular pow?
I got the lucky pow.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, oh no.
No, no.
PP Mod is clipping and submitting my stuff.
I think so.
PP Mod submitted mine too!
Thank you, PP Mods!
We're in fourth place!
I know where that last dungeon is.
I'm pretty sure.
Do we think we can get it done in ten minutes?
If you can find the dungeon and build the base in time.
I know where it is.
I'm pretty sure.
How many points is that dungeon?
That dungeon is...
880.
880 points.
180.
Oh, never mind.
It's blocked off where it usually...
I think it is.
False alarm.
Alright.
I am heading back right now.
It's the ten minute mark so we should...
Why are you doing tower three right now, Shurfer?
What are you doing?
Well, I have to go get to it.
I'm either gonna do tower three or the other bosses.
Which is better points?
Well, bosses is like 70 and 65.
Tower three is a hundred and... Oh my gosh.
I don't wanna...
I'm trying to hit...
It's 150.
But the thing is, if I kill the bosses, I know I get level ups.
But you're 100% sure you get XP from tower bosses?
I'm... Because I'm really close to 50.
Well, if it's faster to do...
Level 50 pal is 120 points.
Then do the hard bosses then.
Because then you can...
Yeah, just do the hard bosses.
I'm gonna head over back now and put the human...
Okay, I'm taking a look at my list.
Uhh...
Forget what the tower even is.
Let me see what I can do.
Yeah, just do bosses.
I'm gonna head over and trying to get to the base.
Oh no, my Van Worm's starving.
Fuck.
Okay, I think...
Yeah, let me check my registered Pokemon.
Do you guys have food at the base?
Because I really need food.
We need 200 more points for third place.
Well, we're gonna get some...
Here, check the cooler.
We're just gonna put a bunch of food in there.
We're about to hit a bunch of free points from me hitting 50, butchering the chickpeas, and human food.
Okay, I am heading...
Which base?
Cooler, normal base, but...
Yeah, I'm putting humans.
How do I put the humans in?
You walk up to it and hit X.
Okay, umm...
How many do they need?
1, 2, 3...
I'm so close to my 40 pal's, man.
Okay, I'm putting more than 3.
They're all gonna be in there.
Clip, clip, clip!
There's definitely more than 20 now!
On my end!
Clip, clip, clip!
Viewing cage!
My team is starving.
Alright.
We're so hungry.
I'm too busy clipping, but they're so hungry.
Let me see LiftMonks if I can get anything on that, but I don't think so.
Sure, you can be back by 3 minutes if you can.
So we can do the chickpea.
How much time we got?
Well, I just died to like a bug or some shit, so I'm here.
Oh, okay, let's do chickpea now.
Okay.
I need the butcher knife.
Wait, what is LiftMonk?
I really need to get back and fucking try and get that shit back.
Nah, there's no way I'm gonna get that.
Okay, okay, let's get the... I'm getting the butcher knife.
Give me the butcher knife real quick and then I'll do it.
I can make butcher knives.
Yeah, just give me one, I'll do it real quick, and then I need to try and kill that boss.
Okay.
I'll make four butcher knives.
I'll make one so that one has to be free.
I'm getting the chicken in my pal box right now.
I'm making two.
I have a chicken in my pal box.
Meat cleavers.
Do we have to do it all at the same time?
Let me see.
Where is it?
I think so.
We should all get together then.
Okay.
Meat cleaver.
We all have to do it at the same time.
In the...
The barrel?
I'm going to do this fast because I need to go get my shit.
Barrel, barrel, put in barrel.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Okay, there we go.
Cleaver and barrel.
Someone get the other.
I'm going downstairs.
Let's all go downstairs when you're ready.
Cleaver and barrel.
I'm trying to...
Let me know when you guys are ready.
I gotta get a chicken.
Can I have your fire armor after this?
Yeah, I can give you my fire armor.
Fire armor, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I got a chicken.
How do I cleave them?
Put it in your inventory.
And then four in butcher.
Yeah, ready?
Wait, I have it in my inventory but I don't have a butcher option.
You have to be holding it.
Yeah, hold it, hold it.
Wait, hold it?
I can't hold it.
You drag the butcher knife into your weapon.
Put it in your weapon slot.
Time is of the essence.
I need to get level 50.
Put it in the weapon slot.
What do you mean?
You just dragged it there.
Take away one of the items.
You guys are bugged.
Give me your armor.
Yeah, I'm bugged.
Okay, I guess we're...
They're bugged or some shit.
Guess we're not butchering the chicken.
You guys are bugged.
You have to re-log.
Just re-log.
And then surefour do his thing.
Just re-log, re-log.
There's no other way to explain it other than just put it in your weapon slot.
That's the only way we can win.
That's literally all you do.
What do you mean?
We're your pickaxe?
You're literally bugged.
You have to re-log.
Okay, I'm joining.
We catch your four ready left.
What the fuck?
You guys are taking two damn logs.
He can get like four achievements done right now.
So we're letting him do his thing.
Wheel the knife, drag it over your pickaxe.
I'm drunk.
Just throw your pickaxe away.
You have to re-log at the same time?
Yes, it does.
Yeah.
The screenshot is all four of them.
It's working now.
Just re-log.
You guys just have to wait a bit.
You have to wait for it.
I'm going to upgrade.
Go get the human thing while I'm...
I did.
I did the human already.
How did you make it work?
I just re-logged.
Just re-log.
You still haven't re-logged?
What do you mean?
Put it in your weapon slot.
Re-log!
I did!
I'm here!
What do I do?
The slot you're holding the crossbow in, just drag the butcher knife in there instead.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What do you mean, oh?
No shot.
We gotta wait.
We're just waiting for sure for him to do his thing.
I have it.
I got the butcher.
I got it.
I have it.
Is there no way I have to catch pals to register?
You can't drop at all?
I'm missing two pals, man.
Two.
Okay, wait, I've got it.
It's there.
It's not working anymore.
I got it.
I have also a pp mod.
Yeah, pp mod.
Clip, clip, clip.
I have 355 registered.
I have 55 registered.
I get what you mean now.
I was trying to put it in my actual...
I meant the butcher knife.
I was trying to put the chicken in my fucking weapon slot.
No fucking way you're thinking that, Brenn.
What?
How the fuck do you put him in the weapon slot?
Okay, okay.
We just wait.
He's just gonna do his thing.
Pp mod.
Clip my...
Clip, clip, clip.
Registered.
55.
Clip, clip, clip.
If I steal...
Holy shit.
Can you make another butcher knife in case I die again?
Yeah, yeah.
We have three minutes here for it.
Do you think you can get through it in three minutes?
Maybe.
Lily, how many pals do you have registered?
38.
I'm a thing to lose.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Lily, uh...
You should probably...
All you need is...
What?
Two more?
Two...
Take this money.
I'm gonna drop this money.
I'm gonna kill myself after I get this guy.
Okay.
I'm gonna make another butcher knife for you just in case.
He's in the cage.
I'm gonna need one if I'm killing myself.
But, yeah.
But if you can, go to the Anubis base and just buy two pals.
I'll manage, I'll manage, I'll manage.
Either that or go to the regular...
Go to the regular...
Actually, regular would be faster.
Just go to the regular village.
Alright, just go to the regular village.
Alright.
Doesn't matter.
There... Oh god.
Jesus.
Alright, I'm throwing pokeballs at him now.
Alright.
Two minutes.
I'm gonna get this sure for...
I believe in you.
Jesus.
No fucking shot.
Did you get it?
I don't think that sounds like something...
Last ball.
Oh, bullshit.
I guess I just have to kill him then.
Do we get...
We don't get points for killing him though.
We do.
Oh, we do?
Okay.
I mean, I think so.
I think they made a new rule for that.
I have enough money to buy everything!
Yay!
I don't have enough money.
I have money.
I can give her some.
Okay, go, go, go.
Drop money.
I'm going over there.
How do I sell...
You guys need to show a pal that I got it.
It's right there.
What did he go?
I dropped it.
I dropped it in front of you.
Where is the mucketeer?
Right here in front of you.
Where's the butcher knife?
Right in front of you.
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
We have one minute.
I'm so close to level 50.
I'm ready to butcher.
Where's the knife?
I'm here.
I'm coming over to give it to you.
I have to travel back to...
Lily here.
One minute.
Let's go.
Alright.
Okay.
Lily, you gotta come back.
We gotta go downstairs and butcher this fucking chicken.
Finally.
Alright, I'm downstairs.
Let's go.
Alright, here we go.
3, 2, 1.
Go, butcher!
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip, clip!
Let's play!
Alright, there we go.
Alright, got it.
We got it.
Show your context.
It's right there.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Lily, show your context.
You have one minute to get to level 50.
Let's go.
40 registered.
Alright.
How the fuck am I gonna get to level 50?
What can you do in one minute or 30 seconds?
36 seconds.
I can kill a boss.
Okay, I don't think we can get that in 30 seconds.
I just need to kill like a semi-high level boss.
I don't think...
I need armor and shit.
He has 26 seconds here.
Here's some pelt armor.
Kill a noobist in 26 seconds.
I don't think he can.
Also, I don't think anybody got this, but check your lift monks as well.
No, but zero.
I don't think we got this.
Yeah, I have none.
I got to four, but not enough.
Shurper, did you show your pelt deck?
Uh... I'm trying to get level 50 first.
We still have time.
We still have the five minutes.
We still have the five minutes after we can do that.
I'm reporting.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
You can report your pelt deck during that.
It's ding ding ding!
Your statue!
Ding ding ding!
Wait, actually, no, never mind.
Is it over?
It's over.
It's ding ding ding!
Ding ding ding!
We were so close to 50.
If only I had more balls, man!
I would have had it!
I'm sorry, man.
I'm sorry.
Check your pelt deck.
Pelt deck time.
I showed mine.
Show your deck.
Ding ding ding!
I already did before, but here.
Pelt deck.
That was clutch getting a little into the 40.
Let's go.
I mean, am I allowed to use the statue to see how many lift monk I went to?
We have to get to, like, five.
I'm not at five for ten points.
I'm at four.
Yeah.
I mean, if I'm allowed to enhance.
Yeah, I think so.
Right?
For reporting?
Yeah, you should be fine.
Yeah, it's just reporting.
I'm at three, actually.
I'm at four.
Yeah, nothing to report.
None of us are at five.
Five is where there's points.
Yeah, five is where it starts.
I have 71 registered pals.
71 showed.
Clip, clip, clip.
Mine's 40.
Already clipped.
Clip, clip, clip.
Fourth tied for third.
We're tied for third.
55.
Clip, clip, clip.
They're still tallying, though, so we could get pushed down.
Yeah, that's true.
You know what, though?
We did really good.
We did pretty well.
We did pretty fucking good.
We did pretty good.
We almost got 120, man.
We almost got 120, man!
Level 50 in eight hours, though?
That's kinda crazy.
We almost got it.
If somebody could've put the fuck out of the function.
I would've gotten 70 points for Blasamit, but it failed the second thing, and then I would've gotten the level 50 for 120.
Yeah, I'm checking what other stuff we can...
RNGs is not with me.
Yeah, our RNG was pretty fucking bad.
And I had to use the legendary balls in the black market.
We just had...
The black market appears to be worth it, because 180 points, so...
Alright.
71... did you...
Okay, I'm trying to check if they did all of this.
And Lily got hers, too.
Wait, Lily got 40.
It says 38, though.
Lily got 40?
Yeah.
Peepee, do the new one, because that says 38.
New register, 48.
40.
High five, Lily.
Oh my god, Lily, we did it!
We clutched!
We just threw money at you, like, The last five minutes, we were just screaming at each other.
We were throwing money at me and screaming at me.
It didn't show the butcher thing, so I restarted, but then you guys were like, put it in the slot!
I was like, how the fuck do you put them in the weapon slot?
I died to a fucking bug, man.
I would have been 50 if not for the bug.
You died to a fucking bug!
Your lucky stats, man!
Your luck stats!
Let me see if I can find the clip of how I fucking died.
Just be like, compensation points, please.
Yeah, like, I would have gotten 50 if not for that shit.
On God.
It's actually wild.
That was crazy.
You should have checked your balls, man.
Dude, what does this have to do with balls?
You ran out of balls!
You know the house rule!
You check your balls before you leave!
Oh yeah, we should log out.
Oh, pp mod, pp mod.
40, 40.
You didn't give her...
check the registered 40.
Wait, technically...
Tell Lily to show dex.
Does the level sync matter with pals?
Because technically my pals are level 50.
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
That works, that works!
Report, report!
Oh fuck yeah!
Take a photo, take a photo!
It just has to be not level 50.
I had the dex open for so long!
Open dex.
Okay, hold up.
Show the level 40, because we still have...
Yeah, we still have one minute.
pp mod, please.
We also need the clip of...
Sureforce, level 50.
Yeah, I'm just looking at it.
Sureforce, okay.
I will fucking go over there and look at it.
pp mod, keep it open.
I'll screenshot myself.
Thank you so much.
Please clip.
Wait, no, that's level 40.
Oh wait, level sync.
Level 50.
Level 50 is sureforce.
50 is sureforce pet.
Pal is level 50, kinda, is the name of the clip.
Oh, oh, oh.
No, get rid of that!
They're not gonna watch the clip anyway.
Just get rid of it.
Call it, pal is level 50.
So fucking giga chad.
The chad is fucking pal.
It's calz!
Log out, log out.
I'm logging out.
Logging out, logging out.
Logging out.
Holy shit.
That was like...
the most stressful last five minutes.
That was so stressful.
Holy shit.
Bro.
Dude, we did so good.
We did so good though.
Okay, watch this clip and explain to me how I died.
Okay, I'm watching.
I need to know now.
I'll put the clip in the chat.
I put it in the team Doki Bird.
Is it...
I was like, what?
Han, I'll pull up the clip for chat in a second.
What?
Wait, yeah, what the fuck killed you?
I don't know!
That's what I'm confused about.
Huh?
Okay, I'm trying to give you the clip.
Wait, wait, what killed you?
Wait, were you on fire maybe and it didn't register?
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm off.
But fire damage doesn't tick that fast for all of my health.
Yeah, that was really fast.
Like the fire damage.
Yeah.
Oh shit, I'm still in non-miss mode, guys.
Give me a sec.
Here, I'll show chat.
I have an on mode on so people don't track you down where I'm looking at.
Why is she in the chat?
There you go.
There it is.
I'm just dying.
He just fucking collapses.
Just fucking dies.
Yeah, he just collapses.
It's like the dead lolomote.
He's in the background.
He's like, huh?
Holy fuck.
I'm gonna check the rankings right now.
That was so fucking stressful.
Holy shit.
That was actually so stressful.
You know what though?
Trust the process, right?
We said it was gonna be slow at the start and big gains at the end.
Oh my god.
That was way too stressful.
Not gonna lie.
We said trust the process.
Trust the process.
We would have been so much better if people just trusted in the stressors.
Yeah, that's true.
Or I'm a process.
We trusted in the stressors the whole time.
That's right.
We trusted so hard.
We trusted so fucking hard.
Trustga.
Oh my god.
It's so close.
Third and fourth place is so close.
Bro.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna pull this over.
Third place for zero...
What's the word?
Setup?
We didn't setup anything.
We didn't fall deep yet.
We just must have planned.
You didn't even level 50.
They didn't count it.
It says level 50, man.
It says level 50.
It says level 50, pal.
No.
It says the pal has to be level 50.
Nothing says it's connected to player level.
Instructions.
Exactly.
Unclear.
Okay.
What about my bug dying randomly, admin?
It says pal level 50.
It's not our fault.
Turf was too weak for his pal.
Weak?
It says pal level 50.
It's not our fault his pal isn't up.
It's an up.
Up section.
Admin.
Oh, we got a second.
We got an at.
Objection.
There we go.
It doesn't change our placements.
It doesn't change our placements at all.
Wait, does it not?
It doesn't.
Wait, how many points is the level?
Wait, no, it does.
We would be second.
No, no, no.
If it does, we're third because they...
They just went in front of us.
Yeah, we would be third.
Yeah, yeah.
This does matter.
This is technicalities right now.
If we get it, we are third.
It literally says pal level 30.
Nothing says... it's corresponding.
It has to be...
Exactly.
Yeah, we're the people admin hate.
Feels good.
No, right now.
Objection, actually.
Ryan Higa's team is like...
20 points ahead of us.
So we need that point.
We need it.
We really need it.
Come on.
Bro.
Bro, come on.
Count it.
There's no mention of player level 50.
That's a whole different achievement.
That's a different achievement for a reason.
That's a different achievement.
If they wanted it to be pal and trainer, they would have clarified in the rules.
But they didn't.
It would have been one achievement for more points.
But they split the achievement.
Objection!
Yeah!
Take him the coin, Lily!
I'll take him the fucking coin!
Give us those 20 points!
I'll point fingers and scream.
And they will take me serious.
At this point, we lost...
We lost the sure fortune to two bugs.
They should give us... No, no, no.
Actually, actually, what do we do about...
Three bugs, technically.
Yeah, what do we do about the fangalope when I went to a new bug?
Yeah, three bugs.
Yeah, we had three bugs.
Come on!
Dude, why am I constantly getting fucked?
At least someone's getting it.
Whoa!
God, I fucking wish.
Wild.
Level 50 or bust!
Give it to us!
Come on!
He's a coward.
The mod's not coming over.
He doesn't want to fight us.
He's like the Karens in the Dokibird chat.
Need to be left alone.
Give us those 20 points!
We want those 20 points!
I'm not asking anymore.
We're demanding right now.
It's a demand.
Demand.
Would you like to return to your wife and kids safely today?
Oooh.
Bro, they're not giving it to us.
Oh my god, they're ignoring us!
What?
Okay.
Let's...I told you, man!
Someone add dead person be like question mark whrend Ask Dan Clancy for a review.
I'll bring it up Monday.
I'll bring it up at the dinner.
I'll be like that!
I didn't get my third place at the rivals!
That's money.
That is money right there that we deserve.
We deserve it!
Oh, wait, wait, they're typing!
They're typing!
Come on!
We deserve it!
Give us the points!
Look, I'm a Vtuber, I can't read, but I can read the word pal, and that's all it said.
They stopped typing!
They stopped typing?!
They're ghosting us.
Put your fucking balls down!
Typing again!
Typing, typing, typing!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Where is it?
Come on!
We don't care!
You can give the others that point too!
We deserve it!
Everybody deserves those points!
Come on!
No!
Yeah, but that's a red number!
That doesn't matter!
It doesn't... yeah, but it doesn't mention cap!
It doesn't!
It doesn't cap!
So what?
Nothing mentions cap!
Nothing mentions... we have a separate achievement for player level!
What's the point then?
What the fuck's the point?!
Yeah, what the fuck's the point?!
We're being robbed.
We're being robbed right now.
We're being such huge carrots at the moment.
That's our third place.
That's our third place right there.
Level 50.
It's a dire wolf!
There was no way we captured a level 50 dire wolf!
We love wood and ferrets!
Show me a level 50 dire wolf and I'll show you a god!
There is no such thing!
Scum-O's peppy hands.
We've been scum-O'sed.
Unbelievable.
If you don't make the rules proper, we deserve the points.
That is a mistake for next time that has to be fixed.
Unbelievable.
They did count the pack 20 humans, right?
They did.
They should have.
I think half points at least is a good compensation.
Oh my god.
At least half.
At least half for when my fangalope was gone.
I put a woo at the end so they can't get mad at me.
It's internet girl magic.
Can we get partial points for when...
I just got fangaloped.
I just know a freaking idea.
Oh my god.
I just learned how to read but it doesn't say cap.
So...
Oh no.
Oh.
All caps so they know I'm serious.
I like how fangaloped isn't cap because he googled the name.
Because I copied and pasted it from the Google Doc.
Can we get partial points for when...
Fangaloped.
So they know I'm serious.
So sure if I wrote...
Oh my god.
Half points please because...
Fangaloped.
I'm choking.
Bro.
Give us those points.
Wait did we get a...
Did we get a...
Close.
We got a clip of the kill.
Okay we did.
Yeah.
Yeah we got a clip of the kill probably.
We should have.
I screwed up.
I should have been there.
Yeah and then I walked up to Anubis and he was bugged and then I had to kill him later.
Guys we're not third.
Everything's against me.
We're fourth right now.
That's why we're trying so hard to get these extra points.
Come on.
Because if we get the extra points we would be third.
No we're fourth.
We literally need twenty more points.
No.
Oh my god.
It's not about the money.
It's top three.
It's the principle.
You wouldn't understand.
You don't understand guys.
Because top three... third and fourth place...
Damn Daniel.
Gets the same amount of money.
They get the same amount of money.
I'm not able to put PAL Tournament champion top three in my file for at least a week.
I need that on my Twitter profile.
Yes!
We can... you know what?
You know what guys?
We'll just put top three with an asterisk next to it.
That's twenty points right there.
That's twenty points.
That clip is twenty points.
Top three asterisk?
Yeah sorry chat.
They're still tallying.
So yeah it's a little...
I like the clip.
Where?
Wait.
He's not there.
Can I just say sure for?
I don't know who's making the clip.
I'm not making your clips but they're very sassy.
Those are mine.
They have like the sassiest clips.
Those are me.
You're making them yourself?
You are sassy.
Yeah look it says clipped by.
You're sassy.
I am sassy.
I told you I've contained myself.
I'm like the straight man.
Dang.
Guys it's not about the money.
Third and fourth get the same amount of money.
Okay.
Ryan Higgins team got more points.
I don't think we can count them.
Oh they got more points.
Oh no no we can if we get the...
No no no no.
If we get the partial points we...
Trust the process.
How are they still getting more points?
Wait how the fuck are they still getting more points?
The report is over.
I want to know how team Garrick is six after they were first from day one.
They did all...
No because they did all the global.
Oh yeah.
They did all the global stuff in the day one.
Day one.
They didn't have a good foundation.
They didn't have a global...
They didn't have a process.
They have to be trusted.
We actually...
We actually got the second most day two achievement points.
Let's go.
Whoa.
We just didn't get lucky pals.
I spent like six hours making that document yesterday.
I like...
Okay can someone tell me how Zentrea's team got zero day two achievement points?
Oh they left...
They forfeited day two.
Yeah.
Yeah because like...
What the fuck?
One of your teammates couldn't do day two so they forfeited.
Oh.
Why didn't they just send a new person?
I don't know.
I guess like it's so last minute.
Maybe because like is Iron Mouse the host of the world?
That could have been it.
Wait.
Wait they're typing.
They're typing now.
They're typing.
They're just like shut up.
They're like never invite team Doki again.
I'll be Tornado.
Flesh man.
Stupid trash.
Why am I only judged by my flesh?
You've...
You're just like this fucking flesh tuber.
He must be inciting them to revive.
Why can't they be saying these fucking pixels?
You're the one.
Shut up UwU.
You're the one who's like can we get partial points for when...
Fangaloo.
What the fuck?
Okay let me scroll up and see all the pictures you guys posted.
And the objection.
Wait I'm gonna take a photo of the whole...
I love this.
I'm just curious what they're gonna say.
Oh my god.
This is great.
Well apparently Overwatch is on top because Flats and Seagull were on...
Team Average Jonas' team.
Oh shit.
Yo go Overwatch too.
There we go.
What the fuck were they doing?
I like how they stopped typing.
Going Giga mode apparently.
Holy.
They probably did all...
They probably did all of those ones where you kill bosses with like the unique weapons.
I don't know.
No they did lucky pals.
They literally have 10 lucky pals.
What?
No but they have...
They have...
They have almost 2000 global achievements.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
We only have 1600.
That's fine.
We had...
That's aight.
I can't believe it.
It's like this is mentioned on broadcast as well.
How will we be watching the broadcast?
We're playing.
What the fuck do I think I'm doing?
It's like...
I think it says it's mentioned on broadcast.
And I'm just like we're playing.
How do we know?
Guys, guys, can you shut the fuck up?
I'm trying to watch the broadcast.
Guys, please.
Silence.
He a dire wolf though.
Come on.
He is a dire wolf.
Okay.
It's fine.
We got top five.
I can't believe it though.
You mean top four.
Top four.
The goal was top five but with third.
It's so close.
Yeah.
It hurts.
That's not really funny that surefour's luck.
Surefour definitely has zero luck.
If I just wasn't fucking unlucky.
Yeah.
Surefour is actually zero luck.
If he wasn't lucky, we would have been top three.
Holy shit.
That's actually crazy.
Yeah.
We're fucking top four.
No.
It's not good enough.
It doesn't have the same ring as top three.
What the heck?
I know.
It doesn't sound good.
It doesn't sound as good on the Twitter profile.
How am I supposed to drag the fourth place on my Twitter profile?
Come on, man.
My new title is top three asterisks if it wasn't for that damn fangalope glitch.
It's okay.
We're top three in your hearts, right chat?
In your hearts, we're top three.
Right chat.
Come on.
Type one of the top three.
Okay.
I'm going to put top three.
I'm going to tweet out top three.
I can't believe we got top three in the power of the tribals.
Yeah.
There we go.
My chat is saying no.
Yeah.
You're not probably.
Your chat doesn't believe in you.
Nobody asked.
They're saying last place in my heart.
Oh, last place in your heart.
Oh no.
Oh my God.
I can't believe.
You know what?
I'm proud of us though.
We went from top 10 to top three.
Crazy.
Started from the bottom.
Now we're here.
We would have been top.
We were top two easily.
But fundamentals, man.
If surefork didn't get bugged like 500 times.
We should get extra points from me having to figure out a new strat during the first half yesterday because of ping.
Oh, my God.
That's a couple of pity points to get to top three easily.
Well, you are kind of asking for it.
Yeah.
We just didn't have an East Coast.
You are kind of asking for it.
We just didn't have an East Coast person here, unfortunately.
Well, I'll just host next time.
It's okay.
Yeah.
Next time we'll play.
No, thank you.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
No, thank you.
What the heck, guys?
I'm an FPS guy.
Ping is all that matters to me.
Mom said it's my turn on the host box.
Denied.
No, move to NA for one day.
Come to NA for Twitch Rivals.
I'll just play out real quick spontaneously.
Yeah, just fly out for like two days and then go do a PC ping.
I'm not going to let the person that just found out they were on a 60 hertz monitor host my game.
You know.
He's not right.
No, I don't agree with him.
What the heck.
He's not right.
I don't think.
You're the type of the fleshy.
I'm a hybrid of everything.
A hybrid?
No.
The 60 hertz is going to follow me for a hot second.
It's clipped forever, Lily.
It's there forever.
Hey, GG, you guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
Amazing.
Seriously, amazing.
Thank you.
When we screamed at each other.
The last three minutes.
Oh, that's what you meant.
I don't put the chicken in the weapon slot?
What do you mean?
The chicken in the weapon slot.
I can't believe it.
Those 30 seconds actually.
Those 30 seconds actually ruined Sheriforce's luck.
His luck went to negative.
I'm sorry.
I was on the second tick from catching it.
And it fucking didn't capture me.
Well, if it hadn't bugged, it wouldn't have been an issue.
Because I was literally on the emote wheel.
Being like, where's the butcher one?
It's supposed to be here, right?
And then I got hurt with confusion.
I was like, what do you mean?
Put the chicken in the weapon slot.
I was like, LOCK UP!
LOCK THE FUCK UP!
What do you mean put the chicken in the weapon slot?
I can't.
It's cheat cheese everyone.
I'm so happy you guys were all on my team.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for being good.
It was really cool.
It was so fun.
Thank you guys for joining the team.
It was great.
What was the fucking rap song?
I'm not a big fan of the government rap.
Chat, chat.
I can't figure out what the acronym is for that.
I'm not a big fan of all those letters.
I'm dyslexic.
What are those letters?
I'm not a big fan of the government.
See you had to type that in too.
I'm not stupid.
What?
NBF Vapnibofager.
Vapnibofager.
Team Vapnibofager.
Let's go.
Hey GG's guys.
I hope we meet again in a tribal.
See you when I see you.
I'll see you guys later.
I'm going to go talk to my chat now.
GG's guys.
Wait, are we confirmed?
We're confirmed for if we're confirmed.
I think so.
They're like, you're third in my heart.
If you're not first, you're last.
We were never going to get first or fourth.
We're fucking last.
Losers.
GG's guys.
I'll see you.
See you.
Bye.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
My first Twitch Rivals.
That's dopey.
We got top three.
It was top three guys.
I can't believe it everyone.
Top fucking three.
Plus one.
Holy shit.
That was so fun.
I still can't believe it.
The last three minutes we were just screaming at each other.
We were just like, guys.
Please.
And sureforye was just yelling at PP.
Like, log out.
Log out for the love of god.
Just log out.
The fucking chicken.
The chicken that fucking.
I'm going to go to bed.
He fucked us all.
Oh my god.
We got hard fucked over by the chicken.
Of all things.
That motherfucking chicken.
I got the chicken in the weapon slot.
Holy shit.
That was so fucking funny though.
Oh my god.
I swear.
I need to look at this.
How many points did the chicken even get us?
It was only 50.
Oh my god.
The chicken was only 50.
If we just let sureforye do his thing.
We would never have to do the chicken.
Oh my god.
So much stress for 50 points.
Holy shit.
Guys.
Oh my god.
It's like 2020.
We were throwing for content.
The make it or break it.
Anyway guys.
I had so much fun.
We had a lot of fun watching.
The content was worth it.
That's true.
If it wasn't for that.
We wouldn't have got the.
We wouldn't have got sureforye's fucking.
Can we get partial points for when.
I have got that.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Anyway guys.
For those who are wondering if there's going to be vods.
I will be uploading vods of this.
In like one to two days.
I don't know.
Two to three days.
Depending on how I feel.
But we do have a vods channel now.
So do not worry for those who are wondering.
We will be uploading the vods for this.
At a later time.
Because I just made my vods channel.
I think it's called Doki Bird Vods or some shit.
But yes.
Anyway everybody.
I hope you guys.
Had a great time.
With us today.
I'm really happy with my team.
With Peepee, Chalili, and Surefour.
It was a great team.
Where we all.
I was so worried.
Because I was like oh my god.
I'm the only one getting points at first.
I was so worried.
But then the moment we were able to like.
Have everything like structured.
The moment we got everything we need.
We just sped run so fucking hard.
On like so many different achievements.
In the last hour.
It was actually crazy.
The last hour we were just going bam bam bam bam bam.
On the achievements.
We just needed to trust the process.
Just trust this process.
Just setting everything up.
Oh my god.
But yeah thank you guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you all for all the subs.
All the gifted subs.
All the raids.
All the bitties and all the follows.
If you guys are new here.
I usually stream on the YouTube.
So please check me out on YouTube.
Exclamation point YouTube.
Because I usually stream over there.
I'm gonna be doing part 3 of Batman tomorrow.
And check me on Twitter.
Because usually when I do stream on Twitch.
I would post updates on my Twitter.
And merch supports me a lot as well.
So thank you everybody.
I'm gonna call it here everyone.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.